So, hallo Leute, auf geht's, ähm, ich, warum gehen meine Corona-E-Modes nicht, haben die, ich glaub, die haben die Corona-E-Modes entfernt, kann das sein, ich hab gestern, ich hab gestern drei, die gehen, echt, gehen die bei euch, weil bei mir im Browser gehen die nicht,
stimmt, ich seh's in meiner Vorschau, in meiner Vorschau gehen die nicht, aber Leute, Chat, ich seh euch jetzt mal kurz nicht, ich refreshe mal, Twitch-Chat unbeobachtet lassen ist gefährlich, ich weiß, ach jetzt, ah, excellent, jetzt funktioniert's, weiß auch nicht, was da gewesen ist,
ich hab mir so gedacht, aus aktuellem Anlass müssen wir mal da ein paar, ähm, so aktuelle Geschehen-E-Modes einfügen.
Wie sieht's eigentlich mit Corona in Hessen aus, hab ich jetzt gar nicht mehr, Corona-Hessen, gibt's da was Neues, News, oh, Frankfurt, oje, Leute, muss morgen wieder nach Frankfurt, oje, RIP, Alter, RIP, F, ajajo, aber, äh, Stripes 007, acht Monate, hüsch, schreib.
Frage an den Chat, funktioniert, oje.
Origins bei euch, äh, kann ich jetzt nicht ausprobieren, oje, Corona in Hessen, Frankfurt, oje, Frankfurt, zeig's mal her, was ist in Frankfurt los, Frankfurt, Leute, hab ich euch schon gesagt, ich hab's ja, ich hab's ja auf Twitter und im Discord geschrieben, ich hatte vorgestern, oder gestern, die Nacht, die Nacht auf gestern, hatte ich die ganze Nacht einen extrem trockenen Hals, äh, ähm, ähm,
das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens,
das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens, das ist ja meistens, so die Vorstufe von, ja, Easykiller5moder, dankeschön, iiqchat wieder, also, zeig's mal her, um 23.45 kam das gestern, ähm, erhelfen, das handelt sich um drei Männer aus Frankfurt, aha, okay, die waren irgendwie zusammen mit einem in Italien, na, wunderbar, das beruhigt mich jetzt natürlich wahnsinnig, ähm, aber, Leute, ich, ich, ist ja kein Problem mehr, weil ich hab ja ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein,
ne, und, ich hab's ja gestern auf Twitter gepostet, ich hab ja meine, ich hab ja mein Metro-Cosplay wieder rausge, rausge, ge, gekramt, wer Spiegelung vor mir sieht, kann sie behalten, irgendwo ist da bestimmt ne Spiegelung, hugemask, ja, ich, komm, wenn du schon sowas hast, ähm, wenn du schon sowas hast, dann kannst du jetzt immer wieder rauskramen, also, ihr seht, äh,
äh, ich, ich hab das Ding noch nicht verwendet, ist noch original verpackt, und die Filter sind gültig bis zum, bis, bis was, März 2024, also, die hält noch ein bisschen, aber ohne Aus, äh, was interessiert mich denn, ob ich Leute anstecke, Hauptsache, ich steck mich nicht selber an, bist du damit schon ein, nein, Quatsch, aber ich hab sie, ich hab mir die gar nicht für die Corona-Geschichte gekauft, ich hab die schon, also, nicht so lang, aber ich hab die schon ein bisschen,
ich weiß gar nicht, wann ich die gekauft habe, da müsste ich mal bei Amazon gucken, ich sag mal, also, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zwei Monate oder drei Monate, also, noch bevor das ganze Corona-Zeug angerückt ist, und mein Hauptgedanke dazu war, warum ich mir sowas gekauft habe, wenn man mal beispielsweise Schimmel wegmachen muss, oder irgendwelches andere Heimwerker-Zeug hat, sei es von, von irgendwie Staub, Feinstaub, Chemikalien, Schimmel, sonst was, dann ist es manchmal nicht verkehrt, wenn man das mal irgendwie ne Stunde machen muss, wenn man den Kram nicht grad einatmet.
So, ähm, aber jetzt, ne, das sind nämlich auch Filter, die gegen Viren helfen, zum Beispiel, sieht man nämlich hier dran, das sind, äh, wobei sieht man das überhaupt hier, das sind, ähm, P3R-Filter, und P3R ist, äh, da gibt es irgend so ein Ranking, was wie vor welchen Filtern schützt, und P3R, P3R-Filter, ähm, die, guck mal, man kriegt schon Virus mit,
ähm, ist, ist gegen, ist auch gegen Viren geeignet, ja, hab ich nochmal Glück, ich könnte die jetzt natürlich verkaufen, und wenn ich die jetzt verkaufe, kriege ich wahrscheinlich das Zehnfache von dem, was ich dafür ausgegeben habe, also die war nicht billig, die hat damals schon um die 200 Euro, oder, oder 150, irgendwie so, irgendwas zwischen 150 und 200 Euro gekostet,
also das ist jetzt kein, kein,
absolutes Billig-Ding, deswegen hoffe ich da, die ist, die ist made in UK, das ist auch keine China-Maske, oder so, also die ist, glaube ich, qualitativ ganz okay, ähm, glückliche Verfügung halt irgendwie, da ich so einen Teil schon hab, ne, weil wahrscheinlich kriegst du sowas gar nicht, oh, der Scam-Train ist am Start, Leute, huge, Heimwerkerzeug, ich dachte, du bist fertig mit deiner Bude, ja, man ist nie fertig, man ist nie fertig, vor allem nicht, wenn es um Automatisierung geht, und, und irgendwelche Sachen in der, in der Richtung, dann ist man nie fertig,
Pils-Schema, das passt ja gerade, wo ich gesagt habe, ich hab mir ne Maske gegen Schimmel gekauft, kommt der Pils, Pils-Schema Stufe 1, Dankeschön, für den nicht Prime-Sub, für den richtig echten Big-Prain-Real-Sub, ähm, kannst du dir jetzt auch mal Pirate Bay runterladen, ein Virenscanner, ja, bestimmt,
wachsen bald zu Atiom, ist Atiom nicht tot?
dabei, aber ich glaube, der ist am Ende vom ersten
Teil noch gestorben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das...
Egal, ich habe nur den ersten Teil gespielt.
Machete. Machete brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe immer noch meinen Speer an der Treppe liegen,
falls jemand einbricht.
Habe ich euch das Ding eigentlich schon mal gezeigt?
Nee, ich glaube... Doch, ich habe
mal ein Bild von ihm gezeigt im Stream.
Allerdings nicht von meinem, in Anführungsstrichen, Speer,
sondern von dem Teil, was neben der Treppe
liegt. Es ist ja kein
wirklicher Speer, den ich neben der Treppe
liegen habe. Ich habe
neben der Treppe, nur für den Fall,
der Fälle, dass man wirklich sich irgendjemand
zutritt, hier in die
Wohnung verschafft und irgendwas ist, man
besser vorgesorgt, als
hinterher doof aus der Wäsche geguckt.
Ich habe
von einem Zaun,
von einem alten Zaun,
gar nicht, wie sowas
heißt.
Ja, ungefähr sowas, plus, plus, nicht
so verziertes. Einfach
nur lang und spitz.
Einfach nur spitz,
also ohne, ohne
irgendwelche...
irgendwelche Sachen drauf.
Sowas hier in der Richtung habe ich,
habe ich, wo ich, gibt es da irgendwas
Schönes, was da, also ich habe
ohne, ohne Verzierung so ein Ding,
einfach nur, einfach, einfach nur
spitz und irgendwie so, so, keine Ahnung,
anderthalb Meter lang oder, oder was ist
das, eher zwei Meter lang.
Und, äh, wenn da einer
reinkommt, reinkommt und nix zu
suchen hat, geht's in your face.
Gehe so morgens mal auf die Arbeit.
Max, ernsthaft, bist du damit schon,
ach so, habe ich ja schon mal einkaufen
gegangen, nee, nee.
Bin ich nicht. Also ich muss, ich muss
eigentlich auch gar nicht einkaufen, weil
ich habe eh immer einen halben Schrank
voller Nudeln. Da ist genug da.
Ja, also wie sah es jetzt mit Corona in
Hessen aus? Es, es, es am Start.
Na gut. Dann versorg uns mal mit
YouTube-Videos dazu.
You've got to make it.
He, he, he, he, he.
Airflow 96.
Meine wahren Beweggründe
hatte der Sebaro gestern auf Twitter schon rausgekriegt.
Toxie, Twitch Prime,
vier Monate, huge sub.
Wenn man sich jetzt noch 20 Mal
verklickt. Dankeschön.
Der IQ des Chats steigt heute echt ins
Unermessliche, sehe ich schon.
Du hast ein Bayonett im Schlafzimmer.
Kann man, kann man alles machen.
Seitdem ich mir so ein, ein Multitool
auf Amazon gekauft habe,
so ein Ding
hier in der Richtung,
wenn man noch nicht genau weiß, was man für Werkzeug
braucht, ist sowas bestimmt nicht
schlecht, wenn man sowas dabei hat.
Also im Prinzip ist es so eine Art Taschenmesser.
Seitdem ich mir das bestellt habe, so, ich glaube,
das hier, weiß gar nicht genau.
Nee, meins hat ein bisschen größeres Messer.
Ich finde es jetzt nicht.
Seitdem empfiehlt mir Amazon
die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Waffen
und Äxte und
Tactical Equipment.
Dabei habe ich überhaupt keine Verwendung für.
Was soll ich mit einer taktischen Axt?
Tactical Tomahawk, genau.
Max wird zum Jäger.
Man weiß ja nie, man weiß ja nie,
was in nächster Zeit so passiert. Vielleicht muss ich mit der
Armbrust in den Wald gehen und
jagen, ja.
Eine Armbrust habe ich.
Jetzt habe ich auch das passende Multitool,
ja.
Da kann er jetzt in den Wald
stelzen gehen.
Ich habe wirklich einen Schrank, weil ich halt nicht
gern einkaufen gehe.
Ich habe einen Schrank, da liegen halt aktuell
keine Ahnung, was sind das?
So 20
Packen Nudeln oder so drinnen.
Die halten ja ewig.
Die Survival-Axt, stimmt.
Wer weiß jetzt? Weiß ja nicht, was alle so passieren.
Ich habe mich ja schon gefragt,
ob nicht heute von der Arbeit irgendwie eine Mail
kommt, dass die Leute,
dass den Leuten empfohlen wird,
die man soll, man soll am Montag
Homeoffice machen.
Der Witz ist ja, normalerweise, ihr wisst ja,
normalerweise gehe ich montags gar nicht
arbeiten. Trickshots, klar.
Also sollte ich, sollte ich
mit der Armbrust jagen gehen,
dann natürlich erschieße ich
nicht im Wald einfach irgendwelche Wildschweine oder so,
zum Essen, sondern mache erst mal den
360 Swiffer Scope davor.
Nur weil das Ding hat überhaupt keinen Scope.
Kann man denn dann machen,
wenn es keinen Scope hat?
Mail von der Uni kam schon, dass keiner kommen soll, oder?
Dann geht es aber ab.
In welchem Bundesland bist du?
Oin, Ramind,
Ramindgo?
Was fange man an?
Zeitschott mit Wurfwasser.
Ich muss, ich gucke gerade mal,
ich habe mein Handy nicht hier.
Sonst würde ich mal gucken, ob irgendwie auf der Arbeit einer
äh,
einen E-Mail geschrieben hat.
Ja, aber man sieht das, also bei mir in der Ecke ist es schon am Start.
Du hast ein Level 1 Hypetrain-E-Mode
erhalten. Der Scam-Train war erfolgreich,
Leute.
Doodle sind auch
easy zuzubereiten, ja.
Also das Einzige, wo ich echt gelitten habe bei mir
daheim ist, ähm, wenn da Strom
ausfällt.
Ich habe, ich habe, ich habe keinen Generator
oder irgendwie, was kostet denn sowas?
Keine Ahnung, Generator,
Benzin, was kostet denn sowas?
Ah,
der hält aber nicht lange.
Cute Chat ist am Start.
Kio, der Kio, Kio Kone
ist am Start. Der, der, der Cute
Tim Morgan.
Aus Interesse mal gucken.
Achso, in Düsseldorf, okay.
Düsseldorf ist ja in der Nähe von Köln und da ist ja überall
auch ganz viel, äh, Fasching angesagt gewesen.
Da haben sich die Leute wahrscheinlich
alle angesteckt.
Ich finde das auch so geil, ne?
Ähm, erst alle großartig Fasching
feiern und jetzt,
jetzt kommt halt raus, dass die meisten
Corona-Fälle halt sich an Fasching angesteckt haben.
Wo ich mir so gedacht habe, hm,
da hätte man ja auch gar nicht drauf kommen können,
dass auf so einer Veranstaltung, wo die Leute
alle auf einem Haufen sitzen, dass man
sich da anstecken kann.
Das ist absolut, das wäre im Vorfeld,
im Vorfeld hätte man sich das nicht
denken können.
Die, äh, Interlake Streammasters in Kato
spielen jetzt auch ohne Publikum, ja, ich weiß.
Das ist auch schon sehr merkwürdig,
wohl, ne, man, für die Spiele auch.
Aber mit was, komm, wir fangen,
wir fangen mit Battlefield an, wir fangen mit ein bisschen
Battlefield an, ähm,
so zum, zu, zu,
zum Einstimmen, ja.
Hast du Blackout gelesen oder
gehört? Ne, hab ich nicht.
Ja, so einen Major
ohne Publikum zu gewinnen ist schon
kacke. Also, einen Major zu
verlieren ist ohne Publikum auch kacke, aber, äh,
gerade wenn man
sich, ich mein, die Events sind jetzt,
also die Major sind, ist jetzt ja auch nicht jede Woche eins,
auch wenn CSGO so groß wie
nie ist. Also CSGO,
deswegen ist CSGO aktuell auch so
mein Lieblings-E-Spot, den ich gucke.
Ähm, du kannst eigentlich jedes Wochenende
einschalten, hast irgendein Turnier.
Jetzt zwar, äh, jetzt zwar kein riesen,
riesen Ding unbedingt,
aber du hast, also du hast ja unter der Woche schon
normale, normale Turniere, du hast in der,
am Wochenende meistens ein bisschen was Größeres
und ab und zu halt irgendwelche großen Sachen.
Ist kein CSGO-Major
mehr, aber trotzdem spielen wahrscheinlich die ganzen Leute
da, die ganzen großen Teams, aber
also das einzige CSGO-Turnier,
wo ich offline war,
war in, ähm,
in Köln,
in,
ist das die
Lanxess-Arena,
oder wie das Ding heißt?
Weiß gar nicht mehr genau, was das war, es war irgendeine ESL One,
ESL, ich hab doch da ein Video zu gemacht.
Ja,
ESL One Cologne,
genau,
das ist das einzige Turnier, wo ich mal offline
gewesen bin.
Ähm,
das war schon nice.
Das war schon nice.
Und das, das Beste an der ganzen Sache war ja,
dass wir von
Asus
eingeladen waren, das heißt, man konnte
auch, äh, entspannt oben sitzen
und zugucken.
Inklusive, inklusive Verpflegung, das war natürlich
huge, huge brain.
Das war schon ganz angenehm.
Ähm,
und das war mal cool mitzukriegen.
Ich, öfters, öfters müsste ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt auf irgendwelche offline Events,
weil, so cool das ist,
immer Atmosphäre und alles mitzukriegen,
wo ich sagen,
entspannender
und, und, äh,
irgendwie,
besser zuzugucken ist es daheim
vom Fernseher oder vom Rechner.
Aber meine Atmosphäre ist,
da kannst du nicht damit vergleichen, wie man
daheim sitzt, aber trotzdem.
Angenehmer zu gucken ist es von
daheim.
Ja, gestern war fast eine Million Spieler.
Ich weiß, ich hab's gestern gesehen hier.
Steam, Stats, CSGO,
ich hab's, oder vor zwei Tagen
war das, glaub ich, schon.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Mehr, mehr als Dota, mehr als Puppke.
Das ist noch nicht so lang.
Das ist noch nicht so lang. Also, ähm, ähm,
vor, vor einem Jahr sah das noch
ein bisschen anders aus.
CS hat, äh, ziemlich einen Aufschwung gehabt, wieder.
Gibt's, gibt's nicht mal Steam Stats?
Was ist denn die Seite?
Steam Stats hieß die doch, oder?
Oder bring ich das jetzt
durcheinander? Oder war Steam?
Steam Charts?
Ach, das da, ja, genau,
das mein ich. Ist das nicht früher Steam Stats?
Ja, die CS, die CS
Stongs gehen hoch.
Guckt euch das mal an, innerhalb von einem Jahr, die sind
wieder, oh ja, genau, vor einem Jahr
waren die noch ein bisschen weiter unten.
Aber allgemein muss man halt sagen,
ähm, ist das, ist CS
halt hier, ich weiß nicht, wo sie die Skins
und den ganzen Shit eingeführt haben,
aber ab da ist es wahrscheinlich hier so,
und ab da ist es halt,
Free-to-Play. Ist das jetzt Free-to-Play?
Ja, das kann, dann, dann
liegt das auf jeden Fall da dran, dass es Free-to-Play wurde.
Ähm, aber es ist halt heftig
zu sehen, auch wie viele Leute zugucken.
Ja. Skins waren seit Anfang
2014, na passt doch, hier, ab hier ist dann
Ui,
rauf. Ähm,
hier so in dem Dreh
hat man irgendwie so ein bisschen den Untergang
von CSGO vorausgesagt, und das hat
auch ein bisschen das Interesse nachgelassen.
Ähm, aber spielerzahlenmäßig, äh,
war der Eindruck halt falsch, ne?
Hier ging es ein bisschen runter, aber ab da,
ich weiß nicht, ab wann Free-to-Play,
ab wann das Free-to-Play geworden ist.
Ab wann ist das Free-to-Play geworden?
Wisst ihr das?
Mitte 2019
irgendwann, ne?
Also wahrscheinlich hier so. Wahrscheinlich
hier so, wo es wieder direkt hochgegangen ist.
Wahrscheinlich hier. Hier war es so dumm.
Hier haben sie bestimmt Handschuhe, hier kamen bestimmt
die Handschuhe oder irgendwie sowas, wo die Leute
ja voll drauf abgehen.
Cosmetics ist so ein Ding, ähm,
mit mir wird's
die Faszination von Cosmetics
im Game nie, werde ich nie so hundertprozentig
nachvollziehen können. Ich meine, ich habe in Overwatch
auch Skins gesammelt, und manche Sachen,
in Path of Exile habe ich mir auch ein paar Sachen gekauft, aber
in Path of Exile habe ich mir hauptsächlich
ein paar Skins gekauft, weil
die Default-Rüstung und die Default-Charaktere
und so, die sehen halt richtig scheiße aus.
Ja, der Battle-Royale,
der Sack, ne.
Na, zumindest seitdem ist halt wieder voll abgegangen
hier. Und jetzt
ist wieder ein bisschen gedroppt,
warum auch immer.
Achso, das ist der Monat, ja gut.
Weil der Monat hier gewechselt hat.
Hm, aber ist schon heftig, ey.
Echt hart, wie das, wie CS
immer noch abgeht. Man darf ja nicht vergessen,
dass es ein Game ist, was
irgendwann so mal
als Mod, weiß nicht wann die erste Version
rausgekommen ist, so 99 müsste das
sein. Ich meine, Half-Life 1 ist glaube ich
1998 rausgekommen.
Ungefähr ein Jahr später
CS 0 irgendwas.
Das erste CS, was ich damals gespielt
hab, war
05.2, glaube ich.
Und damals,
kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
damals waren, ganz am Anfang waren die
Demolition-Maps gar nicht so beliebt, da haben alle
Geisel-Rettung gespielt. Und Assault war
eine der meistgespielten Maps.
Kann man sich heute überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen.
Da konnte man auch, ich war ja da übelst
ein Kack-Noob. Und ich hab
dann immer damals mit der Scout bei Assault
auf dem Dach gecampt, wo man den
Luftschacht, wo der Luftschacht
reingeht und rauskommt.
Schon die
Prost-Threads am Start gehabt damals.
Italy, ja aber Italy kam später.
Italy kam später.
Militia hat man damals auch viel gespielt.
Diese komische Häusermap.
Mit dem Tunnel.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es die Maps heute überhaupt noch gibt.
Ähm
Und es war
auch so, ich kann das ja aus
erster Hand noch berichten, weil ich war ja dabei.
Als Dust 2 rausgekommen ist.
Und Dust 2 ist ja eine der
langlebigsten und immer
noch gespielten Maps in dem Game
überhaupt.
Und die Leute haben übelst
Dust 2 gehatet, als das rausgekommen ist.
Als es neu war.
Die haben alle gesagt, Dust 2 braucht
kein Mensch, Dust 1 beste.
Und jetzt spielt keiner mehr Dust 1.
Hast du auch früher Wolf Team gespielt?
Was war denn Wolf Team? War das das Unreal CS?
War Wolf Team das Unreal CS?
Oder
es gab ja auch noch
so einen CS ähnlichen Mod für
Unreal Tournament.
Ich weiß aber nicht mehr, wie das heißt.
Das war damals
auch relativ beliebt.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, wie das Ding genau hieß.
CS hat sich zumindest im Endeffekt durchgesetzt.
Eine Maske haben wir uns jetzt genug angeguckt.
Wolf Team ist doch, ich kenne das nicht.
Ich kann nicht jeden Chat im Internet kennen.
Äh.
Wir sind eigentlich so
die Overwatch
Viewerzahlen
seit sie auf Youtube
umgestiegen sind.
50k, das ist aber immer noch ganz
okay.
Also ich werde nicht einen Stream auf Youtube
gucken in der Richtung.
Bis dann.
ThePetis
Ähm.
It's a good thing OVL is moving to Youtube.
Nein.
Nein, das ist total
für den Arsch.
Für Game Streams
Ich meine, guckt euch mal diesen hässlichen
Youtube Chat an.
LeChuck1978
5 Monate, Dankeschön.
QChat
geht auch auf Youtube nicht.
Xtremenet von 5 Monate abonniert.
3 Monate in Folge, Dankeschön.
Ich glaube, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Burpel.
5 Monate.
Dankeschön.
Massive IQ Chat.
Jedem Sub geht es steil nach oben.
Schlechter als Wolfs...
Aha, okay.
Ich habe noch nie Pizza Meat geguckt.
Ich gucke eh wenig Let's Player.
Die einzigen Let's Player, die ich gucke,
war auf Youtube mal einen, den gibt es nicht mehr.
Und auf Twitch gucke ich
eigentlich nur Dance Gaming, wenn überhaupt.
Ja.
Youtube Streaming
suckt einfach nur.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie das gut sein soll,
für mich als interessierten Zuschauer,
der das Spiel selbst spielt, also
nicht mehr, aber gespielt habe.
Ich gucke ja auch kaum nach Overwatch.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie es für mich als
interessierter Spieler,
der was lernen will und zugucken will,
ein gutes Ding ist, sich immer mehr
an den Casual-Scheiß anzuschleimen.
anzuschleimen.
Natürlich aus Sicht von Blizzard
mag das alles sinnvoll sein,
weil Casual
gleich Money ist halt so.
Und ich meine, Blizzard sieht man in letzter Zeit auch.
Blizzard geht es immer mehr darum.
Genauso wie allen anderen auch.
Was halt früher nicht unbedingt so gewesen ist.
Nur das zu machen,
was halt möglichst viel Kohle bringt.
Not having Twitch Emotes
is a temporary problem.
Ne, das ist permanent.
Die werden auf Youtube niemals Twitch Emotes kriegen.
Similar Features. Ich halte Google nicht
für in der Lage
einen ordentlichen
Emote Chat
zu designen.
Oder generell,
was da auf Youtube läuft.
Das ist alles so
langweilig im Vergleich zu Twitch.
Das werden die nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Schauen wir das neue
Rant-Video zu Blizzard.
Was denn? Welches denn?
Auf 40 Minuten Talk-Video
von der Gamestar.
Also ich überlege mir das
anzugucken.
Also wir können uns das nachher angucken.
Aber nur, wenn es entweder
mit Maurice ist
oder mit Dimitri.
Anderen mag ich nicht.
Maurice ist da mal da.
Dann können wir uns das später mal angucken.
Gamestar, Youtube.
Aber nachher, wenn es 40 Minuten geht.
Das kann ich mir jetzt nicht gleich am Anfang geben.
Das da?
Das alte Blizzard ist erledigt.
Das war klar.
Ich weiß noch, vor ein paar Jahren,
als diese Activision Blizzard
Geschichte angefangen hat,
habe ich damals in einem Video gesagt,
okay Leute,
bei Blizzard ist jetzt vorbei.
Da ist Activision mit am Start.
Da werden mit der Zeit
immer mehr Leute sitzen,
die sich nicht für Spiele interessieren,
sondern rein für Zahlen und BWL studiert haben.
Und der Bitz ist ja,
damals haben mich die Leute,
teilweise nicht alle,
die meisten wussten, dass ich Recht habe.
Ich wurde übelst angeflammt.
So nach dem Motto, Max, du hast von
Börse und BWL und sonst was, hast du überhaupt
keine Ahnung? Ist ja auch richtig.
Ja, habe ich auch nicht.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Die haben nur gemerged.
Das bedeutet nicht, dass jetzt
Activision bei Blizzard etwas zu sagen hätte und umgedreht.
Ich war übelst aufgeregt
über das, was ich im Video gesagt habe.
Also hier die Strongs, Leute.
Aber im Endeffekt ist doch klar,
vor allem, wenn es, das wird nicht
von heute auf morgen gehen.
Wann war der Zusammenhang?
Das ist schon 5, 6 Jahre her.
Oh, das ist noch länger her.
Das ist noch länger her.
Hier. Hier irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Seit wie Wendy weg ist.
Irgendwie hier so in dem Dreh
war das, wo ich das Video auch gemacht habe.
Wo ich darüber ein bisschen ausgelassen habe.
Und
es ist doch klar,
dass sowas nicht von heute auf morgen passiert.
Aber man sieht es immer mehr.
Spätestens seitdem Madsen weg ist
und der alte
Blizzard-Chef vor 2 Jahren oder so gesagt hat,
er macht sich jetzt vom Acker.
Da war es für den Letzten
offensichtlich,
war es für den Letzten
offensichtlich, dass die Schlüsselposition
immer mehr durch irgendwelche Activision
BWL-Leute ersetzt werden. Was ja auch ganz logisch ist.
Weil halt
Strongs und Manni. Allerdings
entwicklungstechnisch
sieht es, glaube ich, gar nicht mal so schlecht aus.
Was man sich hätte kaufen müssen,
wäre Nvidia gewesen.
Aber nachher ist man immer schlauer.
Man hätte auch
Milliarden machen können,
wenn man Sachen weiß.
Natürlich ist es klar,
man weiß, nachher ist man immer schlauer.
Aber Nvidia ist
dieses Jahr
echt gut abgegangen.
Hätte man das mal gewusst.
Strongs
bei Nvidia sind hoch.
RTX on.
So ein Alex sagt,
ich frage mich ja immer noch, was Amazon
langfristig mit Twitch vorhat.
Was meinst du langfristig?
Im Prinzip das, was sie jetzt auch schon machen.
Immer mehr Sachen
einzubauen, was es den
Leuten einfacher macht,
Geld auszugeben.
Das fängt an mit
Bits, geht weiter mit
Subonly-Streams,
mit dem Subtrain, mit irgendwelchen
Emote-Unlocks. Man hat das schon
gesehen, also seit Twitch bei Amazon ist,
hat Amazon einiges eingebaut.
Was halt
die Sache
konsumfreundlicher macht.
Ich finde das aber nicht schlimm.
Ich verstehe es eh nicht.
Es wird von vielen Leuten auf Twitch rumgehatet
über Twitch.
Das ist zum Teil
schon in gewisser Weise berechtigt.
Wenn man zum Beispiel
sieht, dass
Community-Regeln, beziehungsweise
die ganze TOS-Geschichte
je nachdem wie bekannt
einer ist,
dass das nicht unbedingt
so
nachvollziehbar und
einheitlich ausgelegt wird.
Aber auf welcher Plattform
ist das schon?
Das macht es nicht wirklich besser.
Aber eins muss einem ja klar sein.
Egal ob jetzt YouTube, Twitch,
Mixer oder
sonstige Dinger.
Man ist eh auf Gedeih und Verderben
dem jeweiligen Anbieter ausgeliefert.
Das ist auf jeder Plattform so.
Also wenn der Anbieter
jetzt der Meinung ist, Max
wir schließen deinen Channel,
wir machen dein Profil
dicht und wir löschen alle deine Posts
ähm
ich kann dagegen nichts machen.
Was soll ich
dagegen machen?
Selbst wenn es einen theoretischen Weg gebe
da jetzt irgendwas zu klagen
zu machen, das wird
in absehbarer Zeit nicht zum Erfolg führen.
Das einzige was hilft ist, und das ist halt
der Witz dabei, weil das auch nichts
offiziell ist im eigentlichen Sinn ist.
Das einzige was hilft ist Shitstorm.
Es war vor einem Jahr
oder so, haben die auf
YouTube angefangen
Channels dicht zu machen, die sich mit Waffen
ähm mit Waffen beschäftigt
haben. Weil nicht
kinderfreundlich und nicht
allgemein freundlich und so.
Und in dem Zuge haben die auch relativ viele Channels
geschlossen, die sich, und das könnt ihr
nachgucken, das ist kein Witz, die sich mit
mittelalterlichen ähm
Kampfmethoden und Waffen
beschäftigt haben. Ja, da gibt's
also das ist wirklich Big Brain gewesen von YouTube.
Da haben die beispielsweise versucht ein Channel dicht
zu machen, der hat halt gezeigt, wie man sich eine Armbrust
baut, mittelalter Style.
Da haben die, hat YouTube gesagt
oh ne, das geht nicht, weil Waffe.
So, und das
gab halt einen riesen massive
Shitstorm, äh
den wahrscheinlich nicht jeder mitgekriegt hat,
aber alle die ein bisschen
diese Channels verfolgen haben,
das gab einen riesen Shitstorm.
Und äh, der Channel ist wieder da.
Also lustigerweise das einzige,
ja genau, Toxics, du kennst das,
du kennst das, ähm
und das einzige,
was hilft, ist lustigerweise das
nicht offizielle,
ist Shitstorm.
Das ist witzig, bei vielen, bei vielen Sachen
ist das heute so. Es ist,
es ist mittlerweile fast egal,
ob was rechtmäßig erfolgt,
unrechtmäßig erfolgt,
irgendwie, ähm,
wer einen betrogen hat, sonst was.
Das was hilft, ist Shitstorm.
Shitstorm,
Shitstorms führen dazu,
dass Produkte zurückgerufen werden.
Shitstorms führen dazu, dass YouTube Channels,
die zugemacht werden, wieder aufgemacht werden.
Shitstorms führen indirekt dazu,
dass irgendwie neu gewählt wird.
Shitstorms ist das Mittel
2020, Dinge da durchzusetzen,
die man haben will.
Man muss halt nur gucken, äh,
man muss halt nur gucken, dass man Verbündete findet, ja.
Genau,
Sonic wird umgestylt, weil Shitstorm.
Shitstorm bei Unity Media, oh, die bekommen
genug Shitstorm. Die sind aber bei,
man, was man auch merkt ist,
dass die Anbieter mittlerweile
ein bisschen feinfühliger geworden sind,
was, äh, Shitstorm
Anfälligkeit angeht.
Es ist nicht umsonst so,
dass, äh,
alle größeren
Anbieter heute, äh,
Twitter Support, Twitter Support haben,
die sich um, um Sachen kümmern.
Und ich, ich vermute
einfach mal, ich mein, ich hab immer noch,
ich hab irgendwie um die 1, 2500, äh,
20.500
irgendwie Follower auf Twitter,
und so fies das klingt, aber ich geh,
ich geh wirklich davon aus,
dass Unity Media
und Telekom und wer auch immer
schneller auf jemand antwortet auf Twitter,
der 20.000 Follower hat, als
einer, der 5 Follower hat. Einfach,
weil die, äh, äh, Shitstorm
aware sind mittlerweile.
Die haben da keinen Bock drauf.
Und sowas kann sich ja auch
wie Feuer ausbreiten.
Wenn da einmal mal geshitstormt wird
an der richtigen Ecke und die passenden Leute
drauf aufspringen, ist vorbei.
Da ist Corona nix dagegen von der Verbreitung.
Das Montana Black macht 20k, äh,
70k mit Prime.
Ja, gut. Warum nicht?
Ja, der hat ja, das ist einer der größten Streamer der Welt.
Wenn der kein Geld macht, wer sonst?
Hab vor 5 Tagen eine Frage gestellt, einfach
keine Antwort bekommen von Unity Media.
Man müsste das jetzt ja mal testen,
wenn ich das quote, ob die dann antworten.
Das kommt auch noch dazu,
Crash Fluffy. Ähm,
wenn du den Leuten hilfst, die quasi,
sag mal, wenn du Leute hilfst, die irgendwie
150.000 Follower haben und der schreibt dann
was Gutes oder bedankt sich öffentlich oder
was auch immer, das ist top.
Da gehen die Stonks nach oben.
Was ist in dem China-Ordner? Oh, das kann ich
jetzt nicht zeigen. Das kann ich
jetzt nicht zeigen auf dem Stream.
Doch, kann ich zeigen.
Da sind irgendwelche AliExpress-Links drin,
die man sich auch mal anschauen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das was Schlimmes ist.
Genau, Corona-Geheimtipps.
Keck weh, Alter.
So, wir haben jetzt noch
kein Video geguckt. Ähm,
wir schauen uns jetzt das Battlefield-Video an.
Und danach, ich hab gestern
auf YouTube ein bisschen rumgeguckt,
was man sich heute anschauen könnte.
Ich hab nichts gefunden, außer ein Video
und zwar ist das vom WDR,
ähm, oder vom
BR?
Was zum Teufel ist der BR-Rundfunk?
Was ist BR?
Ah, der Bayerische Rundfunk.
Ah, nicht der WDR.
Die guckt schon so ein bisschen gefährlich.
Ähm,
kann Ari in drei
Monaten ihre eigene App programmieren?
Das müssen wir uns nachher angucken.
Das ist voll cringe, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Solche, ähm, den
Blizzard-Talk haben wir schon auf. Das gucken wir uns
da noch an. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen,
wenn ich dieses erste Bild sehe,
dass das ein wenig cringe sein wird.
Das müssen wir uns angucken.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns, wir gucken uns erstmal
jetzt in Ruhe eine Runde
Battlefield-Montage an.
Und ich, ihr wisst ja, das was ich immer sage,
ähm,
der Typ sagt immer das gleiche
in seinen Videos.
Moment, Leute. Das ist Battlefield 3
jetzt. Das fällt einem echt schwer
zu unterscheiden, vor allem auf dem PC,
wo man keine Controller-Controls
sieht und keine Auflösung
irgendwie das festmachen kann.
Deine Meinung zum neuen Edge?
Stimmt.
Da ist er.
Der neue Edge.
Ähm.
Ich habe
den neuen Edge noch nicht ausprobiert.
Außer hier im Stream.
Was ist eigentlich die Default-Suche?
Ist die Default-Suche Bing?
Ach nee, wir haben
es auf DuckDuckGo umgestellt, die Default-Suche
vom Edge. Ähm.
Oh, ich hab hier einen Facebook-Account.
Sachen gibt's. Hab ich eigentlich
irgendwann mal gemacht. Hab ich seit 5 Jahren nix mehr hochgeladen
oder so.
Facebook-Account, ah.
Facebook in 2020, KKW.
Das letzte
2018 hab ich irgendwie ein Video
verlinkt von Youtube. Hat
keine Sau interessiert, weil Facebook
von der Zoomer-Generation
eh keiner mehr verwendet. Was ist denn das hier
gewesen?
Haha, das
kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Habt ihr was für dich?
I love Cookies.
Und noch den
G2A-Rap-Link drunter, Alter.
Könnt ihr euch da noch
dran erinnern? Daumen
revealed.
Facebook Gaming wächst mehr als Mixer.
Das wundert mich nicht. Mixer ist ja auch totaler
Schrott.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern?
An die Game Pass
Kopiergeschichte von I love Cookies?
Oh Mann.
Gibt's den eigentlich noch?
Ich weiß,
er war irgendwie vor einem Jahr oder so mal
hier im Stream.
Und wir haben gesagt, wir nehmen mal was zusammen auf.
Aber das hat sich ja irgendwie... Oh guck mal, da ist tatsächlich
noch am Start hier. Ab und zu.
Wahnsinn.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Ähm...
Ja.
Gab doch großes Drama damals wegen den Fast Passen.
Ja, ja. Riesendrama.
Streamt er
eigentlich noch Poker?
Was für ein Poker-Dude.
Also Battlefield 3 ist blau, sieht man immer unten rechts.
Stimmt, hast recht. Ja, klar.
So, wir gucken jetzt Battlefield Top Plays an.
Das ist
wieder so ein typischer Clip,
Leute, wo ich mir so denke,
bestimmt
nicht gestellt.
Okay, nee, ich glaub das ist wirklich nicht gestellt.
Ich glaub das ist wirklich nicht gestellt.
Wobei, man weiß es nicht. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es
gestellt war.
Ich dachte jetzt, der erschießt einen auf dem Turm.
Macht er aber nicht.
Welcome to new Battlefield Top Play Video.
Oder irgendwie sowas. Er sagt immer das gleiche.
Jesus.
Moment, haben wir das...
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Haben wir das nicht letzte Woche schon geguckt?
23. Februar?
Nee, können wir letzte Woche nicht geguckt haben.
Ach nee, Moment.
Haben wir das letzte Woche nicht schon geguckt?
Oh.
Lull.
Warum geht nach unten auch weiter
der Monat?
Das ist Microsoft-Kalender-Logik.
Also, die Chance besteht,
dass wir das schon geguckt haben.
Wie viel Uhr hat denn das hochgeladen?
Sieht man da die Uhrzeit irgendwie bei?
Wir machen jetzt Trick 17.
Wir gucken jetzt,
wann das erste Kommentar war.
Big Brain, Leute. Big Brain.
Übrigens, wieder ein Punkt, warum Endlesscroll
kacke ist.
Wir gucken jetzt, wann das erste Kommentar war.
Wir müssen nur 5 Minuten scrollen und dann wissen wir,
ob wir das...
At first, 6 days ago.
Und zwar, wann genau...
Mein Gott, YouTube, ist das so schwer, deine Uhrzeit anzuzeigen?
Ist das so schwer, deine Uhrzeit anzuzeigen?
Okay, wir gucken einfach mal den Anfang.
Und dann sehen wir ja,
ob wir es schon...
Browser, please!
Jetzt wisst ihr auch, warum YouTube
Endlesscroll hat.
Weil der Browser übelst am verrecken ist,
wenn man Endless... wenn man so viele Kommentare
angezeigt hat. Ich weiß nicht, was da dran
schwierig ist, ehrlich gesagt,
5 Seiten Kommentare anzuzeigen, warum das dann so ruckelt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
WTF?
Ist das jetzt nicht euer Ernst?
Reload.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Was läuft da im Hintergrund für
eine großrechnermäßige
JavaScript-Geschichte?
Das ist absolut verrückt.
Und der zweite Clip von Jesus
ist einer seiner
völlig verrückten Tankschotze.
Der erste, den er mit einem Jet
und dann der zweite,
aber er hat es bereits gefeuert,
und es verbindet sich mit einem Heli.
Ich denke, es ist ein Heli.
Der nächste Clip ist IL-2DF-NEO.
Dann Battlefield 3
und eine zuverlässige
langweilige Snipe
auf das.
Jetzt gucken wir uns
ein anderes an.
Battlefield 5, wer braucht
Battlefield 5?
Overrated, jebaited.
Luckiest moment Battlefield...
Okay, kommt, da sind
alle Games drin.
Ah, ne, das ist Battlefield 5.
Battlefield 5 will ich nicht gucken.
Perfect time, Battlefield 5, Battlefield 5.
Ein Jahr, ne, vor einem Jahr haben wir noch nicht geguckt.
Moment, das ist...
Ich will was anderes gucken.
Epic Moments, Battlefield Top
Play ist Battlefield Top.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, auch schon geguckt.
Macht das mit der App in drei Monaten,
dann gucken wir Battlefield, gucken wir nachher, genau.
Wir suchen jetzt erst mal
was Gescheites raus.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, noch nicht geguckt.
Das ist so alt, das können wir noch nicht geguckt haben.
Komm, wir gucken uns den Cringe,
die Cringe-Reportage vom
Bayerischen Rundfunk an. Aber Leute,
ich sag euch, das wird wahrscheinlich übelst zum Fremdschämen.
Wenn ich das erste Foto schon sehe, dann weiß ich,
was das ist.
Die quietscht wahrscheinlich das ganze Video über rum,
so nach dem Motto, oh, wie kompliziert das ist
und lull und Technik
und, äh, überhaupt.
Das wird richtig
Pain's Champ.
Habe ich, das wird wirklich
Pain's Champ eigentlich drinne?
Moment, das brauchen wir noch. Oh.
What the fuck?
High IQ!
Das hat genau das Richtige für uns
aufgemacht.
High IQ?
Place. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das,
wie habe ich das denn geschafft zu öffnen, das Video gerade?
Hat das jemand gesehen, wie ich das Video gerade
aufgemacht habe?
Was, Ctrl-T?
Ctrl-T macht nen, Ctrl-T macht
nen Tab auf.
Und dann?
Ctrl-Shift-T? Nee, das hatten wir gar nicht auf,
das Video.
Egal, High IQ Place, der Browser
Gott hat entschieden, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Äh, jetzt.
Ich wollte gerade irgendwas gucken
im, im neuen Tab.
Genau, Pain's Champ brauche ich noch.
Pain's Champ.
Genau den da.
Gif.
Als Gif brauche ich den. Äh, nicht als Gif,
als Transparent.
Color, Transparent.
Äh, perfekt.
Bisschen, bisschen klein, aber
was ist das?
Hahaha, ist das dumm, ey.
Okay, Pain's Champ.
Besser, besser, besser kleines Bild als gar nix.
Pain's Champ.
Perfekt.
Das brauchen wir für das Video.
Ich weiß, dass das, dass das
äh, essentiell sein wird.
Google Bildersuche
nach Twitch Emotes.
Ja, da findest, ich hab immer Angst, wenn ich Twitch Emotes suche
und Google Bildersuche kommt,
hab ich immer Angst, dass irgendwie irgendeine
Satos-Geschichte kommt.
Man weiß ja nie so genau, ne?
So.
Gucken wir uns mal an. Was, was hat der Bayerische
Rundfunk uns da, äh,
was hat der Bayerische Rundfunk mit
unseren Rundfunkgebühren angestellt?
Zeigt mal her.
Ariane lernt programmieren.
Oh.
Leute.
Es tut jetzt schon weh.
Es schmerzt.
Eigene App haben.
Oh Gott, es schmerzt.
Es tut weh.
Also das wär schon was.
Ich bin ein Computer-Legastheniker.
Öffnen. Hallo.
Aber das Programmieren ist quasi
das Autofahren des
21. Jahrhunderts.
Was?
Das Programmieren ist
das Autofahren des 21.
Jahrhunderts?
Ich versuch mir grad nen Reim zu machen
auf den Vergleich irgendwie.
What?
Egal.
Wir gucken jetzt.
Weiter. Ich kann das Video nicht
ausmachen, Leute. Wenn ich das Video
ausmache, dann kommen
wieder alle Feministen und sagen
Max, du machst das Video nur aus, weil
die Hauptrolle von ner Frau gespielt wird.
Das geht nicht.
Chat, wir müssen das Video fertig gucken.
Wer den hat, ist klar im Vorteil.
Der Plan ist jetzt, dass ich
meine eigene App programmiere,
innerhalb von 3 Monaten
und danach
kann jeder von euch die
auf sein Handy laden.
Dafür geht's am Valentinstag
zu meinem ersten Programmierkurs.
Bei Cook&Code kann jeder gegen
selbstgekochtes Coden lernen.
Coden.
Leute.
Hört auf Coden zu sagen.
Das hört sich an wie Kacken.
Hack-Mack-Programmier-Fanclub.
Oh, mit Rosen.
Hätte der Bachelor für dich da gelassen.
Ich hasse den Bachelor.
Zum Glück nicht der Bachelor,
sondern mein Programmiercoach Alexander.
Er will mit seinen Kursen fürs Coden
begeistern und bringt mir heute
die ersten Basics bei.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, aber es wird schon.
Okay, das ist schon mal ein
äußerst unrealistischer Kurs.
So viele Mädels,
wie in diesem Kurs sind,
das muss Fake sein.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass es in einem Programmierkurs
nur Mädels gibt.
Oder aber, wahrscheinlich ist es
ein Programmierkurs nur für Mädels.
Wahrscheinlich wird es das sein,
weil ansonsten ist die Zusammensetzung
nicht sonderlich repräsentativ.
Ich bin ja heute hier, um
ein schönes JavaScript-Trinkspiel
zu programmieren.
JavaScript ist eine Programmiersprache,
mit deren Hilfe man Webseiten
interaktiv machen kann.
Ich kann mich direkt selbst damit programmieren.
Zumindest haben sie schon mal angefangen
die, äh,
die, ähm,
die beste Aussprache
den Leuten beizubringen.
Nicht Javascript, sondern gleich JavaScript.
Leute, was sagt ihr?
Javascript oder Javascript?
Also ich persönlich
bin ja für Javascript.
Javascript. Javascript.
Javascript.
Javascript sind aktuell so
10 Prozent
Javascript
Ich wechsele immer zwischen beiden.
Bei SCSI mache ich das immer,
wenn ich SCSI einzeln habe,
dann sag ich SCSI,
ansonsten sag ich aber auch
Tsongasi, was gibt denn das?
Gut, so hat jeder mal angefangen, ja?
Aber wenigstens, wenigstens 5%.
passiert das schon mal auf dem macbook weil wir wissen ja dass alle pros auf
macbooks programmieren ich war ein so hat irgendwie jeder mal
angefangen ja also irgendwie abtippen was in dem tutorial steht
da kommt doch wenig doch da jetzt schon
oh ein hallo welt ist aber alex warum ist das eigentlich so dass das anscheinend nur
frauen machen da gibt es verschiedene theorien zum beispiel bei unseren
kinder kursen kommen nur jungs naja also die jungs haben das in unserem alter alles schon
gelernt ich versuche mich weiter am trinkspiel funktioniert das aber das zu laut
ob ich probleme
tolles spiel als antwort kommt immer trinkt das ist natürlich auch eine
möglichkeit wer hätte das gedacht also ich vor
einem stück nicht ob das so wie sie bleibt ich meine ich will ja eine
komplette programmieren hier arbeitet der alex und schauen wir mal was man so
schaffen kann wenn man als anfänger drei monate programmieren darf
hashtag zweites facebook auch in drei monaten kann man schon relativ viel
machen
die hat eine voraussetzung
die hat eine voraussetzung die ist gar nicht schlecht mit mit
die ist gar nicht schlecht mit mit
die ist gar nicht schlecht mit mit programmieren anzufangen
programmieren anzufangen
programmieren anzufangen die weiß was sie machen will
die weiß was sie machen will
die weiß was sie machen will das sage ich das sage ich auch wenn leute
das sage ich das sage ich auch wenn leute
das sage ich das sage ich auch wenn leute im stream fragen so was ist die beste
im stream fragen so was ist die beste
im stream fragen so was ist die beste variante an stoff anzufangen zu
variante an stoff anzufangen zu
variante an stoff anzufangen zu programmieren das beste ist wenn man von
programmieren das beste ist wenn man von
programmieren das beste ist wenn man von anfang an irgendwas im kopf hat was man
anfang an irgendwas im kopf hat was man
machen will, weil dann erübrigt
sich schon mal die Technologieauswahl,
zum größten Teil, ja, ansonsten stehst du
vor einem Riesenberg, so nach dem Motto, mit was
wird das Standbilder?
Das ist ein bisschen unglücklich
gewesen, aber ich habe einfach Pause gedrückt,
ja,
ansonsten stehst du vor einem
Riesenberg und denkst dir,
scheiße, mit was fange ich jetzt an?
Aber die hat echt einen Vorteil, die
hat schon im Kopf, sie will eine App machen,
das grenzt vieles,
das grenzt
vieles aus, was du nicht lernen
musst oder was du gar nicht, was gar nicht
in Frage kommt. Die muss jetzt
beispielsweise nicht mit .NET WPF anfangen
oder so ein Blödsinn, weil damit machst du keine App.
Also die Voraussetzungen
sind gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Hallo!
Hast du dir denn schon Gedanken
gemacht? Ja, bin gespannt, ob das
klappt oder nicht. Meine
geniale Idee, eine Spiele-App,
in der du dir eine Soap-Fresh
spielen kannst. Die Hauptperson in
meiner Mini-Soap sind...
Darauf kann auch nur jemand kommen,
der beim Rundfunk arbeitet, ey.
...sind eine Kartoffel namens Clemens
und natürlich ich.
In der App spielt man schnick, schnack, schnuck.
Wer verliert, muss noch mal spielen.
Massive Game. Huge.
Wer gewinnt, darf sich aussuchen, wie die Soap weitergeht.
Und so ungefähr sollen die Videos aussehen.
Aber so doof ist das nicht, ne?
So doof ist das nicht.
Das ist ziemlich simpel zu machen.
Und, ähm...
Die hat jetzt schon zwei
Voraussetzungen, die echt nicht
verkehrt sind. Die weiß, dass sie in die App
machen will, das heißt, strengt die Technologie ein
und sie weiß schon mal,
was sie zu grob in die App rein soll,
wo man abschätzen kann, das ist in drei Monaten
überhaupt möglich.
Wenn ich jetzt sage,
wenn ich jetzt irgendwie eine total abgedrehte
Idee habe, so nach dem Motto, ich will hier
irgendwelche
Machine Learning noch nie dagewesen
super-advance Sachen machen in drei Monaten,
hab aber noch überhaupt keine Ahnung,
dann ist die Chance, dass das in die Hose geht, relativ hoch.
Sie weiß, dass sie eine App machen will
und sie weiß jetzt im Endeffekt
auch, dass es in drei Monaten möglich ist.
Weil die Idee ist, das ist nichts
Schwieriges in dem Sinn, ja?
Das kann man in drei Monaten hinkriegen.
Das ist auch so
von dem so nach dem Motto, du machst
ein Minispiel rein,
im Prinzip ist das ja nur
random zwischen drei Zahlen
und dann gucken, was größer ist, so im Endeffekt.
Oder was unklar... Das ist so ein...
Also,
Stereoschein...
Stereoschein-Papier zu programmieren, ist jetzt nicht
so, ja, huge.
Aber für einen Einsteiger
ist das gar nicht
so einfach, wenn man sich überlegt, es geht
ja nicht darum, dass die irgendwie ihre zehn Zeilen
Stereoschein-Papier programmiert,
sondern die muss ja den ganzen anderen
Kram drumherum auch machen.
Und da sind drei Monate, ist
realistisch und das ist schon mal gut, dass man weiß, dass es
überhaupt geht. Schön, dass
ihr da seid. Mein Name ist Ariane Alter und
das ist Clemens Kartoffel.
Vor drei Tagen stand er einfach
vor der Tür einer Clemens
Kartoffel.
Für dein Projekt brauchst du
HTML, CSS,
JavaScript und...
Muss es unbedingt im Browser laufen?
Ja gut,
ist das Einfachste.
Kann ich aber verstehen. Ist die simpelste
Geschichte und lässt sich auch am einfachsten entwickeln.
Und die
ономisch ist das GameWorks Angular?
Ionic.
Okay, Ionic verstehe ich.
Muss man Ionic in Angular programmieren?
Nö oder?
Ich habe mit Ionic noch nichts gemacht.
Ich weiß nur, was
es ist.
Ähm
Ionic ist ein App Framework
für quasi
Browser-Anwendungen
in
AppStore
passende Dinger
zu verpacken. Mit, ich glaube,
da bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, weil ich hab mit
Ionic noch nichts gemacht, mit den passenden
Bindings für die jeweilige
Plattform drinnen. Also sprich,
du kannst dann, du kannst dann die Kamera,
du kannst dann den Kamerazugriff,
es ist so ein bisschen was wie Elektron, ein bisschen was
wie Elektron mit zusätzlichem
ähm
Mobile Framework dabei.
Und du kannst am Ende
glaube ich eine App Store
eine App Store Package rausfallen
lassen. Und es
hat, soweit ich weiß, hast
du auch irgendeinen Designer
für, für GUI. Ionic
ist quasi ein Rapper, du kannst mit, ja,
native Schnittstelle ansprechen, genau. Genau, das
ist quasi, das ist, das ist irgendwie so eine Mischung aus
das kann wohl, das kann wohl mehrere Sachen.
Ich hab damit noch nichts gemacht. Du hast auf der einen Seite
wohl irgendwie so ein, so ein Mobile Framework
Geschichten drin, also sprich, dass du eben auf die
Kamera zugreifen kannst, auf GPS zugreifen
kannst, auf irgendwelche Dinger,
die dein, äh Sensoren und
Geschiss, was halt eben dein Smartphone hat.
Ähm, halt mit, mit
JavaScript Runtime und im Endeffekt ist
da wahrscheinlich einfach ein ganz normales V8
und ein bisschen Chrome unten drunter, vermute ich
jetzt mal, einfach mal geraten. Äh, plus
wohl noch so ein paar Hilf, Hilfetools
dass du, äh, App Store
App Store Sachen machen kannst. Und ich glaube
ein GUI Designer hat das Ding
auch. Ich hab mal bei
ähm, Simple App Creator
äh, ich glaub das, ich glaub
das könnte das sein. Ja und was, und was
da, was das Schöne auch daran ist, du kannst
halt, ähm, IOS und
und Android Apps damit machen.
Ich hab da mal ein Video zugesehen, von
äh, ja
ja von dem, der ist
übrigens auch Max, deswegen kann ich mir
den Channel immer gut merken. Ähm,
der hat, der hat mal einen, so eine
so eine Serie gemacht, ähm
Ionic vs
Flutter vs
irgendwelche Native Script
Gedöns und da hat er ein bisschen was zu
Ionic erklärt und
das scheint mir wirklich ein guter Mittelweg zu
sein zwischen Easy Einstieg
und, ähm, Funktionen.
Ja, du wirst jetzt nicht die Wahnsinns
Performance für irgendwie den Game rausholen
aber die meisten Apps sind halt irgendwie
keine 3D oder, oder
Performance fressende
Dinger. Wie viele Tabs hast du
offen? Nicht viele. 15 oder so?
Angular
und Ionworks, Angular
und Ionic. Muss, muss man Ionic
echt mit Angular programmieren? Ich glaube nicht.
Ja, das ist
äh, gar nicht so wenig.
Brave Browser ist gut. Mission Impossible.
Und jetzt
starten wir mit HTML.
HTML. HTML ist das
Skelett einer Website.
Und bringt Inhalte wie zum Beispiel Fotos
auf die Seite. Achtung,
es ist keine Programmiersprache.
Aber super wichtig als Grundgerüst
einer Website.
Ist du sicher, dass es JPEG ist?
Ja. Okay.
Speichern. Und jetzt kommt der große Moment.
Oh mein Gott, das hat geklappt.
Wow.
Unglaublich.
Damit du das gelernte
JavaScript-Wissen nicht wieder vergisst,
möchten wir das gerne...
Da war doch gar kein JavaScript dabei.
Achso, ja, vorher.
Hallo World in JavaScript.
...hinterholen. Und zwar machst das du alleine
in der Hausaufgabe.
Yay! Hausaufgaben!
Bevor ich mich um die Hausaufgaben kümmere,
fange ich lieber mit dem Videodreh
für meine selbst ausgedachte Kartoffelsoap an.
Per Kartoffel.
Das ist prinzipiell schon mal keine gute Idee.
Quasi, bevor man
irgendwie nicht auch einen halbwegs laufigen Prototyp
hat, Content zu erstellen, für was, wo man
überhaupt nicht weiß, ob es funktioniert.
Das ist eigentlich verkehrt rum.
Ihr fragt euch jetzt, warum eine Kartoffel?
Ich sage, was?
In einer Folge
kommen zum Beispiel ein paar befreundete Pommes
bei Clemens Kartoffeln vorbei.
Alter.
Guten Morgen.
Programmpunkt für den heutigen Tag ist
die erste Hausaufgabe.
Ich soll ein Beispielprogramm...
Übrigens,
das ist ja alles...
Erfahrungs...
Also, rein meine Erfahrung.
Im Bett programmieren funktioniert nicht.
Auf Englisch.
Auf Englisch?
Oh Gott!
So.
Moment! Wartet mal kurz.
Also,
der Sprung...
Also, der Sprung von
JavaScript Hello World
zu
irgendeinem Space Invaders Klon
oder was das da genau ist.
Das erscheint mir jetzt
ein bisschen weit.
Oder sie ist wirklich extrem
massive big brain.
Ja, oder es ist Copy-Paste.
Ja, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Einfach Copy-Paste und dann...
Das könnte natürlich auch sein.
Stand da doch eben, oder?
Was denn?
Canvas Basics.
Ach hier, das ist die Mozilla-Hilfe.
Ähm...
Gut, da steht aber nicht drinnen,
wie man da draußen ein Game macht.
Game Dev Canvas Workshop.
Was?
Ist das Alex?
Lesson 1.
Ach, sowas ist das hier.
Ach, das kommt da raus.
Ah, okay.
Dann geht das doch.
Ich vermute mal,
dass es so ist,
man bekommt das hier.
Man bekommt,
man bekommt das hier
und soll dann verschiedene Aufgaben
an diesem Source-Code durchführen.
Na, dann geht das doch.
Dann ist das doch okay.
Kann man doch machen.
Ich soll ein Beispiel programmieren.
Das ist ja alles auf Englisch.
So.
Naja, da muss man sich aber dran gewöhnen,
dass der Kram auf Englisch ist.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was Alex sagt.
Es könnte auch sein,
dass ich einige Aufgaben nicht gemacht habe.
Das fängt ja schon gut an.
So, dann, ähm...
wollen wir doch mal sehen.
Du hast gesagt,
du hast die Hausaufgabe gemacht.
Mhm.
Guck.
Wow.
Ich hab's sogar ein bisschen schneller gemacht,
weil ich finde, dass es zu langsam war.
Nicht schlecht.
Pock.
Also, da... weit raus.
Das ist aber...
Also, das ist genau der Punkt.
Das ist eine Übung,
die kann ich dir nicht beibringen,
außer du machst es selbst.
Das ist ja zum Kotzen.
Also, dann würde ich sagen...
Nee, aber ey,
warum kann er ihr nicht erklären?
Also, warum soll das nicht funktionieren?
Warum kann er ihr nicht erklären,
was ihr hätte machen müssen,
um das zu machen?
Ich meine...
Warum soll das nicht gehen?
Warum soll das nicht funktionieren?
Der kann das nicht...
Der muss das nicht vorsagen.
Es gibt ja immer noch einen Zwischenweg zwischen.
Gar nichts.
Und ich erkläre dir...
Also, ich sag dir, was du hinschreiben musst.
Man kann den Leuten ja einen Hinweis geben.
So nach dem Motto,
guck dir mal die Funktion an,
die aufgerufen wird,
wenn der Ball an die Wand klatscht.
So.
Und dann kannst du sagen,
guck dir mal die Funktion an.
Da kannst du dir nochmal eine halbe Stunde Gedanken machen,
ob man das nicht an der Stelle machen könnte.
Wie du es an der Stelle machen würdest.
Also, es ist ja ein Unterschied zwischen
Vorsagen und gar nichts.
Alter, 292, das ist euer Rekord.
Ich glaube, das höchste bisher war irgendwie 250 sonntags.
Massive Zuschauer.
Alle nur, weil sie Ari in drei Monaten,
beim Programmieren zusehen wollen.
Huge.
Fangen wir an mit CSS.
Warte, ich muss noch kurz das Ding abspeichern.
CSS beschreibt das Design einer Website.
Damit kann man also derselben Seite unterschiedliche Looks geben.
HTML war ja das.
Gillette.
Yes.
Also ist CSS...
Ich liebe Klamotten.
Genau.
Warte.
Die Challenge.
Ich soll meine Website mit CSS grün programmieren
und rosa Kästchen draufbauen.
Boah.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Du hast es geschafft.
Boah.
Jetzt sind wir doch schon fertig.
Fertig?
Ja.
Okay.
Also du hast HTML gelernt, du hast CSS gelernt,
du hast JavaScript, die Grundlagen gelernt.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, die Hausaufgaben wieder von vorne anzufangen.
Gut.
Ja, klar.
Freizeit war dann nicht mehr so,
weil in jeder freien Minute habe ich entweder programmiert...
Die könnte doch einfach...
Ich meine, ihr Job ist es, Reportagen für den BR zu drehen.
Da ist das ja wohl in der Zeit drin, oder?
Oh, Chat.
Chat.
Aufhören.
Ich muss weitermachen.
Clemens Kartoffel gedreht.
Chat?
Ja.
Vielleicht habe ich den Bezug zur Realität verloren.
Eine Süßkartoffel hat zum Beispiel in meinem Bett ein Ingwer geboren.
Kann auch nicht jeder von sich sagen.
Wisst ihr, was ich merkwürdig finde?
Man sieht sie total oft am Notebook sitzen,
aber man sieht sie so gut wie nie programmieren.
Oder irgendwas machen.
Jetzt kommen Konsequenzen, Leute.
War gespannt, was da am Ende rauskommt.
Hallo.
Schon wieder.
Ich finde, wir konnten auch schon zusammenziehen.
Mittlerweile muss ich sagen, ich habe diesen Mann zu meinem Geburtstag eingeladen,
weil ich so viel Zeit mit ihm verbringe.
Wir treffen uns mindestens einmal die Woche.
Ich hacke irgendwas in die...
Da ist ja der Plan von Alex mit dem reinen Mädel-Workshop voll aufgegangen.
Die Tastatur regt mich auf, weil irgendwas wieder nicht geht.
Er rettet mich aus diesem digitalen Meer der Unsicherheiten.
Also der Alex und ich...
Was machen wir heute?
Heute sprechen wir über Angular und über Ionic.
Es wird halt jetzt sehr abstrakt.
Ab jetzt wird es abstrakt?
Es könnte sein, dass du jetzt kurz zur Verzweiflung kommst,
aber das wird schon ganz gut werden.
Schon wieder.
Bist du bereit?
Ja.
Angular ist eine Art Baukasten für JavaScript.
Klingt einfach, ist aber wahnsinnig komplex.
Ja, eigentlich ist die Beschreibung...
Ich meine, die trifft es nicht wirklich.
Aber wie willst du das anderweitig erklären?
Wie willst du anderweitig ein Anwendungs-Framework...
Wie willst du das erklären?
Ist doch eigentlich ganz okay.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier?
Sie lernen auch noch TypeScript nebenbei.
Es wird auch noch TypeScript nebenbei gelernt.
Easy.
Was ich mich frage, wer den ganzen Kram eingerichtet hat,
weil ehrlicherweise ist das reine Setup...
Das reine Setup von so einem Entwicklungs-Environment.
Also ich rede jetzt nicht von dem Editor an sich,
sondern von den ganzen Tools im Hintergrund,
dass das funktioniert.
Ein bisschen beschäftigen muss man sich damit auch.
Ach, Angular geht nur noch in TypeScript.
Ein bisschen muss man sich damit beschäftigen.
Ich meine, bei Vue hast du Vue-CLI zum Generieren.
Ah ja, die Wolle sagt gerade Angular-CLI.
Da gibt es auch was zum Generieren.
Ein bisschen mit beschäftigen, was die ganzen Dinger machen,
muss man trotzdem.
Zumindest ist jetzt Type...
Ich wusste nicht, dass TypeScript Pflicht ist bei Angular.
So, jetzt machen wir das Ganze hier auch noch in TypeScript.
Was deutlich angenehmer ist.
Ich habe trotzdem die Bache.
So, weiter.
Ich tauche immer tiefer in die Marke.
Aber wirklich bereit bin ich nicht.
Stopp.
Wenn du das jetzt ausführst, dann wird ein Wunder passieren.
Was willst du noch mal in deinem Projekt machen?
Video, ching-chang-chong, mehrere Optionen,
dann wieder Video, ching-chang-chong und immer so weiter.
Aber die Leute sollen es auf dem Smartphone nutzen?
Am meisten, ja.
Okay.
Dann kannst du das zum Beispiel mit Ionic machen.
Das ist dafür sehr gut geeignet.
Ionic ist ein Gerüst, mit dessen Hilfe ich aus meiner Idee
tatsächlich eine App bauen kann.
Und das Beste, es macht Spaß.
Genau, das Ding meinte ich ja.
Ich wusste, dass das Ding irgendeinen GUI-Designer hat.
Hörst du das Ding nochmal, Ionic?
Das ist schon mal mein bester Freund.
Das ist das GUI. Die Funktion ist nicht da.
Es läuft gar nichts, Alex.
Oh je.
Gibt es nur noch Paid?
Ja, Alex hat bestimmt einen Paid-Zugang zu Ionic,
zu diesem Ionic-Creator da.
Ionic, zum vierten Mal gemacht.
Und es geht nicht.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
In drei Monaten neben dem Job von null eine App programmieren?
Puh.
Dann ratet mal, wohin es wieder geht.
Meine App ist von Ionic fertig,
aber Grundkenntnisse im Programmieren?
Check.
Ich habe mit Ionic eine App gebaut.
Jetzt muss man die nur noch hinten rum quasi programmieren, ne?
Nur? Nur noch?
Ich meine, das ist das Eigentliche.
Jetzt kann ich nur den Oberflächen-Look festlegen.
Danach kommt erst die eigentliche Programmierarbeit.
Oh je.
Okay, Leute.
Ich glaube, ihr die Seite...
Das glaube ich ihr, dass ihr die Seite selbst gemacht habt.
Genauso sieht eine Anfänger-Seite aus.
Hintergrundbild, Standard-Schrift-Art, absolut kein Kontrast zwischen...
Das glaube ich ihr.
Also...
Also bis jetzt kaufe ich ihr das ab.
Das ist in zwei Monaten noch ohne Probleme möglich.
Eigentliche Programmierarbeit für die verschiedenen Funktionen meiner App.
Aber Hauptsache erstmal einen Bootstrap.
Hauptsache erstmal einen Bootstrap-Button, ne?
Das ist wichtig.
Hintergrund-Text sieht kacke aus.
Einfach einen Bootstrap-Button.
Programmierarbeit für die verschiedenen Funktionen meiner App.
Mit Abstand das Schwerste war dieses vermaledeite Spiel.
Ich dachte es ist so einfach.
Der Computer macht zufällig was...
Ich mach was.
Und dann wird geguckt wer hat gewonnen.
So schwer können sie nicht sein.
Doch es ist so schwer.
und die kartoffel video
Okay sie....
Ich hoffe wir sehen noch ein bisschen Source-code
Schwer.
Darf man...
Darf man sich APKs herunter laden?
Und die complilen..?
Obwohl, wir müssen es gar nicht dichompilen.
Das ist ja Javascript.
Darf man sich APKs herunter laden und auspacken?
Und auspacken, also on stream
Ich will mal gucken
Was da drin ist
Wir laden uns gleich Clemens Kartoffel runter
Gucken wir rein
Ich weiß aber nicht wie man APKs auspackt
Weil bisher sieht man nicht
Viele
Man sieht eigentlich überhaupt kein
Javascript
Wie die Geschichte genau verläuft
Und dann aber ausgeht
Könnt ihr euch ja auf der App erspielen
Clemens ist im Backofen
Das Spiel muss ich aber auch noch fertig programmieren
Da merkt man irgendwie schon
Was macht mir mehr Spaß
Zeigt doch mal was sie so programmiert
Mich interessiert das echt was da raus
Also mich interessiert wirklich was da auf dem Bildschirm ist
Nicht dass er auf dem Notebook tippt
Ich will sehen was auf dem Bildschirm ist
Mit Alex
Aber diesmal wird es wahrscheinlich das letzte Mal sein
Denn heute schließen Alex und ich
Die App ab und laden sie hoch
Also es gab Zeiten wo ich nicht mehr dran geglaubt habe
Ich bin so glücklich
Wahnsinn
Ich habe jetzt auch
Diese Videos fertig
Jetzt haben wir auch die Fotos
Im Prinzip habe ich alles dabei
Um das Projekt heute abzuschließen
Kriegen wir hin
Wer jetzt sagt
Die Bilder sehen ja total unprosenial aus
Ach ne das sind ja auch nur die Platzhalter
Und das wird jetzt einfach nur ersetzt
Und dieses Ersetzen
Kann mir jetzt die ganze Schose
Wieder vollkommen verhauen
Hast du eine Sicherung gemacht?
Jetzt wäre der passende Zeitpunkt
Ähm
Dass Alex ihr mal beibringt
Eine Runde Git, Commit und Push
Wäre jetzt wirklich angebracht
Ja
Was ist wenn der Computer jetzt abraucht
Dann müssen wir wieder von vorne
Also jetzt hast du mal
Oh Gott erst mal auf Festplatte sichern
Es ist ja eigentlich
Es fühlt sich so an als würdest du am offenen Herzen operieren
Ja
Ich wusste es
Jetzt ist das Foto weg
Das Foto ist weg
Ari hat sich vertippt
Wie löscht man ein Foto mit dem man sich vertippt?
Vertippt
Und neuer Versuch
Ersetzen
Ding Dong
Hacker Man ist am Start
Und so sieht es dann auf dem Handy aus
Also jetzt beim Endspurt merkst du
Du machst gerade den geilsten Scheiß
Mache ich jetzt den heißesten Scheiß?
Na gut
Es gibt bestimmt noch anderen heißen Scheiß
Aber es ist schon einer der
Heißesten Scheißen
Erste die es gibt
Wobei ich glaube
Also wenn wir mal davon ausgehen
Das ist wirklich legit
Was wir gezeigt kriegen
Dann kann die sich wirklich freuen
Also wenn man echt keinen Plan hat
Dann ist das schon nicht übel
So was hier zu basteln erstmal
Ich meine mit allem was dazu gehört
Wie gesagt
Wenn wir davon ausgehen
Dass das alles legit ist
Was wir gezeigt bekommen haben
Dann würde ich mich an ihrer Stelle jetzt auch freuen
Wenn das Ding im App Store landet
Ich klicke auf Clemens will Muskeln
Und kriege das Video
Clemens will Muskeln
Stimmt die Zeige ist legit
Die zeigen mehr oder weniger immer die gleichen Stellen
Aber wahrscheinlich
Ich meine
Die App wird jetzt auch nicht allzu lang sein
Ja
Ich meine
Ich meine ein bisschen HTML
Und Embedded YouTube Videos
Mit ein paar Scheiben
Also
Das wird nicht so lang sein
Wahrscheinlich sind das irgendwie 300 Zeilen
Mit allem zusammen oder so
Wir benutzen ein iFrame ja wahrscheinlich für YouTube oder?
Ja
Moment
Leute ich habe die Idee
Wir gucken jetzt
Wir gucken jetzt mal
Wir gucken uns jetzt Clemens Kartoffel an
Ohne App gucken wir uns Clemens Kartoffel an
Oh fuck
Moment
Ich muss mir das mal kurz abschreiben
Was haben wir da
YouTube.com
Slash
Embed
B
Oh fuck
Da muss ich mich
B-S-P-H
A-A
Y
L
Zeigen im Video
Wenn ich da jetzt rauf klicke
Dann fängt es tatsächlich an
Aber Clemens
Du bist eine Kartoffel
Das ist
Da bist du rund genau richtig
Yeah
Voll gut
Siehst du
Check check
Jetzt muss ich meine App nur noch in die Stores kriegen
Nur wenn ich keinen größeren Fehler gemacht habe
Wird sie angenommen
Heißt also nochmal zittern
Mach ich
Was würdet ihr eigentlich programmieren
Wenn ihr programmieren könntet
Und eine App rausschicken dürftet
Oh Gott
Das war's
Auf Wiedersehen sage ich
Und ich sage hoffentlich
Nehmen die das an
Ich glaub schon
Also ich bin dir für alles sehr dankbar
Daumen drücken
Bis die App draußen ist
Sorry
Nee
Nicht so
Sondern
So
Okay
Ciao
Leute
Ihr seht mich wahnsinnig aufgeregt
Clemens Kartoffel rastet fast aus
Denn wenn alles gut gegangen ist
Müsste jetzt
Eine kleine Clemens Kartoffel App
Auf diesem Handy sein
Was zur Hölle
Wow
Ey das ist ganz öffentlich
Das ist jetzt nicht nur hier
Das kann man jetzt auf der ganzen Welt
So das laden wir uns jetzt runter
Installiert
Erstmal selbst geliked
Aber hallo
Also ich sag mal so
Als wir das da reingestellt haben
Haben der Alex und ich vielleicht jetzt kein so richtig
Gutes breites Bild gehabt
Und jetzt zieht er ein bisschen dick aus
Naja egal
Let's play
Schön dass ihr da seid
Mein Name ist Ariadne
Hallo Leute
Ihr wisst ja wohl
An welche Art von Leuten ist das Gerichte
Total cringe
Ja da gebt ihr recht
Dass das total cringe ist
An die Leute die gerne
Bayerischen Rundfunk gucken
Was ihr jetzt machen müsst
Diese App runterladen
Wir reden von müssen
Nicht sollen dürfen wollen
Nee
Ja ja
Okay
Okay wo ist die App
App Store
Play Store
Verbindung zum iTunes Store
Wird nicht möglich
Ja
Verbindung zum iTunes Store wird hergestellt
Das zeigt das Ding meistens an
Wenn die App nicht mehr da ist
Aber Android funktioniert
Fünf
Massive
Sind das insgesamt Downloads oder Bewertungen
Poggers
Das sind 5253 Bewertungen
Huge
So hat irgendjemand ne Ahnung
Wie ich
Wie ich ne
Wie ich ne App
Ne APK
Ne APK runtergeladen krieg
Ehm
Vom Play Store ohne mich anzumelden
Gibt's bestimmt irgendwelche fertigen Skripts für die das machen
Ähm
Müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren
Ich muss mir jetzt den Source Code von Clemens Kartoffel angucken
Übrigens gibt ein Update was meine Heizung anbelangt
Wow
Ach nee nicht Localhost
Ähm
Meine Heizung spackt nämlich immer noch rum
Ihr seht's schon wieder
Die Pumpe pumpt nicht
Morgen geht's wieder
Und ich muss jetzt mal
Ich muss jetzt mal
auf, ich hab jetzt sogar im Keller
im Keller noch
eine Kamera installiert
ähm
noch eine Kamera installiert
die mir den Druck von der Heizung anzeigt
die Kamera ist ein bisschen nah dran
deswegen ist es unscharf
ähm
und das Problem ist, der Druck
ich glaub die Heizung ist undicht
sieht aus wie ein Horrorgame
ähm
die Heizung ist undicht, weil
genau Nettoassi, das ist zu wenig
ich hab gestern wieder nachgefüllt, da war das
hier und jetzt ist es
wieder auf 1 runter, ich glaub das Ding ist undicht
an irgendeiner Stelle, ich hab jetzt nämlich innerhalb von
zwei Wochen schon, schon, das
gestern war das dritte Mal
das dritte Mal, ähm
was mag Defekt, was es mag
zumindest ist es
zu wenig drauf, ähm
das ist ziemlich ja, Sack
das heißt morgen
kommt dann der Heizungsman
und guckt sich das mal an, ob das hier
Ausdehnungsgefäß, oh das muss ich mir
das muss ich mir aufschreiben
Ausdehnungsgefäß
der war voll überrascht
mein Heizungs
äh
Heizungsman, als ich ihm erzählt hab
ich werte das ganze aus und hab da jetzt
in den letzten paar Tagen hier ein paar Statistiken drüber
und ich weiß, dass äh
wann der Brenner angeht, dass die Pumpe nicht funktioniert
was die Kesseltemperatur ist
die Abgastemperatur, und da hab ich gesagt
wie kriegen sie das denn raus
und ich hab gesagt, ja ich hab mir so einen Optolink
von Wiesmann bestellt, Raspberry Pi dran angeschlossen
lest das ganze aus, da hat er gesagt, was das geht
das geht, aha
war voll überrascht, äh
das heißt, wenn er morgen vorbeikommt
zeige ich ihm das mal
ähm, was er auch gemeint hat, ist irgendwie
ja, wie alt ist der
boah, keine Ahnung, 60 oder so
ähm, was er gemeint hat, ist ja, er weiß, dass es
von Wiesmann sowas gibt, wo
dass er das dann auch sehen kann
ähm, das Problem ist, dass dieses offizielle
Wiesmann-Zeug halt, ähm
äh,
übelst viel Geld kostet und nicht so gut ist
wie das, was ich selbst gebaut hab
ist das Wasser kalt und die Heizkörper
beziehungsweise Fußboden, ja
ne, das Wasser ist nicht kalt, also das Wasser
aus dem Wasserhahn
wenn ich, wenn ich, ähm
Wasser aufdrehe, das funktioniert
aber die Heizung ist kalt
so, wir laden uns nebenbei
jetzt erstmal hier, ähm
Clemens Kartoffel runter
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es da
Monkartoss-Werbung gibt
hier
drauf
so, Clemens Kartoffel runtergeladen
verkauf ihm
deine Lösung, das Problem an solchen
Lösungen ist, die funktionieren daheim
wunderbar, die mögen
auch zu 99% funktionieren
aber wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, man installiert
sowas mit einer Verfügbarkeit von
99% und
ähm, hat, und hat nur 100 Kunden
da gehen einem laufen die Kunden
auf den Keks, ähm
das was kaputt ist
also sind wir bei einem kaputt
also da, da, da, für, für
ein Heimgebrauch ist das super, super
wenn ich da ab und zu mal gucken muss
im Jahr, weil irgendwas nicht geht, ist okay
aber wenn das der Fachmann verwendet
ähm, dann ist das zu fehleranfällig
was ich hier gestrickt hab
dann ist die
Heizkreis-Umwälzpumpe fest
kannst du die anderen Pumpe für
Warmwasser auch sehen?
oh, das muss ich nachher mal
ausprobieren
die Dinger sind halt ein bisschen doof benannt
das müsste ich nachher mal gucken, weil
ich, da
müsste ich mal schauen
ich kann alle, ich kann die
intern, ich hab, ich kann abfragen
Pumpe 1, Pumpe 2 und Pumpe intern
kann ich alles abfragen, ja
so, wir, wir entpacken jetzt aber erstmal
Clemens Kartoffel
ähm
wie entpackt man Clemens Kartoffel?
kann man einfach so ein APK
achso, easy, einfach so APK entpacken
it's a f
kann man dazu nur sagen
manchmal
manchmal muss ich wirklich sagen
äh
cringe es bei mir selber, äh
wenn ich mich, wenn ich vorm Rechner sitze, ja
und quasi vor mich hin sage
it's a f, it's a f
und mich freue, dann hab ich echt so meine
Zweifel, ob ich echt 35 bin
und noch ganz dicht im Kopf war
Alter, mein Rechner ruckelt übelst rum
was ist denn los?
mein Vorschau-Rechner ruckelt übelst rum
but why?
ah, wegen der Kamera wahrscheinlich
so, ähm äh, Moment, wie, wie, wie
na gut, wenn es ein Zip ist, kann ich einfach unzip machen
ach, ich, oh nee, jetzt hat er alles nach Downloads extrahiert
egit
äh, äh, okay
ich, ich verschieb das nochmal
unzip
so, jetzt aber
also, was haben wir da alles drin?
Bild, nach Bild müssen wir
Bild
Cordova? Ich dachte es ist Ionic
Oder verwendet Ionic Cordova
Irgendwie unter der Haube
Vielleicht
Ich bin mir da nicht so
Android Manifest, Clemens Kartoffel
Also hier ist anscheinend das interessante drin
App.js
Bild
Hier müssten wir reingucken
Oder?
Wo ist hier der interessante
Source Code drin?
Was machst du eigentlich beruflich?
Ich hab dazu ein Video mal gemacht, wenn dich das interessiert
Ausführlich, ich hab da mal
Ein Video zu gemacht und zwar
Noch gar nicht so lang her
Am 18. Oktober 2019
Da hab ich mich 14 Minuten drüber ausgelassen
Was ich auf der Arbeit mach
Kannst du hier bei mir auf Youtube angucken
Wenn du es genau wissen willst
Das ist dann relativ ausführlich
So, wo ist denn jetzt hier das Zeug drin?
Das muss eigentlich unter Bild sein, oder?
Main.js, Main.css
Ich würde mal sagen
Index
Ne, holen wir es mal rein
Assets
Oder wo ist der ganze Kram drunter?
www
Index
Ok, das ist
Boilerblade
Äh, sonst was gedöhnt
Also müssen wir
Bild
Wahrscheinlich können wir uns das nicht angucken, weil es Minified ist
Oder so
Ne, ist es nicht
Import
Kafka Page
The fuck, Alter
Was ist das?
Das ist doch nicht von Hand
Gebastelt hier, oder?
Das ist doch automatisch generiert
Das ist automatisch generiertes
Zusammengefügtes Source-Zeug
Boilerblade
Das ist, äh
Nachschwanger Prototype
Ja gut, den richtigen Source-Code haben wir halt nicht, ne?
Ähm
Haben wir da sonst noch irgendwas Interessantes drin?
Main.css
Before, before, before
Alter
Ah, das ist, das ist, das ist
Alles Ionic Generated
Also den richtigen Source-Code
Den, äh, kriegen wir
An der Stelle nicht
Aber das Index
Wo war denn Index hier noch?
Mal
Irgendwo muss doch, irgendwo muss doch das
Das JavaScript gedöhnt sein
Äh, das, das HTML gedöhnt
Irgendwo muss das HTML gedöhnt sein
Oder ist das HTML gedöhnt
Wie bei React im JavaScript drinne?
Hat sie also doch nicht
Nö
Da stand was von
C-Doppelpunkt-Users-Alex
Wie haben die das da eigentlich zusammen gemacht?
Das wird schon, das
Das würde ich jetzt mal nicht so überbewerten
Wir gucken uns grad die App an aus dem Videobeitrag
Von eben
Äh, doch, doch, das hat die schon selbst gemacht
Das, das sieht, das sieht
Nicht wie war es aus
Bisher, was irgendjemand gemacht hat, hat er schon eine Weile gemacht
Ich denke, man kann das
Mit einem Node-Web-Server starten
Ach ne, ich will das gar nicht ausführen
Ähm, haben wir denn hier
Manifest
Okay, ne, ne, ne, also
Wirklich großartig angucken können wir uns das
Ganze nicht
Das ist halt
Äh, Mini, äh, nicht
Minified, aber zusammengefügt und ein bisschen
Äh, transpiled
Und so, das, das, da können wir
Können wir nicht wirklich viel drin erkennen
Vielleicht können wir aus den Map-Files ein bisschen was raus
Oh, fuck
Das Android-Manifest soll ich mir angucken
Okay
Wo ist denn das?
Hier? Ja, wo ist das?
Meta? Hier?
Das da?
Generated by, ja, das ist
Das ist, das ist sie
Du hast es übersehen
Ach da, da ist es doch, hier
Android-Manifest
Das soll ein XML sein?
Das sieht irgendwie nicht aus wie ein XML
Das ist ein Android-XML
Oh
What?
Was haben wir da sonst noch schönes drin?
Bildchen?
Also ich glaub, dass der schon, dass die das selbst gemacht hat
Das ist jetzt, äh
Nicht so die Huge-Brain-App
Und drei Monate
Kriegt man das hin
Das würde ich da keinem unterstellen, dass das irgendwie gefakt ist
Das, äh, erscheint mir
Jetzt irgendwie
Zumindest halbwegs mit Unterstützung, legit
Wie würdest du das auf der Arbeit bewerten?
Gar nicht
Weil das ist, ich sehe ja den, ich sehe ja den, den ursprünglichen Code nicht
Ich sehe ja
Das, was Ionic da im Endeffekt als Bild raushaut
Da erkennt man gar nichts
Warum sollten die das auch faken?
Ja, da fallen mir ein paar Gründe ein
Ja, weil
Äh, ohne der, ohne die App würde der Beitrag nicht richtig funktionieren
Ähm, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass das gefakt ist
Das macht, irgendwie, irgendwie passt das zusammen
So, was schauen wir denn jetzt als nächstes?
Erstmal, wir lassen mal die Musik, die Musik resetten
Kein Essen oben
Fuck
Was ist der Netz oben rechts?
Lockpicking
Jetzt Blizzard Talk
Also, ich, guck mal
Was wir noch zur Auswahl, zur Auswahl haben
Wir haben irgendwas über den Playstation 4 Emulator
Wir haben, äh, Windows 10 Tipps, die keiner braucht
Wir haben irgendeinen Battlefield 4 Gameplay
Wir haben einen Single Board Computer mit Grafikkarte
Äh, irgendwas zu Doomen
Ein Linux Desktop auf, äh, WSL
Äh, die Top Plays, HRQ Plays, das machen wir mal zu
Das haben wir gerade geguckt
Der App Store hat's rausgeschmissen
Ein paar Lockpicks
Und den Blizzard Talk
Der PS4 Emulator
Wir gucken uns das an, wir gucken uns das an
Wir gucken uns, wir gucken uns die Sachen hier vorher noch an
Weil die gehen bloß eine Viertelstunde
Weil das Blizzard Talk Video geht halt 40 Minuten
Wir gucken uns die zwei Sachen vorher an
Das geht nur 5 Minuten und 10 Minuten
Dann gucken wir uns das Blizzard Talk Video an
Wir haben noch Zeit
Oder seid ihr schon wach?
Hey guys, what is up
Ups
Back to the channel
In today's video, we're gonna be taking a look at something
I've been dying to cover for quite a long time now
We're gonna be taking a look at a Playstation 4 Emulator
In today's overview, I'm going to be concentrating mainly on two emulators
One, which is called Orbital
And the other, which goes by the name of GPCS4
Both of these emulators are still very much so in the early days
Ähm, PS4 Emulator
Ich frag mich gerade
Ob nichts mit einem PS4 Emulator
Prinzipiell einfacher ist
Als mit einem PS3 Emulator
Weil der PS4 ist halt viel, viel näher an einem 9.5. Emulator
Von einem stinknormalen Desktop-System ran
Also du musst zumindest schon mal da keine CPU-Architekturen emulieren
Zwischen PS4 und einem normalen PC
Bei der PS3 sieht das ganz anders aus
Also ich würde so aus
Aus dem Bauch raus sagen
PS3 Emulator ist wahrscheinlich sogar schwieriger als ein PS4 Emulator
Äh, wieso benutzt du eigentlich Windows als Main OS und Linux in der VRM
Weil das die beste Kombination ist
Windows unter Linux ist eklig
Also quasi Windows unter Linux ist eklig
Windows VM unter Linux ist nicht so schön
Wie eine Linux VM unter Windows
Und ich brauche Windows halt für Spiele, ein bisschen Videokram und das ganze Streaming Zeug
Also sprich, ich brauche Software und Geräte, die halt so unter Linux nicht tun
Und dementsprechend ist es einfacher
So, gucken wir weiter
Bisschen lauter
Aber mach, mach ich
Auf Entwicklung, das heißt, sie sind nicht wirklich für den übrigen Anwender gemeint
Oder sie sind zumindest nicht sehr userfreundlich, gerade jetzt
Egal, sie haben in den letzten Monaten noch einen großen Prozess gemacht
So, das ist das, was wir uns in diesem Video anschauen werden
Lass uns uns auf die Orbitale anschauen
Orbitale?
Der Orbitale Emulator begann sein Leben im Jahr 2018
Und seit seiner initialen Eröffnungszeit und Report
Hat er signifikante Verbesserungen gesehen
Zu seinem Colonel VFS
Und ist auch jetzt durchgegangen, wo es Joule-Schock-Support hat
Und jetzt auch Resonanz
Man konnte vorher nicht mehr den Controller verwenden, das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd
Die Playstation 4 GUI
Dank der berühmten Verbesserungen zum Bootloader und der generellen Leistung
Wahrscheinlich laufen darauf gar keine Games
Sie haben jetzt Unterstützung für USB-Storage-Devices
Insbesondere für das interne HDD
Aufgrund dieser GUI-Bedrohungen
Hatten sie auch die Möglichkeit, die Masken-Storage-USB-Device wieder zu installieren
Während Orbitale keine kommerziellen Playstation 4-Games bootet
Ja, das dachten wir
Was sie bis jetzt erreicht haben, ist immer noch super, super beeindruckend
Also bin ich persönlich sehr gespannt, was sich hier passiert wird
Und wie das Projekt in Zukunft so weitergeht
Wenn ihr noch weitere Fragen habt zum Orbitale Emulator
Dann findet ihr die...
Zum Glück sind die PS4, äh, Moment
Ich wollte gerade sagen zum Glück sind die PS4-Keys geleakt
Aber das waren die PS3-Keys
An die Discord-Seite in den Beschreibungen
Warum laufen da keine Spiele?
Wahrscheinlich Verschlüsselung, Kopierschutz und generell das Fehlen vieler Funktionen die Spiele brauchen, das sie überhaupt starten
Auch die Station 4 Emulator, die in den Monat des Jahres entstanden ist, eρχete in die Welt, im Januar 2015
In der Kombination hat er es.
Boah.
Ach so.
Wisst ihr, was ich gerade gedacht habe?
Ich dachte, es wäre nie Automata, bloß mit massiven Grafik-Klitsches.
Aber nee, das ist ein anderes Game.
Das ruckelt ein bisschen.
Okay, es hört echt hardcore kaputt an.
Boah.
Also, in vier Tagen kann man sich da nicht beschweren, ne?
Da Anthem ist nach einem halben Jahr immer noch kaputt.
Oder Wolzen, ne?
Werden sich die neuen Konsolen deiner Meinung nach lohnen?
Die Xbox Series X wird ja zwölf Teraflops haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was bei denen abgeht, dass sie da irgendwie groß mit Teraflops um sich schmeißen.
Damit kann der normale User eh nichts anfangen.
Also, zwölf Teraflops, ich weiß gar nicht, auf was sich das bezieht.
Wahrscheinlich auf die GPU allein oder so, ich weiß nicht.
Also, das ist ungefähr so schnell wie eine 1080 Ti.
So im Dreh.
Was schon ziemlich gut ist im Vergleich zu dem, was damals rausgekommen ist von, äh, bei der letzten Generation.
Also, ich denke schon, dass sie die neuen, äh, die neuen Konsolen...
Die Playstation setzt sich in Deutschland eh durch.
Deutschland, beziehungsweise Europa, aber Deutschland allgemein ist halt Playstation-Land schlechthin.
Spackt das Audio, das liegt an dem Video.
Ähm, ich muss mal übrigens gucken, ob...
Unity Media heute rumspackt.
Nein, Unity Media funktioniert wunderbar.
Meins?
Inwiefern spackt mein Audio rum?
Hab ich mein Noisegate zu empfindlich eingestellt, oder wie?
Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test, Test.
Also, ähm...
Ich muss leiser als so reden, dass es ausschaltet.
Also, sprich...
Sprich, wenn ich so rede, in der Lautstärke, dann ist noch alles an.
Erst, wenn ich leiser rede, dann geht's aus.
Jetzt hier, so ungefähr in der Grö...
In der Größenordnung geht's aus.
Aber nichts, es hat nur wieder was, ja.
Ne, also, äh, ich glaube nicht, dass mein Noisegate ausschaltet, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, guck mal.
Es muss irgendwie hier sein, dass es ausschaltet.
Ich bin da.
Ich mein, aber in vier Tagen das Audio zu fixen, ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Aber so, wie es aussieht, kann man auf dem PS4-Emulator nichts spielen.
Ich habe mehrere aktive und in-Development-Emulators.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere, die ich in den kommenden Wochen und Monaten anschauen werde.
Diese betreffen Spine, die, glaube ich, in diesem Zeitpunkt ein Linux-only-Emulator ist.
Und ich will auch ein paar RPCS-4-Emulatoren anschauen, die eine Art Kollaboration zwischen den RPCS-3- und Orbital-Teams aussehen.
Also, es gibt noch keine ordentlichen PS4-Emulator.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr mir die Themen, die ich beantworten möchte, beantworten möchtet.
Bitte vergesst nicht, sie in den Kommentaren zu schreiben.
Es war in der Tat von den Kommentarsektionen von den vorherigen Videos...
Ja, ich habe übrigens ein paar Subs vergessen.
Lichak11978 hat resubt, äh, XtremeNerd hat resubt, ähm, Burpel hatte ich schon, hat auch resubt.
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs.
Gut.
Gut, Stabs.
...that you guys made me aware of several of these emulators.
So, as I said, if there is anything that has piqued your interest or that interests you...
Ja, ich meine, das sind immerhin, immerhin 12 FPS, mehr sieht das Auge eh nicht.
...be afraid to let me know about it down below.
Further to this, we...
Wie man ja offensichtlich sieht, ihr seht, ihr könnt ja alle gar nicht erkennen, dass das ruckelt.
...very nice and growing Discord community.
So, if that's the kind of thing that interests you, down in the description, you will also find a link to my own...
Okay, ja, das hat jetzt...
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch den Single-Bot-Computer an.
What's going on, guys? It's ETA Prime back here again. I think I found the perfect use for...
WTF, was ist das?
Kek.
What's going on, guys? It's ETA Prime back here again. I think I...
What?
Da ist die Grafiker, der hat zehnmal so groß wie das Ding.
...found the perfect use for the GTX 1650.
Irgendwie sieht lautstark aus, kacke.
This is a low-powered card. A lot of people have been complaining about this. It's a newer NVIDIA card for around $150.
Now, this particular model that I have here is the Zotac GTX 1650, and it does not require any external power.
So, it doesn't have a 6-pin or an 8-pin net.
All the power is delivered through the PCI-E slot, and it's got a TDP of 75 watts.
So, what I have here is one of my favorite Single-Bot-Computers connected to this GTX 1650.
This is the Latte Panda Alpha, and we're gonna go over the specs real quick.
Was kostet so ein Ding?
Was? Latte? Panda? Alpha?
Boah!
WTF?
What?
Warum sollte ich sowas kaufen für den Preis?
What the... Was ist denn da drauf?
Was ist denn da... Okay, okay.
Vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen so schnell.
Was ist denn da an Hardware drauf?
Äh...
Core M3? Das ist irgendein Mobile-Ding?
Weil die CPU ist ordentlich, RAM ist auch ordentlich.
Das ist schon ganz okay von der Hardware, aber
das ist schon ein ordentlicher Preis für ein Single-Bot-Computer.
Ich glaube, der hauptsächliche
der hauptsächliche Vorteil davon
dürfte halt eben tatsächlich die Größe...
Aber trotzdem, äh...
Man kann sich über den Anwendungszweck streiten,
aber gucken wir mal, was rauskommt.
Ich denke, der 1650 ist ein guter
Wettbewerb für diesen kleinen Single-Bot-Computer.
Der NUC ist nicht viel größer, ja, ich weiß.
Ich habe mir absichtlich keinen NUC gekauft
für die neue Kiste hier, weil ich
Erweiterung gebraucht habe.
Das ist halt gut.
Das ist halt ein PCI Express, ein NUC hat keinen PCI Express.
Das ist halt gut. Das ist halt ein PCI Express, ein NUC hat keinen PCI Express.
Die Leistung ist großartig, weil es so klein ist
Die LattePanda ist ein tolles
x86-gearbeitetes Single-Bot-Computer und in der Box
kriegst du die LattePanda und deinen USB-Type-C
Power-Adapter.
Das ist so, wie wir die LattePanda powern.
Es gibt andere Wege, aber aus der Box
benutzt du den USB-Type-C.
Die Basispekte sind so wie folgt.
Die CPU ist ein Intel Core-
Wartet mal.
Wartet mal, Moment.
Ja, was nun?
Läuft das jetzt über USB?
Der Strom oder über einen Stecker?
Oder geht beides?
Man kann es darüber betreiben
oder darüber betreiben.
Es ist 8 USB, aber es ist ein Stecker dran.
... in der Box benutzt du den USB-Type-C.
Ah, okay.
Die Basispekte sind so wie folgt.
Die CPU ist ein Intel Core M3 7Y30.
Das ist eine Dual-Core-CPU.
4 Ströme, bis zu 4,6 GHz.
8 GB LPDDR3 und...
Ich weiß nicht, was ein Core M3 ist, aber das dürfte wahrscheinlich
die Mobile-Variante
von einem i3 sein.
LPDDR3?
Okay, der RAM ist uralt.
... 1866.
24 GB internal Storage, aber man kann
eine SD-Karte und einen externen Harddrive
oder einen M.2 SSD anbieten.
Das ist ganz schön teuer.
Ich meine, das ist halt klein.
Das mag der Vorteil sein, aber ich wüsste
nicht, wo... Also ich habe gerade wirklich
legit keinen Anwendungszweck
dafür.
Weil meistens ist die Leistung gar nicht
das, was man braucht,
sondern halt der Formfaktor.
Deswegen ist ja so ein Raspberry Pi
Zero... Ich habe mehr Zeros
im Einsatz als normale Raspberry...
Wobei... Nee, stimmt nicht.
Stimmt nicht.
Ähm... Zumindest, ich finde den Raspberry
Pi Zero an sich praktischer als
die normalen. Einfach, weil man den
sogar in...
in Steckdosen reinkriegt.
Oh, mach kurz.
So.
Wie viele Pis hast du denn am Laufen?
Lass mal überlegen. Ich glaube, drei Stück gerade.
Einen am 3D-Drucker, einen
für die Access Points, einen
im Keller für die Heizung
und hier oben ab und zu ein paar Dinger zum Testen.
Aber so wirklich 24-7 und
mit wichtigen Funktionen laufen gerade
drei Stück.
Was ein bisschen mehr läuft, sind ESP
2866 und ESP 32.
Ah, yes.
Beste.
Mit so Dingen haben wir hier auch schon rumhantiert,
wer sich noch daran erinnert.
Das sieht dann immer ein bisschen falsch aus.
Das sieht immer ein bisschen falsch aus,
wenn man die Netzwerkkarte verkehrt herum
auf dem Mainboard hat.
Was? Für die ACPO
haben die nicht den hohen Flaschenhals?
Äh... Was?
Und das alles über USB-C?
Ja, genau.
Nee, nicht über USB-C.
Anscheinend ist ja nur die Stromversorgung
über USB-C. Der Rest nicht.
Ah.
Davon... Die Dinger sind wirklich gut.
Davon habe ich auch ein paar.
Habe ich euch ja gezeigt.
Sogar meine neue
Kiste, die ich jetzt...
Ich glaube, man sieht was.
Man sieht nicht viel, man sieht...
Man sieht, wo ich den Kram
reingeschmissen habe ins Gehäuse.
Aber man sieht hier auch, das ist auch so eine Pico...
Pico PSU.
Das ist einfach random ins Gehäuse
reingeschmissen, der Kram.
Äh...
Wie hat der denn 16X
in 4X bekommen? Einfach aufgeschnitten
hinten. Oder aber
es ist offen.
Das müssen wir uns mal angucken. Hat man das hier gesehen?
Äh, ja.
Guck, der 4X-Slot ist hinten offen.
Kannst du einfach reinstecken.
Guck dann halt hinten raus.
Das geht. Das geht.
Ist kein Problem.
Du sagst, du hast Raspberry Pi als WiFi-Point.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ich hab, ähm...
Ich hab den Raspberry Pi
als, als, ähm...
Web-Interface für meine
Access-Points. Also mein
UniFi-Controller läuft auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Äh, da läuft dann auch
die, die, die Kamera-Software läuft auch auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Und ein paar andere kleine Sachen.
Ein MQTT-Controller läuft auch auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Nee, aber hauptsächlich ist der für da
für die Access-Points.
Ich hab zwei, ich hab zwei
UniFi-AP...
Ich hab ein AE Pro und ein
und den neuen AE Pro.
Ich find das immer so geil, wenn die das ausprobieren.
Molex, SATA...
Das sieht irgendwie ein bisschen falsch aus,
das USB-C da dran.
Aber warum nicht, ne? Ich mein, da ist ja keine Daten drüber.
Das ist ja einfach nur Strom.
Machst du auf deinen Raspberry Pi's
regelmäßig von Hand Updates?
Regelmäßig, unregelmäßig
mach ich da drauf Updates, ja.
4 Monate, dankeschön.
Huge, huge sub.
Dankeschön.
Ja, ja, wir haben's verstanden.
So komplex ist das Ganze jetzt auch nicht.
Also ich mein...
Wir haben's verstanden, wie der Kram angeschlossen ist.
Corona.
Ja.
Ja, ja, gut!
Das Gebäude ist
ein Software-Programm.
Ein·Zetteler.
Ich würde sagen,
es ist eineázene
illegale
Schmiedekamera,
weil sie auf stop-down durchc chaîne
Ich meine, performancemäßig, ne,
ist das Ding natürlich
meilenweit besser
als jeder Raspberry Pi,
als
sonst so ziemlich jeder andere
ARM-basierter
Single-Bot-Computer,
besser als ein Shield TV
und besser als sonst was.
Also wer irgendwie so einen
High-Performance-Media-Center
braucht, ist das wahrscheinlich
gar nicht,
das ist auch besser als ein Raspberry Pi-Cluster.
Also so ein, was ist denn das,
ein Vierkern, ne, jetzt hat man ja
M3, oh, fuck.
Was, Core, Core,
M3, was war da
drinne? Ah, Dual-Core
ist das, trotzdem. Also
performancemäßig dürfte das Ding schon ordentlich
Power haben im Vergleich zu den Alternativen.
Allerdings
ist halt die Frage,
inwieweit man das braucht.
So ein Shield TV ist halt eine super Sache
oder wenn man es günstiger haben will,
so ein Fire-TV-Stick, wenn man ein Media-Center
braucht. Also, und wenn man halt richtig was
spielen will, richtig Power haben will,
dann stellt man sich halt ein kleines Gehäuse hin
mit aktueller Desktop-Hardware hin.
Also der Anwendungszweck erschließt sich mir
noch nicht so hundertpro, aber es ist cool, dass es geht.
Ja gut, wenn du ein Raspberry Pi-Cluster
aus 72 Stück hinstellst,
dann hast du wahrscheinlich schon theoretisch
schnellere CPU-Leistung, aber du musst den Kram
erstmal sinken.
Jetzt kommt erstmal Cortana
und nervt.
Okay, das sind zwei
Cores mit Hyper-Threading, oder?
Okay, was ist das ein M3?
7Y30
M3
Okay, was ist da drin?
2016, okay,
schon ein bisschen her.
Number of Cores, ja, Dual-Core
mit Hyper-Threading ist das hier.
Curved Display.
Wir haben hier ein Kurs, das ist ein Kurs, das ist ein Kurs, das ist ein Kurs, das ist ein Kurs, das ist ein Kurs, das ist ein Kurs, das ist ein Kurs, das ist ein Kurs.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit ein Curved Display,
was
wirklich verdammt
ähnlich zu dem hier aussieht, bloß, dass es
ein 21 zu 9
Display ist.
Dabei könnte das ja auch sein.
Es ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Es ist gewöhnungsbedürftig,
aber es fällt
einem eigentlich gar nicht mehr auf, nachdem
man eine Weile davor gesessen hat.
Das muss man bei mir auf der Arbeit
wirklich lassen. Die Arbeitsplätze
sind echt in Ordnung.
21,9
21 Zoll, äh, nicht 21 Zoll,
21 zu 9,
was ist jetzt 32 Zoll, 4 Kabel
Schirm, leider nur
60 Hertz, ja, also
ihr wisst es, ich hätte gerne lieber mehr, aber
das war damals noch nicht drin.
Ein höhenverstellbarer Schreiblicht,
ein ordentliches Notebook, das ist ganz in Ordnung.
Also, wir können ruhigen Gewissens
in die Stellenbeschreibung schreiben,
moderner Arbeitsplatz, und es ist wirklich
ein moderner Arbeitsplatz, schreiben aber alle rein.
Das geht.
Das geht, das dürfte,
also, 1080p spielen,
damit dürfte kein großes Problem, das sollte wunderbar
funktionieren, kommt halt auf das Game und die
Grafiksettings an, aber prinzipiell ist es kein Problem.
Ja, das
funktioniert, das wundert
mich auch nicht, dass es geht.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn man sich die Specs
anguckt, surpreist mich das überhaupt nicht.
Erstens läuft das Spiel prinzipiell gut,
und die Kombi aus hier einem
halbwegs modernen
Dual-Core, ich meine, okay, 2016, aber
aus einem halbwegs modernen Dual-Core und einer
ganz guten Grafikkarte, kein Wunder,
dass das läuft. Kommt nicht bald,
das neue Doom.
Oh, Rennspiele.
Residenz-Retail-Rennspiele.
80, 90% Last,
der ist doch gut, und schafft's wenigstens
was, das Ding.
Die Grafikkarte wird's wahrscheinlich nicht
limitieren, eher die CPU.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ist das das GTA?
Ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das geht schon in Ordnung.
Ha, der hat
jetzt nicht wirklich ausgepiepst, oder?
Gut.
Also ganz ehrlich, CS läuft
auf dem Taschenrechner mittlerweile.
Massive Headshots.
Leute,
habt ihr das gerade gehört?
Man hört den Reload-Sound, aber er reloadet
nicht.
Oder ist das gar nicht der Reload?
Das ist gar nicht der Reload-Sound.
Das ist eine Tastatur gewesen.
Quick-Fighting-Game, Marvel vs. Capcom,
Infinite, 1080p,
Medium-Settings, Constant-60,
and I'm pretty sure we could've went to high with this,
but I didn't want any lag in this game.
Doom 1 läuft auf einer Regelung von der Heizung.
Ja, Doom 1 läuft echt auf allem.
Doom 1 läuft auch auf dem Drucker.
Auf irgendeinem Epson-Drucker hat das
einen auf dem Display zum Laufen gebracht.
Ja.
Jetzt kommen wir das gleich danach.
And finally, for the PC-Gaming
side of things, we have Skyrim
remastered, 1080p, Medium-Settings.
Es gibt keine Plattform mehr, auf der
es kein Skyrim gibt.
Dann müssen wir ein paar Mods installieren,
dann hat er 5 FPS.
Ja, okay, wir haben es jetzt verstanden,
dass das läuft.
Das stimmt, dafür ist es wahrscheinlich
wirklich ziemlich praktisch.
Also halt, jetzt,
nicht unbedingt jetzt für den Switch-Emulator
oder so, aber halt für...
Das ist etwas unter, weil wir dieses 4x3-Ratio haben.
Leider ist dieses System nicht gut
für PS2 oder SimU,
weil es genau am CPU-Gipfel ist.
Es gibt einige Spiele, die auf beiden Systemen
funktionieren werden, aber es ist nicht erwartet,
dass sie auf jedem System funktionieren.
Aber Gamecube und Wii-Emulation
mit Dolphin ist großartig,
sofern die Spiele mit dem Emulator kompatibel sind,
der System wird es geben.
Das ist Mario Kart Double Dash
auf 1080p.
Also, das wird basically
in jedem System unter dem Gamecube
außer PS2.
Wenn ihr PSP oder sogar Sega Saturn
machen wollt, wird es es.
Michael, 50 Billionen
abonniere Twitch Prime.
Fünf Monate, huge sub.
Prime,
Samus Climber.
Dankeschön.
Also, overall,
der GTX 1650
passt mit der Latte Panna
für 99 Cent die Woche.
Leute,
ist das wirklich so?
99 Cent die Woche,
Amazon Prime,
was man damit alles machen kann.
Wow, now I wouldn't expect you
to go out and build
something like this
just for gaming.
You can get out a lot cheaper
and have more power
by buying used parts.
Also, den Anwendungszweck
sehe ich nicht wirklich.
Get an old OptiPlex
with a third-gen i5.
But, if you already have
a Latte Panna Alpha
or you were dead set
on buying one,
just know that you can add
some pretty decent
GPU performance
by adding an external GPU,
like the
GTX 1650.
So, that's pretty much
it for this video, guys.
I really appreciate
you watching.
I'm gonna leave links
for everything I need.
Es ist cool, auf jeden Fall,
dass das geht
und dass das so tut,
aber so einen wirklichen
Anwendungszweck dafür
habe ich nicht.
So, Leute,
ich habe es versprochen,
wir gucken auf das GameStar-Video.
Auf geht's.
Aber was haben wir denn hier?
40 Minuten Maurice,
der über Blizzard meckert.
Das kann ja nur was taugen.
Die Aufgaben vom BND,
nee, das haben wir
noch nicht ausprobiert.
Oh, ein bisschen leise, hä?
Aber es war lang nicht,
die einzige in letzter Zeit.
Von Diablo Immortal
bis zu der Hongkong-Kontroverse.
Oh, das Video ist aber
übelst leise.
Die Firma stolpert
von einem Shitstorm
in den nächsten.
Was zum Geier ist da los
mit einem Entwickler,
der früher doch eigentlich
Das Video ist übelst leise.
nichts falsch machen konnte.
Das will ich mit
zwei alten Blizzard-Fans
besprechen.
Ich mache gleich
noch einen Ticken lauter.
Aber wir müssen erst mal gucken,
wie laut die anderen Beine
eingestellt sind.
... meinen Kollegen
Clape und René.
Hallo.
Hi, Maurice.
Und, äh, Clape,
fangen wir doch mal
mit dir an.
Du als langjähriger
Blizzard-Fan,
du hast ja sogar
die Server-Downshow
damals gemacht und alles.
Was ist dein Bild
vom aktuellen Blizzard?
Hast du das Gefühl,
das ist eine Firma,
die seine Community
nicht mehr versteht?
Jetzt haben sie
sich richtig eingestellt.
Puh, äh, äh,
hast ja gleich mal
ein Flaggschiff.
Okay, was?
Okay, okay, Moment.
Jetzt habe ich dir
überhaupt nicht zugehört.
... Downshow damals gemacht
und alles.
Was ist dein Bild
vom aktuellen Blizzard?
Hast du das Gefühl,
das ist eine Firma,
die seine Community
nicht mehr versteht?
Doch, Blizzard
versteht ihre Community.
Naja, was heißt
Blizzard versteht
ihre Community?
Äh, Blizzard,
Blizzard,
also das ist das Gleiche
wie bei Call of Duty.
Da muss ich jetzt mal
kurz was zu sagen.
Das ist das Gleiche,
wie immer bei Call of Duty
rumgeflamed wird.
Die würden das nicht verstehen
und die würden nicht
auf das Feedback
der Fans hören.
Doch, ich glaube schon,
dass die das mitkriegen,
aber, ähm,
die machen vieles
einfach nicht,
weil es Blizzard
nicht mehr darum geht,
die möglichst best,
das möglichst,
möglichst, ähm,
beste aus, aus,
ja, sagen wir mal,
Hardcore-Gaming-Perspektive
abzuliefern,
sondern das,
was Kohle macht.
Als Nass,
na, trotzdem,
als Nass
würde ich auch was anderes
verwenden.
Die Stonks sind wichtiger,
so sieht's aus.
Spielst du noch Overwatch?
Nee, schon eine ganze
Weile nicht mehr.
Puh, äh,
hast du dir gleich mal
ein Flaggschiff
überlegt,
um so zu starten?
Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Also, äh,
ich glaube nicht,
dass Blizzard
die Community
nicht mehr versteht.
Ich glaube nur,
dass Blizzard, äh,
mehr als früher
einfach, äh,
vor allen Dingen
durch die ganze,
den Firmenzusammenstoß,
Kohle machen.
Ähm,
mit Activision Blizzard
mehr auf Dinge guckt,
die sich irgendwie rechnen
und was man tun muss,
um Geld zu verdienen.
So sieht's aus.
Und wie,
wie sehr es sich lohnt,
in bestimmte Dinge zu investieren,
sei es jetzt neue Projekte,
sei es, äh,
Innovation oder so.
Schade,
du hast einen stabilen Lucio gespielt,
das ist schön zu hören.
Naja,
aber ich kann mir
Overwatch jetzt nicht geben,
da,
es tut sich in dem Game
einfach zu wenig.
...bestimmten,
ja,
Status zu halten,
ähm,
was jetzt die Qualität
von den
Blizzard-Produkten
wie man mehr Geld verdient,
wenn man das Spiel
als Produkt sieht,
angeht,
bin ich nach wie vor der Meinung,
dass das ganz,
ganz oben ist,
bei dem,
was man so
auf den Markt sieht.
Vielleicht sind die einen
oder anderen Releases
problematisch,
ja,
das haben wir jetzt ja
neulich erst gesehen,
ähm,
aber ich sag mal,
das eigentliche Spiel,
ja,
die Crispiness,
wie es immer so schön,
äh,
da genannt wird
und,
ähm,
das Gameplay.
Blizzard,
Blizzard hat halt so ein bisschen
die,
diese magische Aura verloren,
was die Sachen,
äh,
von Blizzard früher umgeben hat.
Ich glaub,
das trifft's eigentlich ganz gut.
Das hatte schon
Overwatch nicht mehr richtig,
ähm,
mein,
ist halt mein Eindruck
bei der ganzen Sache,
das hatte schon Overwatch
nicht mehr richtig,
aber Overwatch war wenigstens,
war wenigstens was Innovatives
an sich,
ja,
ähm,
mach die Maus da weg,
nee,
geht nicht.
Und so weiter,
das,
das ist schon immer noch
ganz weit oben.
Problem ist halt ein bisschen
die Innovation,
die,
äh,
von diesem Konzern eben
nicht mehr so kommt,
wie man sie sich erwünscht hat.
Allerdings,
wenn man mal genau hinschaut,
äh,
kommt auch,
das,
das Zitat,
Innovation is overrated,
ja auch von Blizzard,
weil sie eigentlich
relativ wenig Innovationen
in die Anzahl gemacht haben.
Blizzard hat schon viel erzählt
jetzt,
20 Jahre.
Eigentlich haben sie ja nur
von den Besten geklaut,
in Anführungszeichen,
und das dann einfach refined,
bis es wirklich richtig,
richtig super war.
Insofern,
ich glaub schon,
ähm,
dass Blizzard,
also,
grad der kreative Teil,
er guckt so ein bisschen,
wieso,
ich möchte auch was gefragt werden.
Was denn Spieler wollen?
Sie haben ja auch ihren eigenen,
ihre eigenen 10 oder 12 Regeln da,
äh,
also,
so wie so eine,
10 Gebote,
nach denen sie sich da,
wo sie sich auch fügen möchten.
Wie sowas?
Nur,
letztendlich ist auch immer die Frage,
ist das was,
was denn am Ende Geld verdient?
Mhm.
Wobei ich schon das Gefühl hab,
dass,
also,
die Produktqualität ist die eine Sache,
aber in der Kommunikation,
vor allem,
hab ich das Gefühl,
dass Blizzard sich schon sehr viele,
Und,
und Blizzard ist halt auch mittlerweile
ein relativ großer Laden.
Man darf nicht vergessen,
Blizzard hat Hearthstone am Start,
Heroes of the Storm,
wobei Heroes of the Storm
ist jetzt ein bisschen,
ein bisschen,
zurückgegangen.
Ähm,
Starcraft,
WoW,
also,
die haben sau viel Sachen am Start.
Ähm,
das machst du nicht mal mit 40 Leuten.
Fehltritte geleistet hat in letzter Zeit,
zum Beispiel,
dass jetzt Diablo Immortal
vielleicht nicht gut ankommen würde,
wenn du seit Jahren nichts anderes zu Diablo,
die Mobile,
sie hatten natürlich Fairness halber
nichts anderes anzukündigen,
aber,
dass sie völlig überrumpelt waren davon,
dass ihre Hardcore-Audience das blöd fand,
auf ihre Hausmesse,
dass da nur ein Mobile-Spiel kommt,
das finde ich Zeug schon so ein bisschen davon,
also,
bist du,
das war doch,
hätte sich jeder denken können,
war so mein erster Gedanke,
ich saß ja im Publikum damals,
äh,
und jetzt genauso auch bei Warcraft 3 Reforged,
wie du sagst,
da werden wahrscheinlich
rechnerische Gedanken dahinterstehen,
dass man sagt,
okay,
so viel Aufwand lohnt das nicht,
aber das dann irgendwie
überhaupt nicht kommuniziert zu kriegen,
an die Spieler in einer Form,
die den Shitstorm auch nur annähern.
Ich hab's,
ich hab's schon so oft gesagt,
wenn's um diese Diablo-Geschichte geht,
ne,
die hätten einfach nur Diablo 4 teasern müssen,
so wie die es mit Elder Scrolls gemacht haben,
und die hätten auch einfach drei Stunden,
drei,
drei Jahre nichts mehr sagen können danach,
ist egal.
Die hätten,
die hätten Immobile angekündigt,
äh,
Immortal angekündigt,
und hätten sie gesagt,
übrigens,
Diablo 4,
bam,
und fertig.
Quasi eindämmen kann,
und das ist ja in letzter Zeit doch oft mehrfach schon bei Blizzard gewesen,
dass sie in solchen Fällen,
vielleicht auch,
weil Blizzard früher solche Fälle gar nicht so oft hatte,
nicht wissen musste,
wie man mit den Spielern spricht,
und es gab ja auch,
oder,
nee?
Das ist vielleicht der gute,
der gute Punkt,
ähm,
Blizzard früher war ja sehr,
auch,
ähm,
sehr strikt,
also in seiner eigenen Kommunikation,
auch sehr zurückhaltend,
also,
in uns alles dauerte immer sehr lange,
bis,
äh,
Dinge gezeigt wurden,
zum Beispiel Starcraft 2 damals,
wurde ja ge...
Dafür war der Kram,
wenn Blizzard irgendwas in der Beta rausgebracht hat,
ich,
mein Overwatch,
als es in der Beta rausgekommen hat,
das war technisch,
und von dem,
wie das lief,
und online-mäßig,
äh,
besser als,
als viele fertige Spiele,
ähm,
und eins kann man Overwatch wirklich nicht,
nicht,
nicht nachsagen,
auch wenn ich es nicht mehr spiele,
und auch wenn man das vom Inhalt her mittlerweile ein bisschen auf den Keks geht,
aber,
technisch ist Overwatch,
vor allem was Netzwerk-mäßig angeht,
saumäßig gut.
Also,
ich hatte in Overwatch,
im Vergleich zu allen anderen Multiplayer-Spielen,
seltenst,
wirklich seltenst,
das Gefühl,
äh,
ich hab auf den Sack gekriegt,
weil irgendwas nicht richtig registriert hat,
oder weil irgendwas nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Klar,
hat Overwatch,
die,
ähm,
ein oder anderen Sachen,
die auch online,
ich mein,
es ist online,
da kann immer mal ein bisschen was schief gehen,
aber,
Overwatch-Netzwerktechnik ist wirklich gut,
da können sich viele eine Scheibe von abschneiden,
das funktioniert einfach erstklassig.
Holy Dich gibt's immer noch,
ja,
oh,
mich gibt's schon,
mich gibt's schon ganz schön lang,
und auch,
auch immer noch,
ja,
und mich gibt's hoffentlich auch noch eine Weile.
Man weiß ja nicht,
Corona in Hessen und sowas,
aber,
ich hoffe,
ich überlebe das noch ein bisschen.
Bis,
äh,
Dinge gezeigt wurden,
zum Beispiel StarCraft,
äh,
StarCraft 2 damals,
wurde ja,
glaube ich,
was war's,
in Paris oder in Korea,
ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau,
aber es wurde eigentlich gezeigt,
als es schon fast,
zweifelsohne,
fertig war,
ja,
also,
dass man sehr lange,
und sehr behutsam immer gewesen ist,
in den Interviews,
auch in der BlizzCon,
als ich mit den Entwicklern,
äh,
oft gesprochen habe,
war auch immer zu merken,
das ist alles super auf Kontrolle ausgelegt.
Ich hab teilweise das Gefühl,
dass das eben in der heutigen Zeit
Ihnen schwerer fällt,
äh,
überhaupt auch über alle Projekte,
die Sie nun mal haben.
Naja,
also,
da,
dazu muss ich sagen,
Blizzard früher,
also,
ganz früher,
wir reden jetzt nicht von 2012 oder so,
sondern noch davor,
da haben die Entwickler einfach oftmals erzählt,
was sie,
äh,
was sie bewegt hatten,
was sie wollten.
Wer sie,
vielleicht kann sich noch einer dran erinnern,
wo,
äh,
Jeff Kaplan,
also sprich der Overwatch-Man,
der war ja früher bei,
bei World of Warcraft dabei,
als der,
ähm,
irgendeinen WoW-Raid vorgestellt hat,
ey,
der hat auf,
der hat auf der BlizzCon
gestanden
und gesagt,
öffentlich auf der BlizzCon,
das würden die sich heute überhaupt nicht mehr trauen,
dass er schlechte Spieler aus der Gruppe kickt.
Das hat er wirklich auf der Bühne erzählt damals.
Das wäre in der heutigen Zeit undenkbar.
Die Leute wären heute so ultra getriggert,
würde einer auf der BlizzCon stehen
und sagen,
kickt schlechte Leute aus der Gruppe.
Das hat die damals nicht gejuckt.
Und das fand ich auch ehrlich gesagt viel besser.
Ja, auch so eine Sache.
Früher hatte Blizzard fast immer nur so ein Ding,
dann das nächste Ding,
dann das nächste Ding.
Jetzt haben sie halt viele Titel,
die parallel laufen,
parallel betrieben werden müssen.
Das ist auch ein Punkt,
ja, das stimmt.
Und da geht dann auch ein bisschen eben der Überblick
und auch die Kontrolle im Sinne von,
was mache ich,
wie kommt das an,
kann ich gerade aktuell nichts zu sagen,
Planung und so weiter ein bisschen zu kurz
und vielleicht auf den Punkt zu fragen,
weil du sagtest,
versteht Blizzard seine Community noch?
Vielleicht für die heutige Runde
wird es ja auch ein bisschen das sein,
versteht denn die Community Blizzard?
Oh ja,
ich verstehe Blizzard schon,
warum die manche Sachen machen.
Das heißt ja nicht,
dass es mir gefallen muss.
Das ist natürlich für den Spieler
nicht wirklich wichtig,
aber darüber wollen wir ja ein bisschen reden.
Was sind denn vielleicht Gründe,
egal ob die gut oder schlecht sind,
aber einfach ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkel bringen.
Wie kommt es denn dazu,
dass diese Dinge vielleicht auch passieren?
Wartet mal kurz.
Oder aber auch an manchen Punkten zu sagen,
vielleicht sind sie für uns als Core-Fans,
also die wirklich von Anfang an,
von irgendwie vom ersten Warcraft,
über alles, was danach kam,
von eben den Tieden davor,
alles immer mitverfolgt haben.
Vielleicht ist es im Großen und Ganzen,
weltweit gesehen.
Hat er eine Max Payne?
Ist das eine Max Payne-Tasse?
Nee, oder was ist das für eine Tasse?
Max?
Welcher Max?
Also von mir ist die definitiv nicht.
Was hat er da am Start?
X-Mas?
Weihnachten?
Vielleicht, ja.
Öffnen wir im Hintergrund was.
Das Ding am 8.
Nicht so relevant.
Also welchen Impact hat denn jetzt wirklich dieses oder jenes auf die Sache?
Und?
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das Zitat geht,
aber so nach dem Motto,
man sollte nicht hinter allem, was passiert,
immer einen großen Masterplan verstehen.
Manchmal sind wir auch nicht im Du.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Da hat er recht.
Das Zitat ist doch irgendwie, schreibe niemals.
Da ist, ich gehe ganz stark davon aus,
dass vieles weniger durch, also was wir so zu hören bekommen,
vieles nicht so durchdacht ist, wie man, wie man das teilweise vermutet.
Manches ist da einfach auch ein Schnellschuss.
So nach dem Motto, oh Gott, die Fans regen sich jetzt aus,
äh, auf, äh, Shitstorm am an, sich zusammenbrauen,
ähm, lasst mal irgendwas raushauen.
Und das, das ist schon überlegt, aber wahrscheinlich nicht so
der Wahnsinns-Big-Brain-Plan, wie man oftmals denkt.
Da, da gäbe ich ihm schon, da gäbe ich ihm zu,
was sich auch durch Dummheit erklären lässt.
Und zum Beispiel die Immortal-Geschichte, würde ich sagen,
Ja, das war einfach blöd.
war pure ...
Das war einfach blöd.
nicht sich damit richtig mal auseinandersetzen,
was es denn jetzt heißt, diesen Shift zu machen.
Sondern ich glaube, das war einfach aus,
ich will nicht Arroganz nennen oder so,
aber aus einer gewissen Selbstsicherheit
und Selbstzufriedenheit.
Ja, da, da hat er recht.
Wie damals eben, und das geht allen Großen, äh, so.
Das hat ein Apple schon hingekriegt.
Das hat ein Microsoft, ne, Xbox One, äh, hingekriegt.
Das hat ein Playstation.
Nach ihrem Mega-Erfolg mit der Playstation 2
waren sie halt sehr cocky bei der Playstation.
Ja, ja, ja.
600, zahlt mal!
So, und ich glaube, das ist bei Blizzard auch so ein, äh, Thema.
An manchen Punkten wissen sie vielleicht auch selbst nicht,
wer sie noch sind und wie ihre Wahrnehmung da draußen ist.
Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist dieses Immortal-Ding zumindest,
glaube ich, voll darauf zurückzuführen,
hey, ihr nehmt doch eh, wenn wir Diablo raufschreiben,
dann, dann liebt ihr uns, dann jubelt ihr.
Ähm, und ich denke, das ist jetzt auch eher so ein Lernprozess,
mal ein bisschen wieder ...
Ich denke, da hat er recht.
Ja, das glaube ich auch, dass sie sich gedacht haben, so nach dem Motto,
ey, alle, alle lechzen nach einem neuen Diablo,
warum soll man, warum soll man ein neues Diablo nicht auf dem Handy machen?
Und die, die Sache mit ihr habt ihr keine, habt ihr keines, habt ihr keine Handys,
das hat der ernst gemeint.
Das war nicht irgend so eine Beschwichtigungssache,
das war, das, das hat er sich, das hat er wirklich ernst gemeint.
Der hat sich gedacht, hä, wie, wie kann man sich darüber aufregen?
Ihr habt doch alle Handys und das ist doch eigentlich die logischste Sache der Welt,
dass man Diablo auf dem Handy spielt.
Oh, okay, alles, äh ...
wird uns nicht verziehen und alles geht einfach auch nicht.
Und wie gesagt, vielleicht kommen wir da ein bisschen hin, so eigentlich,
was ist der Grund, warum Blizzard jetzt so handelt oder eben so agiert,
wie sie das einfach tun?
Mhm. Es gab ja durchaus dann auch ein paar, sag ich mal,
bisschen handfestere Schlappen für das Studio.
Zum Beispiel hat man gemerkt, Heroes of the Storm war offensichtlich ein Problem,
das war nicht der Erfolg, den sie sich erhofft haben.
Jetzt, es läuft ja immer noch,
es ist irgendwie so, man, man kapiert es selber nicht ganz so.
Aber das ist, da haben sie, da haben sie es wieder,
da kamen die Stonks-Typen von Blizzard wieder an den Start, ne?
Ähm, es waren alle guter Dinge, Heroes of the Storm, ähm,
die letzte, die letzte Season von ihrer Pro League war, glaube ich, ganz gut
und es haben sich alle drauf gefreut, vielleicht wird nächstes Jahr, äh,
oder es waren sich eigentlich alle irgendwie sehr zuversichtlich,
nächstes Jahr wird noch besser.
Ich meine, noch besser bedeutet nicht, wir können auch nur ansatzweise,
sie hätten auch nur ansatzweise mit LoL oder Dota oder CS oder irgendwas anderem,
mithalten können, das nicht, aber halt besser als das Jahr davor.
Und das ganze Ding wurde eingestellt, so, ähm, so shady irgendwie alles,
dass noch nicht mal die Spieler im Vorfeld, geschweige denn die Team-Owner
oder irgendwie einer da, noch nicht mal die Mitarbeiter wussten das vorher.
Und da haben sie sich überhaupt nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert,
weil wohl einige, ähm, äh, News-Redakteure, Journalisten,
wussten Bescheid über interne Blizzard-Quellen, halt eben aus
dem, aus dem Stonks-Office-Bereich und nicht aus dem Entwicklerbereich,
dass dieser Move kommt, bevor es die eigenen Mitarbeiter,
bevor es die eigenen, äh, Teams wussten teilweise.
Das war schon ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Semi eingestellt worden, wir haben die E-Sport-Szene eingestampft,
sehr überraschend, ich erinnere mich noch, ich hab kurz davor,
war ich auf der BlizzCon, hab mit den Entwicklern von HOTS gesprochen,
die mir voll begeistert ihre neue Heldin vorgestellt haben,
die zum ersten Mal eine ist, die nicht aus anderen Blizzard-Spielen kommt,
und was sie da noch für coole Pläne haben.
Das war vollkommen klar, die hatten keine Ahnung,
dass das Mutterschiff einen Monat später sagt,
nee, wir sägen die halbe Belegschaft ab, der E-Sport geht auch nicht mehr.
Angeblich haben die das irgendwie am gleichen Tag erfahren.
Ein paar weitere Sachen waren halt zum Beispiel, das ist wieder,
muss nicht jetzt auch wieder handsfest finanziell sein,
aber das letzte WoW-Add-On, die Story, das kam nicht sehr gut an,
auch Overwatch 2, sag ich mal, wurde zumindest gespalten, aufgenommen,
und im weiteren Sinne hat das Studio auch, wie du sagst,
zwar sehr viele laufende Projekte ...
Overwatch 2 ist halt so ein Ding, ich halt das immer noch,
für Fake, dass das Overwatch 2, also nee, Fake ist das falsche Wort,
ich halte das immer noch für kein wirkliches Overwatch 2 im eigentlichen Sinne,
sondern eigentlich eher sowas, was Apex und Fortnite und sowas jetzt auch schon machen,
so eher Season 2, also quasi, man nimmt Overwatch 1
und erweitert das halt noch ein bisschen und macht das halt wieder interessanter
für die Leute, die schon mal gespielt haben, aber es ist, kann man nicht vorstellen,
dass das wirklich dem gerecht wird, was sich Leute unter einem Overwatch 2 versprechen.
... Projekte, aber dann doch jetzt eine Weile lang gar nichts mehr Großes,
wirklich Neues rausgemacht, das letzte wirklich neue Spiel war ja Overwatch 2016,
seitdem sind schon Dinge passiert, hauptsächlich im WoW-Sektor,
WoW Classic war ja auch ein großer Erfolg, Battle for Azeroth so mittel.
Wenn ich mal kurz unterbringe, da muss man sich, glaube ich,
schon auch mal als Spieler dann dazu herablassen, mal eine Frage zu stellen,
haben Sie denn bestimmte Projekte von einem Spielehersteller gemacht
und warum wird dann so mit den Dingen entschieden?
Blizzard hat kein Overwatch gemacht, weil sie gesagt haben, cool,
lass uns mal einen Shooter machen oder so, und genauso haben sie kein HOTS gemacht,
um einfach, ja, finden wir irgendwie cool, wollen wir auch noch machen.
Vielleicht im Kern im kreativen Team schon, vielleicht kamen da die Impulse her,
aber bei HOTS war natürlich die Idee, hey, MOBA, großer Markt, League of Legends, Dota,
guckt mal, was da bewegt wird, guckt mal, welche Summen da laufen,
und sie haben halt ihren Wunsch,
den Weg versucht, da drin zu finden, haben auch da wieder ein sehr, sehr gutes Produkt abgeliefert.
Ob das jetzt dem einen oder anderen gefällt, dem einen oder anderen,
ob es in die MOBA-Szene gepasst hat, obviously not, aber es ist immer noch,
also als Spiel vom Gameplay und von allem, wie es läuft, ein gutes Spiel.
Und dann ist auch irgendwann mal klar, wenn man sieht, okay, wir können damit nicht das bewegen,
was wir wollten, wird es halt eben nicht eingestellt, aber wird es halt dann eben nicht mehr so verfolgt.
Warflammer.
Das ist ja ein Gegenbeispiel, wenn du mal so willst, wenn du mal guckst,
ich habe jetzt dazu keine Zahlen, dafür gibt es ja vielleicht dich ein bisschen,
aber wenn man sieht, was Blizzard mit Overwatch geschafft hat, ist ja unfassbar,
wenn man es jetzt mal so will, also sie haben ein so gutes Spiel abgeliefert,
was in der Multiplayer-Shooter-Community jetzt auch so einen Status hat, gespielt wird.
Es ist tatsächlich ziemlich auf dem absteigenden Ast, was man,
mich würden die Spielerzahlen von Overwatch echt mal interessieren.
Da veröffentlicht Blizzard ja nichts.
Aber wenn man sich so die Aktivität anguckt im, also in diesem, wie heißt das,
Competitive Overwatch-Edit und wenn man sich mal die Wartezeiten der Queues anguckt
und Streaming-Zahlen und Content, der erstellt wird, das ist schon, das hat schon seine beste Zeit hinter sich.
Gepflegt wird die ganze Geschichte mit den, mit den, mit der Liga.
Es kommt ja auch nichts.
Guckt euch doch mal an, was, was, äh, Fortnite für nen Content, ähm,
oder beziehungsweise für nen, für nen Change-Feuerwerk abfackelt, seit sie so groß sind.
Overwatch hat paar Helden, paar Maps, ähm, meiner Meinung nach grundlegend, äh, aber nix, nix am Spiel geändert.
Zumal 2CP immer noch der größte Bullshit-Modus aller Zeiten ist.
Naja.
Das ist teilweise in Amerika, äh...
Was ich von Anfang an in Overwatch nicht verstanden hab, das muss ich jetzt nochmal kurz loswerden.
Das ist, das ist ein Spiel, was sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass es verschiedene Helden gibt.
Mit, mit, mit Persönlichkeit dahinter.
Ich hab's von Anfang an in Overwatch nicht kapiert, warum es überhaupt möglich war, pro Team die, ähm, gleichen Helden mehrfach zu picken.
Und ich hab von Anfang an nicht verstanden, warum es überhaupt möglich ist, in einem Game den gleichen Helden mehrfach zu spielen.
Ähm...
Ja, ich weiß, ich, ich, ich, ich kenne die, die Beweggründe dahinter, warum sie das gemacht haben.
Sie haben sich erhofft, dass das Ganze dynamischer wird, balanced wird, mehr balanced wird.
Und, ähm, Overwatch war ja ursprünglich darauf angelegt, als, ähm, Spiel, wo man permanent Helden switcht.
Das hat sich so halt nicht bewährt.
Aber gerade in nem Spiel, ich find das passt so von der Identität da irgendwie schon nicht so richtig zusammen.
Man hat nen Spiel, wo man die Persönlichkeit und die Unterschiede der Helden besonders in den Vordergrund stellt.
Und dann erlaubst du nicht nur, nicht nur den gleichen Held in beiden Teams zu spielen, sondern auch noch von Anfang an den gleichen Held mehrfach zu picken.
Das, ähm, das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Und ich, ich mein Overwatch, der Hero Pool, was ist denn das?
Irgendwie 10 Helden von, was haben die mittlerweile, 35 oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele es mittlerweile sind, die gespielt werden.
Das ist ein bisschen wie in LoL, ja.
In LoL werden, glaub ich, auch nur 10 Helden oder so gespielt.
Ähm, und...
Gerade bei nem Spiel, wo es eben die Persönlichkeit und die, und die Einzigartigkeit von den Helden ausmacht,
versteh ich nicht, warum man nicht, warum man das nicht versucht hat, darauf auszulegen, dass es eben ein Held pro Spiel nur einmal gibt.
LoL ist der Champions Pool echt riesig.
Ich hab letztens, ich hab letztens irgendwas gelesen, dass, dass im, im, im Pro-Lol-Meta irgendwie 10 Helden gespielt werden.
Vom Fernsehen übertragen wird, ja, wo dann einfach jetzt...
Über 80% der Champs wurde bei den Worlds gepickt, okay.
Oh ja.
Ist ja, ist ja gut.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, LoL hat halt auch massig Helden zur Auswahl.
Es ist übrigens auch ne Sache, ähm, die, die Overwatch gut tun würde.
Bullshit, es werden viele gespielt.
Alter, ich hab gesagt, als ich das gelesen hab, nicht, dass es ja die ultimative Wahrheit ist.
Jetzt macht gleich, gleich hier, gleich hier, der, der LoL, der LoL-Fan wieder übelst getriggert hier.
...Spiele oder so in der Sports-Wahl geguckt haben, jetzt einfach Overwatch gucken.
Ähm, wenn man sieht, was da für Summen fließen, dann ist das...
...ist das halt schon, schon beachtlich und, ähm, am Ende darf man halt nicht vergessen,
nur ein Satz zu dieser Diablo-Immortal-Geschichte auch nochmal.
Vielleicht ist halt auch so ein Team, was in so ner kreativen Bubble ist und einfach sagt,
naja, jeder guckt doch die ganze Zeit auf sein Handy, jeder spielt doch die ganze Zeit auf seinem iPad,
gibt genug Vorbilder, PUBG Mobile, Fortnite Mobile, äh, Clash Royale und so weiter und so fort.
Ähm, hat man gar nicht drüber nachgedacht, dass das jetzt als negativ empfunden werden kann,
wenn man so ein Spiel spielt?
Genau, da hat er voll und ganz recht.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte mit, ähm, das, der hat das wirklich ernst gemeint, ähm,
als der auf der Bühne gesagt hat, habt ihr nicht, habt ihr nicht, habt ihr keine Handys?
Habt ihr keine Smartphones?
Das hat er nicht gesagt, um die Leute zu, ähm, äh, zu beschwichtigen oder auch zu beschwichtigen,
aber das, da ist das, da war der wirklich von überzeugt.
So nach dem Motto, wie ist es doch das Normalste von der Welt, dass man, dass man jetzt, wo alle auf dem Handy spielen,
einen Diablo auf dem Handy rausbringt.
Das hat er doch gesagt, um die Leute zu jebaiten, das meint er wirklich ernst.
Spiel zu machen und ich würde jetzt auch ehrlich mal bezweifeln, wie sehr es ihnen in ein, zwei Jahren geschadet haben wird,
dass sie, dass sie diesen, dieses Miss-Announcement gemacht haben, weil ich lehne mich jetzt mal aus dem Fenster,
wenn es da ist, jeder wird es erstmal spielen, zumindest mal runterladen, ja. Ob es dann weitergespielt wird, weiß ich nicht, aber...
Werdet ihr es spielen? Was meint ihr, Leute? Wirdet ihr Immortal spielen? Also, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen Diablo Immortal und Perseverance,
dann würde ich eindeutig Person of Exile Mobile vorziehen, allerdings würde ich es wahrscheinlich gar nicht spielen,
weil die Zeit, wo ich mobil spiele, spiele, spielen würde, wären wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil eh nur im Zug und das ist am Tag nicht so lang
und vielleicht mal, wenn ich irgendwo warten muss, aber das kommt so selten vor, das lohnt sich eigentlich gar nicht so richtig.
Die Steuerung, ja, das ist das große Problem, weil ich finde, die Steuerung von den meisten Mobile Games ist Crap.
Ausprobieren, ich würde es wahrscheinlich mal installieren, ja.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch mal...
Übrigens, Leute, wenn das Video fertig ist, oder während ich... Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Ich, ich... Entweder gucken wir noch ein Essen-Video danach oder ich esse jetzt hier einfach, während wir GameStar-Video gucken.
... schon häufiger harte Zahlen angesprochen, kommen wir doch zu denen mal. Wir haben hier zum Beispiel eine Einnahmenkurve von Blizzard...
Ich mute mich mal kurz und futter das.
... seit Ende 2016, wo man dann doch sieht, es geht bisschen nach unten, es sieht jetzt für den Laien, sag ich mal, auch nicht nach einer kompletten Katastrophe aus,
Oh, die Stompschwein!
... mehrere hundert Millionen, die jedes Quartal umgesetzt werden, aber es geht dann doch nach unten.
Und die Gerüchte zumindest sind ja von Jason Schreier von Kotaku, der in der Regel ja keinen Unsinn verzapft und gut vernetzt ist von Insidern,
dass es bei Blizzard selbst einen zunehmenden Einfluss von Activision gibt, das auch den...
Na klar! Gibt's den! Na klar!
... Kosten zu sparen und wieder mehr Sachen zu releasen.
Ja, das ist genau der Punkt, weil das ist ja ein bisschen so das, was dahinter passiert.
Um da ein bisschen reinzukommen, wie du ja schon sagst, die haben jetzt gerade erst, jetzt vor kurzem, ihr viertes Quartal abgeschlossen und halt ihre Jahresberichte vorgelegt und so.
Und tatsächlich, ich glaube, ist das das erste Mysterium, mit dem man mal brechen muss, auch wenn's hart ist.
Blizzard ist nicht das, wie ihr Image nach außen mal suggeriert.
Ja, stell doch Pause mal.
Ups, hab ich mich gemutet.
Da hat er auch recht, aber das ist bei den meisten so.
Die meisten stellen sich nach außen hin immer so als, wir lieben die Community und wir machen alles für unsere Spieler und bla bla bla.
Es ist halt alles Bullshit.
Ich weiß das aus erster Hand.
Also was heißt, es ist nicht alles Bullshit, es ist da teilweise schon ein bisschen was Wahres dran, aber bei weitem nicht so, wie man sich nach außen hin präsentiert.
Ich arbeite bei einer Bank.
So.
Und eines der wichtigsten Dinger, die es bei mir auf der Arbeit gibt, ist...
...nach außen hin gut dastehen.
Scheißegal, was wirklich ist.
Nach außen hin gut dastehen ist das Wichtigste ever.
Und das ist bei Spieleherstellern auch das Gleiche.
Also Blizzard ist A, seit 1991, ich hab nochmal nachgeguckt, glaube ich, durch fünf Hände gegangen.
Also es war eben Teil von eher kleineren Unternehmen, also war ja selbst, hieß es ja auch anders, dann wurde es umbenannt, dann wurde es nachher, ich hab's mal aufgeschrieben, es war wirklich eine lange Kette.
Silicon and Synapse war es doch ursprünglich noch so.
Genau, da gab's nochmal einen Zwischennamen, glaub Chaos Studios, das hatte dann aber rechtliche Probleme, dann ist es Blizzard Entertainment, 94 geworden, wie gesagt, 91 gegründet.
Dann Blizzard Entertainment seit 94, dann wurde es aber von Davidson und Association aufgenommen.
Dann haben wir irgendwann Vivendi am Start.
Die wiederum wurden von CUC International aufgekauft, die wiederum wurden zwei Jahre später von Havas aufgekauft, die wiederum mit Vivendi zusammen gegangen sind und dann die Vivendi Game Group, wo auch Sierra und so drin war, gegründet wurden.
2008 dann nachher, also 2007 angekündigt, 2008, wo hat dann Vivendi Activision gekauft. Dann 2013 hat sich Activision selbst aus Vivendi rausgekauft und so weiter.
Ah, yes.
Dann kamen Kinder dazu. Und das ist, glaube ich, das große Ding, was auch dahinter steht.
Excellent.
Am Ende gibt es kein Blizzard.
Stocks.
Es ist eine Marke, es ist eine Sparte, es ist ein Teil einer sehr großen Unternehmung. Ich weiß nicht genau, jetzt nach Marktkapitalisierung, glaube ich, ist irgendwie Activision.
Ich glaube, Activision blitzert so an die 40 Milliarden oder 44 Milliarden US-Dollar-Wert. Also es ist keine kleine Klitsche mehr.
Was, echt?
Sondern es besteht und das ist halt ganz spannend. Wir können es dann auch mal größer ziehen. Ich habe es hier dann auch drin, weil da sind sie relativ transparent.
Das bedeutet Stocks. Das bedeutet, Alter, übelst verschluckt. Das ist ein Anspiel auf Stocks. Also Aktienkram.
Wie gesagt, dieses Großunternehmen besteht aus Activision. Das hat jetzt im Q4 1,4 Milliarden gemacht. Dann Blizzard. Knapp 600 Millionen. Und King, Candy Crush und Co. sind 500 Millionen.
Das haben wir uns ja auch schon mal im Stream angeguckt in den Activision Blizzard Financial Report. Und was das Tolle war, da zu sehen ist, dass Overwatch kaum Kohle gemacht hat.
Blizzard ist so groß oder so wichtig ungefähr wie, weiß ich, ein King.
Wie die Candy Crush-Macher.
Genau.
So, machen vom Ergebnis ein bisschen mehr und machen halt aber deutlich weniger als Activision, was hauptsächlich heutzutage nur noch Call of Duty ist.
Und da kommen jetzt die ganzen Schwierigkeiten halt rein, die natürlich auch wieder den normalen Spieler mal so gar nicht interessieren. Und das verstehe ich auch.
Aber der Hintergrund ist schlicht und ergreifend, es ist ein Unternehmen, die versuchen durch kreative Produkte viele Leute zu erreichen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das auch der Jason Schreier war oder ob das woanders mal gut analysiert wurde.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das auch der Jason Schreier war oder ob das auch der Jason Schreier war oder ob das auch der Jason Schreier war.
Ja, es ist ein Unternehmen, das drei Phasen durchlebt hat, die sie maßgeblich verändert haben. Die erste Sache war der mega Erfolg von WoW, der diese Firma krass intern verändert.
Ja.
Zum einen, weil sie auf einmal einen Titel hatten, den sie die ganze Zeit betreuen mussten.
Das hat einfach monatlich Geld gegeben.
WoW hat einfach, und das ist das, wovon jede Firma bzw. jeder Spielhersteller auf jeden Fall, aber jede Firma träumt, dass du jeden Monat mehr oder weniger Geld verdienst.
Und dass du jeden Monat mehr oder weniger sicher mit einem gewissen festen Betrag rechnen kannst.
Es kündigen nicht einfach mal von heute auf morgen irgendwie alle WoW-Leute ihr Abo.
Das war Wahnsinn. Und bei WoW, überlegt euch mal, die hatten teilweise bis zu 10 Millionen Abos. Das Abo kostet irgendwie 12 Euro.
Die haben massiv, massiv Kohle gekriegt im Monat, auf einen Schlager.
Auf zwei erstmal lange Zeit zugrunde gegangen.
Nämlich das ganze ursprüngliche StarCraft 2.
Das StarCraft-Team musste mithelfen, dass WoW gelauncht werden kann 2004.
Deswegen dauerte es so lange, bis das wieder aufgenommen wurde und nachgefunden wurde.
Dem ist auch Diablo 3, die ganzen Iterationen, zum Opfer gefallen.
Sprich, WoW war so übererfolgreich, dass es intern so viel verändert hat.
Sowohl was Ressourcenausrichtung angeht, als aber auch Denkweise.
Das ist immer so, wenn man, man stellt sich vor, man gewinnt im Lotto, das verändert einen sein Leben.
Man kauft sich vielleicht ein Haus, ein Boot, was auch immer irgendwie.
Auf einmal sind andere Dinge und es kommen auch andere Probleme.
Und all deine alten Freunde sind plötzlich auch ganz anders da.
Hey, was doch jetzt geht?
Und das ist halt natürlich so eine Sache, die halt vielleicht auch Personen ändern, interne Sachen.
So, der zweite größere Wechsel, was ich mal eben gehört habe, war Hearthstone.
Weil, was war das Besondere an Hearthstone?
Es war ein Mini-Projekt von einem winzig Team.
Übrigens, das Erfolgreichste.
Ich habe keine Zahlen dazu.
Aber das erfolgreichste Unity-Spiel überhaupt.
Überrascht immer wieder Leute, dass das Hearthstone in Unity ist, weil Unity ja immer so gerne geflamed wird.
Am Anfang wirklich so eine Handvoll, dann waren es nachher zehn, zwanzig maximal.
Das war wirklich einstellig ursprünglich wirklich, das Team.
So, und es wurde zu einem und ist bis heute noch zu einer so tragenden Umsatzsäule,
also was an Geld immer reinkommt für Blizzard, dass es ebenfalls wieder Denkmuster, wie gehe ich an Spiele ran,
muss ich denn immer das Großprojekt quasi, was acht Jahre in Entwicklung ist, mit 100 Designern und so weiter und so fort, haben.
Oder ich weiß nicht, bei WoW waren es nachher, weiß ich nicht, 300, 500 Leute nachher.
Am Anfang war das Wortteam gar nicht so riesig.
Das hat auch viel geändert.
Hearthstone, klein, richtig getroffen.
Und dann, das war nämlich auch, glaube ich, die Idee an Heroes of the Storm.
Ich habe das ja auch von Anfang an noch, bevor, wie hieß es, Blizzard Allstars, glaube ich, hieß es am Anfang.
Stimmt, ja.
Habe auch Preview damals geschrieben.
Und war auch so, oh, endlich gibt es halt die echten Blizzard-Helden in einem Dota-Style und so weiter,
weil da kam das ja mal alles her.
Aber da, glaube ich, hatten sie nämlich auch die Idee, ach, wir nehmen ein kleines Team,
wir gehen jetzt in diese Nische, wir sind Blizzard, bam, knallt, ausgesorgt.
Das war das nächste.
Und Overwatch, was du gerade sagtest, war das nächste.
Das war ihre erste neue IP seit ganz langer Zeit.
Hatten wir auch einen Talk hier gemacht.
So, was wird denn jetzt? Was ist das Projekt Titan?
Wie geht es weiter?
Also, da wussten wir noch nicht, dass es Overwatch wird.
Und Overwatch war auch wieder zu erfolgreich.
Es waren Milliarden Umsatz, glaube ich, in dem Jahr, so in den ersten zwölf Monaten.
Overwatch hat übertrieben, ich weiß gar nicht, was die aktuellen Overwatch-Verkaufszahlen sind,
aber irgendwie 16 Millionen oder irgendwas.
Es ist, es ist irgendwie, Overwatch hat übertrieben krass verkauft, ja.
Äh, nicht Overwatch.
Overwatch.
Stained.
Äh.
Okay.
16 Millionen.
Vergiss, was ich gesagt habe, Leute.
50 Millionen.
Overwatch hat, er hat sich echt übertrieben geil verkauft.
Die dahinterliegende, die Firma wird, ist intern unglaublich erfolgreich gewesen.
Dann wird sie verkauft oder mitverkauft, geht in eine andere Fusion mit rein.
Und dann hat das Ding einen Wert.
Blizzard ist jetzt, weiß ich nicht, 5 Milliarden wert, 8 Milliarden wert oder sonst irgendwas.
Und dieser Wert kommt aus diesem, was die Spiele gerade einspülen.
So.
Und das führte dazu, dass sie natürlich große Erwartungshaltung bei ihren Neueigentümern
haben.
Ah, ja.
Plus natürlich die Leute auch von Blizzard, die da jetzt übergegangen sind, die machen
das auch natürlich aus Leidenschaft.
Das, äh, hab ich denen immer abgenommen.
Das war kein, das waren keine Businessleute, sondern, äh, ja, Chris Metzen, auch Mike
Morihan und so.
Das waren Überzeugungstäter.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die jetzt halt weg sind.
Äh, Blizzard gilt ja auch als eine der, äh, Spieleschmieden, die am meisten wirklich
Spieler in sich drin hat, ähnlich wie Valve.
Also, wo Leute wirklich die ganze Zeit zocken, zocken, zocken und gucken, was man irgendwie
machen kann.
Ist nicht selbstverständlich bei großen, äh, Dev-Teams.
Ähm, aber dann kommt wieder eben dieser finanzielle Aspekt.
Sie kriegen Ziele.
Wenn du verkauft wirst und daran Anteile hast, dann kriegst du einfach, ne, wenn du 20% mehr
schaffst, dann kriegst du, weiß ich, 50 Millionen, wenn du 100, ne, ich kenn die genau nicht,
ist nicht offengelegt, aber eben du wirst an dem Erfolg gemessen und kriegst dafür deine
Ausschüttung.
Weil auch der Ausstieg von Mike Morihan und von anderen, das war sicherlich geplant.
Weil wenn du deine Firma nach und nach halt in eine andere Firma integrierst, planst du
immer mit dem Ausstieg.
100%.
Es kann mal anders laufen, dass du sagst, ach, ist ja doch ganz cool, ich bleib.
Aber ich bin ganz sicher, das war den Leuten selbstbewusst.
Ich bleib jetzt hier noch drei Jahre unter Activision oder auch vier, fünf, was auch immer.
Aber eigentlich, ich bin auf dem Weg nach draußen.
So, um das mal kurz zusammenzufassen, was jetzt jetzt passiert, nochmal, wie gesagt,
Activision Blizzard, das ist eins.
Da drunter ist ein Blizzard-Entertainment.
Da ist ein Element integriert worden, wie du ja auch vorhin im Vorgespräch gesagt hast.
Und es gibt nur noch einen President.
Es gibt keinen CEO, also keinen Einzelchef von Blizzard.
Also keinen Vorstandsvorsitzenden, wie man das im Deutschen nennen würde.
Genau, das war der Mike Morihan.
Und jetzt ist, und der hatte diesen Titel, den hast du mir vorher erzählt.
Aber eigentlich gibt es nur noch einen CEO von Activision Blizzard und das ist Bobby Kotick.
J. Allen Brack hat jetzt den, wie du mir auch erklärt hast, weniger mächtigen Titel in amerikanischer Palance President.
Dieser einen Abteilung von Activision Blizzard.
Der dürfte uns ja allen bestens bekannt sein.
Das heißt aber jetzt auch, die Gesamtstrategie des Unternehmens, und das kann eben jeder auch nachlesen,
weil es ja börsennotiert ist, müssen wir das offenlegen.
Was machen sie, warum machen sie das, was erwarten sie davon?
Da sind die oft sehr transparent.
Auch da wieder, ne, für die meisten Spieler völlig irrelevant.
Man will ja nur einfach die guten Spieler haben.
Was war so schlimm an dem?
An dem ist nichts schlimmer als an allen anderen Oberstocks-Mans.
Den haben wir aber schon.
Wenn es um das Call of Duty-Thema geht, hatten wir den schon öfters mal am Start.
Was sind ihre Kernmarken, auf die sie sich konzentrieren?
Das sagt leider aber auch, sie haben wenig bis gar kein Interesse, neue Marken aufzubauen.
Es gab mal eine Diskussion 2009, 2008, da hatte sich der Bobby Kotick mal ein bisschen verplappert,
wo er nämlich gesagt hat, er hält gar nichts davon, eigentlich dieses da noch was, da noch was.
Am liebsten würde er alles, was jährlich nur geht, alles was nur große IPs sind, die wiederholbar sind, die tief sind.
Das ist ja auch logisch, aus dem seiner Sicht, das ist ja auch keiner, das ist ja kein kreativer Mensch.
Das ist ein Stonks-Mensch.
Deswegen, für den ist es ganz klar, du machst das, was etabliert ist.
Wenn du jetzt einen Diablo 4 machst, okay, gehen wir mal zurück, wenn du jetzt einen Diablo 3 machst, du weißt, der Scheiß wird sich verkaufen.
Die Leute lächeln nach einem neuen Diablo 3.
Das war dem Typ auch klar.
Das ist halt kein kreativer Mann, das ist ein Stonks-Mann.
Die denken halt in andere Richtungen.
... aus gelb, gelb, gelb gesagt, sondern weil er selbst gemerkt hat, viele Top-Entwickler gehen nur zu Teams, die nachweislich fortlaufende Erfolge erzielen.
Ist auch, kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Viele Mitarbeiter von Studios offensichtlich nicht so richtig Lust haben, nämlich drei Jahre sich, Entschuldigung, tot zu arbeiten und danach rausgeschmissen zu werden.
Kann ich auch verstehen.
So, sie erwarten von einem großen Studio, wo sie dann hingehen auch,
langfristige Erfolge.
Da gibt es ja schon dann einen direkten Konflikt von dem, weil das ist ja auch wie Activision arbeitet, schon seit langem mit Call of Duty, wie du vor allem gesagt hast.
Das ist aber das genaue Gegenteil von dem, wie Blizzard immer gearbeitet hat und ja eigentlich auch bis heute noch eigentlich, so abgesehen von WoW, wo sie jährliche Addons rausbringen.
Haston ist auch sowas jetzt geworden.
Stimmt, Haston ist auch sowas.
Overwatch soll sowas, das meine ich, aber das ist genau die Brücke jetzt.
Sie haben King, was durch Candyquash immer noch Unsummen einnimmt.
Sie haben überall gelernt, neue IPs, schwierig, riskant, unsicher.
Aber auch bei Overwatch manchmal vielleicht.
Auch mal, ja, genau.
Das aber erhöht dann sogar den...
Das ist halt generell das Problem, was wir aktuell haben, nicht nur in der Spielewelt, auch wenn man sich irgendwelche Filmegeschichten anguckt.
Also, es gibt halt, wenn man sich die Releases anguckt, das sind 71% oder wenn nicht noch mehr, 80% Neuauflagen.
Entweder komplette Reboots oder halt meistens Fortsetzungen.
Und ich finde das so langweilig einfach nur.
...druckt, dass das nächste IP-Ding halt, also IP sagen wir immer, ne, also eine neue Serie, eine neue Marke, die geschaffen wird, also Intellectual Property.
Aber es erhöht auch den Erwartungsdruck, das wieder zu machen.
Und jetzt kommt die nächste große Problematik rein, Mobile.
Activision, jetzt auch in den letzten Calls und auch in internen Diskussionen, sie sehen, wie entscheidend Mobile auf einer weltweiten Ebene ist.
Was war jetzt der letzte Wert, den sie jetzt letzte Woche veröffentlicht haben?
Ja, guckt euch Call of Duty Mobile an, wie das eingeschlagen ist. So ein Crap.
Die haben, ich glaube, 150 Millionen installierte Call of Duty Mobile.
War klar, dass das jetzt kommt.
Damit hatten sie ja einen Riesenerfolg. Und in dem Fall sind ja die beiden Studios sogar auf Linie.
Weil, wie du ja sagtest, Blizzard hat das auch schon von einer Weile erkannt. Der hier ist ja sehr Hearthstone-süchtig, zum Beispiel.
Nicht so sehr, wie du denkst.
Aber das ist halt, weißt du was?
Die haben jetzt zwei Arme, die zeigen Mobile, Mobile, Mobile.
Und dann ist Blizzard da. Ja, eigentlich würden wir ja am liebsten PC.
Ja, ein bisschen Konsole ist noch okay.
Weißt du, also das auch wieder beeinflusst.
Klar, Phoenix.
Mobile war vor Modern Warfare, das Release.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich sogar deutlich erfolgreicher als Modern Warfare.
Die zeigen nämlich, am Ende ist es eben eine große Unternehmung.
Und die jetzt nach und nach alles bestimmt.
Deswegen, wie gesagt, nochmal, Blizzard konnte früher auch ein bisschen allein gelassen werden.
Gerade unter Vivendi.
Weil zum Beispiel Vivendi auch riesen Probleme mit Sierra hatte.
Sierra war so lange ein Problemkind.
Wurde ja dann auch abgewickelt und aufgelöst und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist fast immer so.
Auch bei uns intern, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Man kümmert sich immer vor allem erst um die Sorgenkinder.
Nicht unbedingt um die Sachen, die von alleine laufen.
Jetzt ist es aber so.
Wie du schon sagtest, die Kurve von Blizzard selbst ist jetzt nicht so super.
Während Call of Duty gerade wieder neue Rekorde aufstellt, also Modern Warfare.
Ja, warum auch immer.
Mega erfolgreich.
Hat wieder alle anderen Franchises im Konsole-Bereich abgelehnt.
Warum auch immer.
Die haben halt ein absolut geniales Marketing-Team bei Call of Duty.
Die kriegen das jedes Jahr wieder hin.
... erfolgreich.
Jetzt zeigen sie, Mobile geht auch noch.
Man muss sagen, dass CoD Mobile besser ist als CoD Mobile.
Ich habe das bei vielen Leuten auf YouTube gehört, nachdem auch die übelst am flamen sind.
Aber es ist wie jedes Jahr.
Jedes Jahr kommt eine CoD raus.
Am Anfang sagen die Leute, ah, ist ja nicht schlecht.
Und danach kommt immer die gleiche Reaktion.
Immer so dieser gleiche Reflex.
Oh, das aktuelle CoD ist scheiße.
Wir spielen jetzt das von letztem Jahr.
Das ist immer, immer.
Und man kann, man hält einfach nur eine gewisse Anzahl ein CoD am Stück aus.
Wenn man das so sieht.
Wenn man CoD zwei Monate gespielt hat, dann ist es vorbei.
Das Game, da ragest du mehr rum, schneller rum, als in OV ranked.
In Overwatch ranked ragest du länger, aber schneller zum Ragen bringt dich Modern Warfare oder Call of Duty.
Das kannst du nicht länger als zwei Monate am Stück spielen.
... uns irgendwie dem auch ein bisschen unterordnen und einfügen.
Und deswegen kann ich auch sagen, dass ich das nicht so gut finde.
Und deswegen meine ich ja, das muss man nicht mögen.
Aber das ist einfach der Grund, warum das ist.
Wenn ich eben mit diesen und jenen Werten mal irgendwie gekauft wurde, ist auch die Erwartung, dass ich das wiederhole.
Also dass ich jedes Jahr im Idealfall meinen Milliarden-Seller habe und nicht nur alle fünf Jahre mal.
Und das ist glaube ich der Kampf, der jetzt in dieser Unternehmung, was man auch mitkriegt, irgendwie dort eben einfach vorherrscht.
Genau, das ist ja auch was eben Jason Schreier sagt.
Ninja mit dem It's Just a Game, kenne ich nicht.
Das ist übrigens eine coole Idee mit dem neuen Spielmodus
in Overwatch.
Ich hätte mir schon längst, also so einen Spielmodus
fände ich cool und ganz ehrlich,
können die nicht einfach 2CP
umbauen, die 2CP Maps
umbauen in einen ordentlichen Spielmodus?
2CP ist wirklich so,
der komplette Hass
für Overwatch entlädt sich bei mir,
wenn ich an 2CP denke.
Bei Entwicklern durchaus.
Und es ist gar nicht mal der Modus
nur, es ist gar nicht nur der Modus.
Der Modus in Kombination
mit den Maps und vor allem
den Spawnplatzierungen,
das ist für mich so der pure
Overwatch-Rage, den ich da bekomme,
wenn ich da dran denke.
Was ist an 2CP so schlimm?
Zum Beispiel, was die Defender
meistens,
zumindest was den letzten Punkt angeht, oder je nach Map,
2 Meter vom Punkt
weg spawnen.
Dass du in 2CP teilweise dafür
bestätigst,
dass du dafür bestraft wirst, aggressiv zu spielen.
Dass du in 2CP teilweise
dafür bestraft wirst,
Punkte einzunehmen
im falschen Timing.
2CP hat so viel
komische Dinge
einfach nur,
das Ding müsste nochmal ordentlich überarbeitet werden.
Also 2CP ist für mich so
der komplette Overwatch-Rage
in einem Spielmodus zusammengefasst.
Außerdem
sind, finde ich, die mit Abstand
schlechtesten Maps in 2CP.
Die Maps, die 2CP-Maps,
das ist so
so ein Ding, was
Leute, die angefangen haben,
Level zu designen, als erstes
basteln, irgendwie so,
bauen einfach
ein Ding mit einem Chokepoint, einem Eingang,
vielleicht einer Flank-Hute und sagen, geile Map.
Frustration gibt,
dass sie das Gefühl haben,
Entscheidungen werden mehr und mehr von Leuten
getroffen, die auch, wie du sagst, Blizzard ist
ein Gamer-Entwickler sozusagen, werden aber weniger
von Gamern getroffen, weil Activision irgendwelche
McKinsey-Berater oder sowas
reinholt und die in Finanz-Meeting-Sets
die dann Entscheidungen treffen, was ja
nachvollziehbar ist irgendwo, aber was dann gleichermaßen
auch vielleicht für, sag ich mal,
Reibereien sorgen kann. Und man hat ja durchaus
gesehen, dass auch in letzter Zeit wieder
einige Blizzard-Gesichter
können uns den Tweet von Ninja danach, glaube ich, mal kurz
angeben, gegangen sind. Also vor einer Weile ist ja schon mal der Ben Broad
gegangen, der Hearthstone-Game-Director war.
Der Dings hier, Madsen ist weg, Moen ist weg.
Und auch der Dustin Browder ist jetzt weg, würde ich auch.
Und in letzter Zeit sind auch noch mehr.
Ist ähnlich wie bei DICE. Bei DICE rennen die Leute
auch reihenweise weg.
Der Storm-Game-Director, davor war er StarCraft 2
Lead-Designer. Da wird auch ein bisschen
gemerkt, also gerade der Dustin Browder, vielleicht so die Spiele,
die ich gerne mache, die ich cool finde bei Blizzard,
sind jetzt offenbar nicht mehr die Dinger,
die hier so entstehen. Was ein bisschen bitter ist,
weil der war ja vorher der C&C
Lead-Designer mal und C&C
wissen wir auch, hat es auch nicht über die Jahre geschafft
und ist dann ja zu StarCraft gegangen.
Ich fühle sehr mit diesem Mann.
Er tut gute Dinge. Ich habe mal mit ihm eine Stunde
im Heroes of Storm geredet
und es war ganz spannend, dass halt mal,
wie ist das denn für jemanden, der auch mit Strategie,
wir beide sind ja große Strategie-Fans,
aufgewachsen ist und das eigentlich so
mit der Muttermilch aufgesaugt hat und dann
ist es halt tatsächlich so ein bisschen... Milch ist Gift, Leute.
Denkt dran.
Unge hat uns das erklärt.
Nochmal, weltweites
Unternehmen guckt,
wo sind Spieler und die
Spieler sagen, bitte Action,
also Shooter, Call of Duty, Overwatch
oder bitte Mobile
oder bitte mit langer, langer
Bindung.
Aber ich nenne es mal jetzt eher Liebhaber-Themen,
fallen schnell runter. Warum gibt es kein
StarCraft? Warum gibt es keine, auch mit,
warum wurde Warcraft 3 Reforged
ausgelagert? Ist ja nicht mal mehr intern richtig.
Wobei ich tatsächlich da nochmal geguckt habe, Blizzard,
also das ist ja auch eine Sache, die sie häufiger jetzt machen,
weil du sagst, sie haben jetzt inzwischen
einfach ein bisschen zu viel auf der Platte.
Diablo Immortal wird ja auch mit NetEase, einem chinesischen
Entwickler, zusammen gemacht. Chinesisch.
Das klingt erstmal so, sie haben es ja nach Malaysia
ausgelagert. Ja, klar kenne ich das noch.
Das klingt wirklich so nach irgendwie in so eine Klitsche,
aber das ist tatsächlich immer noch ein sehr hochwertiges
Studio. Lemon Sky heißen die, die haben
unter anderem auch schon an Uncharted mitgewirkt.
Ich finde das gar nicht negativ, also viele Studios.
Ich meine, ich glaube, also ich habe es erstmal, als ich es gehört habe,
wurde nach Malaysia outgesorgt, dass man,
ah ja, okay, möglichst billig
irgendwie, nee, gar nicht. Da ist tatsächlich anscheinend
ein sehr talentiertes Team, aber trotzdem
macht Blizzard ein bisschen weniger selbst.
Genau. Und so sah das aus.
Du fokussierst das ja auch so in eine Wahrheit,
also ich weiß nicht, wie es bei Blizzard aussieht, aber du siehst,
du hast ja auch erzählt, Top-Talents sind teilweise gegangen.
Die Branche ist hart umkämpft
um richtige Super-Designer. Da gibt es nicht viele.
Also von allen,
von den Ubisoft-Studios hören wir das, von
Microsoft-Game-Studios, von Bethesda
und so, überall gibt es
Mangel an echten
Super-Kreativen, also die wirklich
visionär, die wirklich Gameplay
verstehen. Ich glaube auch,
also ich glaube, da kommen auch
wenige nach, weil
ich stelle mir das
einfach nur vor, dass es in der
aktuellen Lage, wie es jetzt gerade ist,
wo quasi
Stonks vor Kreativität gehen,
schwierig ist, neue Leute
quasi
zu erschaffen, die so denken.
Wo soll das herkommen?
Die werden ja nicht, das fängt ja nicht von jetzt
auf gleich einfach mal an.
Das braucht alles ein bisschen Erfahrung. Talent ist das
eine, Übung, Erfahrung, sonst was
und
wenn es das Umfeld nicht mehr hergibt,
wenn
quasi so das Durchschnittsmotto ist, Stonks
vor Kreativität, wo willst du neue
super-kreative Designer-Leute
herkriegen?
Und so weiter und so fort. Es ist immer noch, auch 2020,
eher die Ausnahme, ein super-erfolgreiches Spiel zu machen, als die Regel.
Also es ist weiterhin super-schwer, alles richtig gut hinzukriegen
und so weiter und das eben...
Ja, und das führt aber dazu, dass so viele Retorten-Dinger
zusammengefuddelt werden, so was wie Anthem zum Beispiel.
Anthem ist so ein typisches BWL-Stonks-Game.
So nach dem Motto, wir brauchen das, wir brauchen Loot, wir brauchen
Service-Game, wir brauchen hier und die und die und die Elemente.
Und hier.
Und hier, Kreativ-Team, macht man ein Game draus.
Und da gucken die sich das an, da denk ich, what the fuck, Alter, was soll man,
was soll man da draus für ein Game machen? Ach übrigens, in drei, in drei Monaten ist, ist die E3-Demo.
What?
So ungefähr muss Anthem entstanden sein.
Und was da rausgekommen ist, sieht man ja.
Und da kommen, und da kommen bestimmt keine super-kreativen Leute.
Und, und wenn da einer wirklich kreativ ist und was Gutes draus machen will, hat er keinen Bock mehr.
Verpisst sich.
Unser Top-Leute müssen
jetzt irgendwie am nächsten Overwatch arbeiten.
Oder die müssen jetzt an Diablo 4 arbeiten.
Deswegen ist ja einer ihrer verbliebenen Top-Leute ist noch Jeff Kaplan, der damit kein Problem hat.
Aber selbst der, der hat neulich öffentlich gesagt, er hätte die Blitzschank-Sache nicht gemacht.
Er hätte den nicht bestrafen.
Ja, der ist auch pisst. Hab ich auch letztens auf Reddit nochmal gesehen, ey.
Und er ist ja schon ewig dabei.
Man darf nicht vergessen, der hat, der hat angefangen als, als bei, bei, bei WoW, Blizzard, also als Blizzard WoW entwickelt hat.
Das war eine übelst krasse, ähm, EverQuest 2-Suche.
Suchter, Jeff Kaplan.
Da gibt's sogar noch die Flame-Posts von ihm.
Legendär mittlerweile.
Die Flame-Posts, wo er sich über, über EverQuest-Mechanics und EverQuest und den Hersteller aufgeregt hat, wie scheiße alles ist und so.
Hat er übelst, übelst, übelst rum geflamed, ja.
Und den haben die bei Blizzard damals geholt.
Weil halt, äh, MMOs waren ja noch in der Entstehung.
Das gab ja noch kein so das MMO schlechthin.
Das ist dann World of Warcraft geworden.
Aber als WoW quasi in der Entwicklung war, gab's das noch nicht.
Und dann haben die erfolgreiche Spieler aus damals, ähm, etablierten MMOs geholt.
Um, äh, quasi Infos zu bekommen aus erster Hand und die mit, mitarbeiten zu lassen da dran.
Was eben ein gutes MMO ausmacht.
Da, da kommt er ja her.
Er, er war mal einer der größten EverQuest, EverQuest 2-Flamer quasi.
Haha.
Und der ist ganz schön lang bei Blizzard schon dabei.
Und wie gesagt, es gibt noch, es gibt noch diesen BlizzCon-Auftritt von ihm früher.
Wo er auf der Bühne war.
Wo er auf der Bühne gestanden hat und gemeint hat, äh, er kickt schlechte Leute aus der Party.
Das könntest du heute eben im Leben nicht mehr sagen auf der Bühne, ey.
War oft, fand ich auch ein interessantes Zeichen, dass der das so klar sagt.
Weißt du, also, ich finde, also man muss noch einmal aufpassen, weil du gerade gesagt hast, Leute gehen auch von Blizzard weg und so.
Was den Leuten oftmals von der Community in den Mund gelegt wird oder was man halt so schnell mal in irgendeinem Chatroom oder in einem Forum schreibt, ist halt auch nicht immer die Wahrheit, ja.
Also, oh ja, äh, der Ben Broad ist jetzt gegangen, weil, weil er damit unzufrieden war.
Weil, weil er damit unzufrieden war.
Naja, Ben Broad ist halt einfach deswegen gegangen, weil er gesagt hat, ich habe jetzt dieses Hearthstone-Team geführt und ich will nicht mehr führen, ich will wieder selber programmieren.
Deswegen ist er jetzt...
Verständlich.
Da hat er sein Dark Dinner gegründet und macht da sein Marvel-Kartenspiel.
Weil er halt einer von denen ist, der wieder selber hier programmieren will, ja.
Ähm, bestimmt gehen auch Leute, weil sie sagen, ich komme nicht mehr mit der Firmenstruktur, äh, komme da nicht mehr klar und ich will das nicht mehr.
Aber ich finde, vergleichs mal mit Fußball, ja.
Ungern, Clay.
Naja, prinzipiell.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, da liegt mir auch nichts ferner, aber es ist ein bisschen ähnlich.
Das Herz der Fans ist immer beim, beim Verein und ja, und die stehen dafür und meine ganze Kindheit und die haben schon damals und so.
Ja, natürlich.
Und das ist auch das, was viel Geld in die Kassen spült, ja.
Klar, Marketing und so weiter kommt noch dazu und Merchandise.
Ähm, aber am Ende ist halt der FC Bayern nicht nur elf Leute oder mit denen, die auf der Bank sind, einen Verein, die halt Fußball spielen,
sondern da gehört halt noch ein ganz großer anderer Apparat dazu, der auch funktionieren muss.
Und es ist halt auch sehr wichtig, dass das, was da auf dem Platz passiert, dann immer zu einem bestimmten Ergebnis führt.
Und für die einen, für das eine Firmenkonstrukt reicht halt okay Erste Liga irgendwo, für das andere reicht halt nur Meister und Champions League und hier und da.
Und ähm, so sind diese Dinge halt aufgebaut.
Was aber nicht im Umkehrschluss ist, wollte ich eigentlich sagen, heißt, dass diese Leute jetzt bei Blizzard zum Beispiel, die dann wirklich die Spiele machen, nicht immer noch die Kreativen sind.
Klar.
Nicht immer noch die, die in ihren, sag ich mal.
Ich glaube, bei keinem Entwicklerstudio sitzen zum größten Teil Leute, die kein gutes Game abliefern wollen.
Also die, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwo absichtlich Scheiße gemacht wird.
Mal ähm, Kinderzimmern mit Postern, mit Actionfiguren, wirklich denen diese, diese Surroundings gegeben werden, dass sie da so kreativ wie möglich sein können, das bestmögliche Produkt abliefern können.
Warum ist es denn so?
Ja, aber Mobile Games, Mobile Games zählt nicht.
Da bin ich da schon gar nicht mehr dabei.
Ich hab so viele ARPGs angeguckt, wegen halt, wieder Hype für Diablo 4 und so.
Es tut mir sehr leid, Wolcen, Last Epoch, Grim Dawn, wie sie alle heißen, ich hab alle ausprobiert.
Es kommt vom Gameplay her nichts an Diablo 3 ran.
Steinigt mich, ihr wisst, wie meine Unterkanäle sind, ihr könnt mich befeuern.
Path of Exile, Beste.
Von den Hintergrundsystemen her vielleicht schon, aber vom puren Action-Gameplay ist es immer noch ungeschlagen.
Aber das ist ein schönes Beispiel.
Path of Exile ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Die Leute wollen immer, macht doch was mit Diablo.
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn du dir irgendwelche Asset-Flips auf Steam anguckst, schon, aber ich meine, bei den großen Entwicklerstudios, bei den großen Geräten, da sitzt auch keiner da und sagt so nach dem Motto, nee, wir bauen das jetzt besonders scheiße.
Das hat meistens äußere Umstände.
Die meisten wollen ein ordentliches Spiel abliefern, da bin ich mir sicher.
Asset-Flips? Ich meine Asset-Flips.
Nicht Asset.
Asset-Flips hören sich ja irgendwie an nach irgendwelchen chemischen Substanzen.
Ja.
Also, gibt uns doch hier, gebt uns doch da.
Man muss sagen, Leute, ihr habt einmal für dieses Spiel bezahlt und das war vor wann?
Acht Jahren oder sieben Jahren?
Irgendwie so.
Ja, schon länger, ja.
Und es gibt keinerlei Dinge, die ihr in dieses Spiel bezahlen könnt, also keine Cosmetics, es gibt nichts, es gibt keine Ingame-Transactions, die ihr alle so sehr hasst auch.
Kleiner Game-Shop gibt es.
Und mehr Add-Ons.
Ich zahl doch für Add-Ons.
Tatsächlich für Diablo nicht.
Doch, es gab doch eine Klasse, die konnte man nachkaufen.
Ja, aber es gab nur einmal.
Okay, aber das würde ich jetzt wirklich als Add-On sehen.
Ja, aber du hast jetzt nicht wie bei Clash Royale oder so.
Aber das ist ja, was die Leute wollten, mehr Add-Ons, für die sie durchaus auch zahlen wollten.
So, das heißt, da ist das Spiel ganz klar, wir machen das einmal und dann muss das beim Verkauf oder vielleicht...
Ja, okay, okay, naja, da muss ich sagen, das ist nicht reiner Fanservice, wobei Fanservice ja bei unseren Freunden aus dem Anime-Land ein bisschen was anderes bedeutet.
Also, das ist nicht reiner, um die Fans glücklich zu machen, dass sie Diablo 3 supporten.
Ähm, wenn die Diablo 3 nicht weiter supportet hätten, das Ding wäre einfach gestorben.
Komplett.
Also, das ist schon eigenes Interesse dran, dass die Diablo 3 supportet haben.
Auch, man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, Diablo hat auch eine gewisse Konkurrenz, ja.
Und die haben bestimmt keinen Bock, dass die Leute bis zu Diablo 4 Release allesamt in Path of Exile oder sonst wo drin stecken und sich denken, was, Diablo 4 kommt raus, ist mir scheißegal.
Der Hype wird eh nach Diablo 3 am Anfang jetzt nicht mehr da sein.
Ja.
Da wird Diablo 3 am Anfang jetzt ein bisschen verhaltener sein.
Wobei, weiß man nie so genau, marketingtechnisch ist Activision, hat's ja da voll drauf, ja.
Ähm, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, es wird trotzdem wieder erfolgreich sein.
Ich meine, Diablo ist ein großes Ding.
Aber das ist nicht nur, um die Fans zu erfreuen.
Das ist genauso, wie Rainbow Six nicht, äh, weiter betrieben wurde.
Gut, da gibt's jetzt vieles zum Kaufen und Season Passes und so.
Einfach nur, um die Fans zu erfreuen.
Da hieß schon ganz viel Eigeninteresse dran.
Und die bauen Anthem jetzt auch nicht weiter um.
Ähm, nur um die Leute zu erfreuen.
Und das wird man an Anthem auch sehen.
Je nachdem, was für ein Modell die wählen.
Wenn das nämlich ein Modell ist, wo, wo, wo nicht weiter irgendwie Kohle reinkommt oder irgendwie was zu, zu, vom Vorteil für sie, für sie, äh, passiert.
Dann wird auch Anthem 2.0 nix großartiges Neues bringen oder nix, was das Game großartig ändert.
Ähm, weil für die grundsätzlichen Sachen müsstest du da schon ordentlich Entwicklungszeit und Geld natürlich reinstecken.
Und ob man das bereit ist zu tun.
Außer zu versprechen, man macht das.
Ob man das wirklich macht.
Äh, hängt ganz davon ab, wie sehr die noch sehen, dass man damit Geld machen kann.
Beziehungsweise, zumindest, wie sehr sie hoffen, dass sie, dass sie das Ganze irgendwie noch stärken.
Oder vielleicht, wenn's nur das, wenn's nur mindestens so ist, dass die Leute wenigstens Anthem spielen und nicht Destiny.
Da haben sie auch schon was gewonnen.
Also ganz, äh, so nach dem Motto, nur um die Fans zu erfreuen, ist das mit Sicherheit nicht.
Vielleicht beim Verkauf vom nächsten DLC so knallen, dass über Jahre hinweg, wenn wir euch die Seasons und alles anschauen.
Wenn wir euch die Seasons und alles geben wollen, die Finanzierung dafür halt klar ist, ja.
Und ich finde schon, das kann man dem Spieler, also gerade, wenn die ein bisschen jetzt Erwachsener sind, schon mal abverlangen, sich auch darüber Gedanken zu machen.
Wer würde denn das World of Warcraft 2 oder das Titan, was auch immer es war, falls es es überhaupt jemals gegeben hat, wer hätte es denn gekauft, wer würde es denn spielen, ja.
Und eine Community, die jeder der Leute, die jetzt die meckern, haben ein Smartphone.
Und ich sage jetzt einfach mal, auch jeder hat irgendwie ein Tablet.
Da darf der andere auch nochmal was sagen heute.
Jeder benutzt es Tag für Tag, für seine Netflix-Serien, für seine E-Mails, für alles.
Und es muss auch klar sein, dass dieser Markt auch irgendwie von dem Unternehmen erschlossen werden muss oder es wird sterben.
Das Blizzard, das man sich so anguckt mit dem Moorhain und allem, wie sie da am Boden saßen und Magic gespielt haben, dein Lieblingskarten-Spiel.
Gute Leute.
Natürlich ist das ihre Legacy und ihr Origin, da kommen sie her.
Aber sie wären vielleicht auch noch da, ja.
Und jetzt nicht da, hätte es kein World of Warcraft und so gegeben, wenn sie da geblieben wären und nicht irgendwie in den...
Ich glaube letztendlich, das ist allen klar.
Also, es ist relativ klar, warum Blizzard die Sachen so macht, wie sie es machen.
Der eigentliche Punkt ist doch viel eher, dass das den Leuten nicht gefällt.
Dass sie sie eben mit Blizzard spielen und dem, was Blizzard macht, was anderes verbinden.
Als das, was aktuell gerade läuft.
Ich meine, es ist ein Unterschied dazu, ob ich mir erklären kann, warum jemand was macht.
Oder ob ich es gut finde, was jemand macht.
Und ich kann mir das durchaus erklären, warum das bei Blizzard so läuft.
Das ist ja auch das, was sie alles erzählt haben.
Das hat schon Hand und Fuß.
Ich kann mir auch erklären, warum das so ist.
Ob mir das jetzt gefällt.
Das ist ja wieder ganz anderes.
... zu einem Konzern geworden wären.
Ja.
Dann kommen wir mal zum Schlusswort tatsächlich.
Weil ich merke, wir reden schon sehr lange, glaube ich.
Ich wollte nur ganz kurz da noch...
Ganz kurz, zehn Minuten.
... ergänzen.
Das ist tatsächlich eben das.
Wie gesagt, auch das bei uns.
Eine GameStar ist jetzt auch 22 Jahre alt und so.
Und das ist halt, wenn Dinge lange laufen, Dinge verändern sich.
Auch durch die Personen, die dann da sind.
Neue kommen dazu, haben andere Schwerpunkte.
Und deswegen meine ich das von daher so ein bisschen deutlicher gesagt.
Dass Blizzard eben, was es heute gibt, ist nicht das, was viele im Kopf haben.
Und viele sollten halt dann eher mal wieder gucken, wo können sie denn andere...
Wo können sie ihr neues Blizzard finden?
Ja.
Da hat er voll und ganz recht.
Es hat wenig Sinn, wenn quasi hier die Strongstypen das Sagen haben bei Blizzard, permanent drauf rumzuhacken.
So nach dem Motto, Blizzard macht nicht mehr, was ich will.
Macht nicht das, was ich will.
Das wird Blizzard auch nicht mehr tun.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass es nicht doch die ein oder anderen Games gibt,
die einem quasi das Gefühl wieder geben.
Da sitzt ja jemand dahinter, der wirklich, wo Herzblut in dem Game steckt.
Das einzige Problem, was ich dabei sehe, ist, es ist unglaublich schwierig, gute Sachen zu finden.
Also wenn man sich mal durch Steam durchguckt, Steam ist so voll.
Steam ist so voll von Bullshit.
Egal in welchem Sektor.
Im AAA-Sektor natürlich, da kommt viel Bullshit raus.
Aber gerade im Indie-Sektor.
Steam ist so ein Drecksloch, was Spiele angeht.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht übertrieben, wenn ich sage, auf Steam sind 95% Schrott.
Und die restlichen 5%, von denen sind 90% auch nicht der Wahnsinn.
Aber die letzten 10%, die muss man halt finden.
So.
Und 95% ist eher untertrieben.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Genau, du musst das Gute im Scheißhaufen finden.
So sieht es aus.
Und woran man, finde ich, immer noch ganz gut sieht, wie die Leute ticken, ist,
also gerade bei größeren Sachen,
wieso die Konferenzen und Sachen abgehalten werden.
Manche Sachen sind so...
So cringe-mäßig, wo du richtig merkst, so irgendwie, okay,
da haben sich jetzt ein Marketing-Mensch und ein BWL-Mensch zusammengesetzt und haben da sich überlegt,
was wir irgendwie in der Show zeigen können oder so.
Deswegen sind die ganzen Konferenzen und Ankündigungen heute auch so wenig Gameplay und so wenig Inhalt,
sondern so viel Bullshit drumherum.
Lass mich einfach angucken, wer das Sagen hat.
Ich meine, wenn die ein neues Need for Speed ankündigen,
ich meine, die Marke kannst du eh mittlerweile vergessen,
da ist erstmal 10 Minuten Show mit irgendeinem prominenten, keine Ahnung, Basketballspieler,
ne, Moment, wir sind wieder bei EA,
mit irgendeinem, keine Ahnung, prominenten Formel-1-Fahrer,
der kommt dann mit irgendwie einem super expensive Auto aus dem LKW gefahren,
qualmt ein bisschen rum, fährt ein bisschen im Kreis,
dann kommt irgendwie so ein Möchtegern-Influencer-Mensch, der das Ganze moderiert,
irgendwelche schlechte Witze darüber macht,
in 30% der Präsentation, ich habe jetzt einfach mal Need for Speed genannt,
weil ich habe die letzten Need for Speed-Sachen gar nicht mehr geguckt, geschweige denn gespielt,
aber das ist bei vielen AAA-Sachen so,
die machen 30%, guckt euch, die Battlefield 1-Präsentation war auch so ein Ding, Alter.
Die machen 30% Show und am Ende bist du fast genauso wenig schlau wie vorher.
Cyberpunk Ocarina of Time war geil, ja, das stimmt.
Aber der Sache hast du auch angemerkt, dass es halt kein komplett gescriptetes Cringe-Ding gewesen ist,
sondern der hat wahrscheinlich echt Bock auf das Game, damit zu machen.
Natürlich kriegt der Kohle für, aber das wäre bescheuert, umsonst würde er das nicht machen.
Angeblich soll es ja sogar so gewesen sein, dass er gesagt hat, ihm gefällt das, er will eine größere Rolle haben
und irgendwie kaufe ich ihm das sogar ab.
Snoop Dogg Battlefield 1 gespielt hat, das fand ich sogar cool.
Wo Snoop Dogg Battlefield 1 gespielt hat, das war geil.
Der ist einfach nur im...
Der hat einfach...
Das war geil.
Der ist einfach nur im Kreis gelaufen die ganze Zeit in irgendeinem Graben
und hat irgendwie einen Joint geraucht.
Snoop Dogg Battlefield 1.
Das war geil, Alter.
Der läuft die ganze Zeit hier geradeaus hin und zurück in diesem Graben, Alter.
Er wartet darauf, ob jemand auf dieser Trenche reinkommt, um mit seinem Team zu arbeiten.
Du kannst die Konzentration sehen, schau an all diese Spieler.
Das war geil, Alter.
Die waren alle...
Die ganze Zeit, wenn er da hergelaufen ist.
Ich muss mich wirklich konzentrieren.
Ich muss mir sicher machen, dass ich...
Siehst du Stone Mountain da hinten?
Er macht sich sicher, dass...
Ja, sieh.
Snoop Dogg.
Er wartet darauf, ob jemand auf dieser Trenche reinkommt, um...
Sieht du die Konzentration?
Schau an all diese Spieler.
Ja, ich muss mich wirklich konzentrieren.
Sieh, sieht man das Scoreboard von ihm?
Ich muss mich sicher, dass ich...
Du siehst Stone Mountain und hat einfach...
Warte, warte, warte, warte.
Warte, warte, warte.
Sieht man das Scoreboard von ihm irgendwo?
Wer ist der denn?
Oh!
Wo ist er denn?
Ist das er selbst?
2 zu 4.
Fake Brain, Alter.
Massive.
Also, ja, wir, auch, wie schwer tun sich denn die...
So, ja, wir, auch, wie schwer tun sich denn die...
Kleinen, die Neuen auf dem Markt. Wie schwer ist es dort durchzuhalten, sichtbar zu bleiben, irgendwie eine Community aufzubauen. Und deswegen würde ich halt immer sagen, ja, Blizzard wird dann noch weitergehen und die machen halt dann eher Sachen wieder für den Großmarkt und müssen für irgendwie eben eher an die 100 Millionen Spieler denken.
Aber es gibt da draußen andere. So eben wie in CD Projekt eben auch aufgekommen ist, als aus einer Nische, wo andere das eher ein bisschen ignoriert hatten und dann konnten sie mit wieder hochwachsen, kann man sie lieben und vergöttern. Aber ganz sicher werden sie auch in 20 Jahren wahrscheinlich auch wieder nicht mehr das sein, was sie heute sind.
Und dann werden andere wieder sagen, ja, aber früher. Und das ist eben auch natürlich.
Als ihr noch diese tollen DLCs für Witcher 3 gemacht habt, 10 Euro für 30 Stunden.
Es ist halt einfach. Eine Unternehmung ist ein Stück weit natürlich auch ein lebendes Objekt und so weiter. Und da haben wir jetzt gar nicht drüber gesprochen.
Ja, aber das muss mir als derjenige, der die Spiele gut fand, die sie gemacht haben, die Entwicklung muss mir ja nicht gefallen. Das ist ja das, was ich die ganze Zeit sagen will. Es ist eine Sache, ob man das nachvollziehen kann, warum was so ist oder ob man es gut findet.
Am Ende ist es ein Aktien- oder ein börsennotiertes Unternehmen.
Es ist also für Blizzard und CD Projekt.
Es ist vollkommen unerheblich, ob ich das gut finde oder ob die Leute das gut finden.
Wenn die Kohle machen wollen, machen sie Kohle. Das juckt die nicht. Aber ich persönlich muss es ja nicht gut finden. Auch wenn ich weiß, warum sie es machen.
Dort auf Bobby Kotick werden halt leider, würde ich jetzt mal so sagen, aber eben sehr nur über eben auch diese Performance an der Börse belohnt.
Also ich hab mal nachgeguckt, der hat irgendwie so 30 Millionen Dollar Compensation im letzten Jahr erhalten oder stehen die mit zu.
Wenn ich es richtig zusammengerechnet habe, sind davon über 80 Prozent gekoppelt an den Unternehmenswert oder an den Aktienkurs.
Das heißt, er wiederum...
Wie, wenn er das nicht erfüllt hätte, dann hätte er nur 5 Millionen gekriegt. Oh fuck, Alter. Da kannst du ja von fast nichts mehr leisten.
Nur wo Kunden sind, wo Märkte sind und dann schiebt er die Unternehmung dahin und wenn dann man sagt, okay, ich muss eine Million Diablo-Fans zurücklassen, weil ich schiele ja auf die 100 Millionen Mobile-Fans,
dann tut der das.
Bitte jetzt keine Kommentare zu, ich würde auch mit 20 Prozent von 30 Millionen Dollar klarkommen.
Das geht gar nicht darum, dass der rumheult, der heult ja nicht rum, ich will nur die...
Der ist knallhart.
So und auch da wieder ist es so, es ist Big Business und das ist das Image, wir sind doch von euch, von Spielern, von Spielern, ist manchmal einfach auch eben nur genau das ist ein Image.
Das ist auch schon Teil der Marketinggeschichte. Am Ende reden wir hier über Entertainment.
Es muss aber klar sein, dass die, dass die ihre Spieler weder lieben noch wirklich das ernst meinen, wenn sie erzählen so nach dem Motto, wir haben die Besten und Dedicatedsten und sonst was, das ist alles Berechnung.
Das muss aber klar sein.
Ja, der Lion King, alles schön kuschelig, nett oder frozen, das sind knallharte Milliardenunternehmen und wer dahinter guckt, sieht das halt auch und da muss man sich dann halt eher insgesamt fragen.
Aber wie gesagt, das würde ich nicht blizzardpersönlich...
Naja, es ist so, wir sind ja auch schon so vor Ort, es ist voll andauernd, wie viel Geld wir jetzt damit verdienen, weil wir in Europa alles verdienen wollen.
Und da sagen die Leute im Internet so, oh, ihr wollt Geld verdienen, ihr seid gierig und so.
So, in dieser Welt haben wir uns ein bisschen entschieden, halt auch zu leben.
Kapitalismus, Marktwirtschaft etc.
Und so weiter und so fort und wenn...
Aber was ich scheiße finden kann ist, ich kann es Ihnen nicht wirklich übel nehmen, ich kann es Ihnen nicht wirklich freuen, aber was ich halt scheiße finden kann ist, dass da nicht mehr die Spiele rauskommen, die mir Spaß machen.
gesagt, dann lieber Sachen unterstützen, die es anders machen, die was Neues probieren,
die sich wieder hochkämpfen wollen, aber vielleicht nicht dann immer hoffen, dass der
Megakonzern dann immer noch auch der totale Fanversteher ist und auf jeden Einzelnen guckt.
Da kannst du ja nicht mehr drauf hoffen.
Was kommt mir im Kopf, ob sich Sachen wie Diablo Immortal und so damals auf den Aktienkurs
ausgewirkt haben? Ich meine schon, dass das kurz nach unten geht, aber es hat viel langfristig…
Das ist auch so eine totale Mär. Ich habe 3,5 Jahre mal als Wirtschaftsredakteur
gearbeitet bei der dpa und es gibt so viel auch wieder Halbwissen, Unwissen über Verhalten
von Aktienmärkten und ich sehe ganz oft YouTube-Videos, Blizzard-Shares-Crash-after-d-d-d-d-Announcement.
Entschuldigung, das ist nicht immer ganz so, weil der Gesamtmarkt beeinflusst das viel
stärker und zum Beispiel Blizzard hatte seinen Höchststand, ich habe nochmal nachgeguckt
jetzt, was die Aktienkurve angeht, ich glaube Sommer 2018. Sie haben danach massiv verloren,
haben zuletzt wieder ein bisschen gewonnen, sprich der Gesamtmarkt und damit meine ich
gar nicht nur die Börse an sich, sondern auch der Gesamt-Gaming-Markt kann mehr entscheidend
sein als so etwas wie ein verpatztes Announcement. Auch jetzt mit Warcraft hatte ich auch ein
Video gesehen, irgendwie Shares fell 5 Prozent.
Ja.
5 Prozent nach Reforged-Desaster und so. Das stimmt nicht. Der gesamte Markt hat in
dem Tag massig verloren und am nächsten Tag ging es wieder hoch.
War ganz davon abgesehen, als würde das jemand, der wirklich daran auch interessiert ist,
an Blizzard, ob der großartig jucken, dass Reforged in die Hose gegangen ist. Ich glaube,
die würde das viel eher jucken, wenn Blizzard noch, jetzt mal rein Stonks- und Geldsicht,
die würde das wahrscheinlich viel eher jucken, wenn Blizzard noch drei Jahre an Reforged
rumgebastelt hätte und massig Geld verschlungen hätte für ein Produkt, was sich eventuell
gar nicht so gut verkauft. Und das ist denen wahrscheinlich lieber. Es kommt jetzt raus,
hat ein bisschen Kohle gekostet und verkauft sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht so wahnsinnig
gut. Weiß ich nicht, wie da die Zahlen sind. Das ist denen mit Sicherheit lieber.
Sehr komplex. Das heißt nicht, dass nicht irgendwie langfristige Entscheidungen negativ
sind, aber auch da wieder das Gesamtunternehmen.
Hier, man sieht es auch, ist auf einem sehr guten Weg gewesen. Sie haben jetzt, deswegen
auch die Cuts. Sie haben letztes Jahr, glaube ich, angekündigt, 800 Leute zu entlassen.
Also Activision Blizzard insgesamt.
Activision Blizzard als Gesamtes.
Das waren vor allem Support-Mitarbeiter und so. Und das war auch teilweise so, weil sie
Destiny nicht mehr hatten. Also der Destiny Support wurde gecutt und so.
Ja, und sie wussten schon, sie kommen in einen Bereich, wo sie jetzt erstmal Umsatzschwäche
haben. Und das ist dann auch wieder ganz normal. Auch da wieder muss man nicht gut finden,
aber so ist es halt, gerade in den USA.
Ja.
Man holt schnell Leute rein, wenn man sie braucht, wenn man schnell wächst und man
feuert sie auf, wenn man sagt, okay, jetzt sieht es nicht so doll aus. Aber wie gesagt,
im Gesamtspektrum, sonst wäre auch Bobby Kotick nicht so lange dabei, führt der Activision
sehr erfolgreich. Das muss man leider auch mal festhalten. Und das ist nämlich dann
auch noch der entscheidende Punkt von Blizzard, ist nicht, wie ihr Umsatz gerade ist. Sie
haben ein Problem mit ihren Active-Usern, weil das ist die Haupteinheit. Also viele
Unternehmen, also gerade auch Spieleunternehmen, müssen jetzt offenlegen, wie viel Monthly,
also M-A-U heißt das, Monthly Active Users haben sie.
Wisst ihr?
Und Blizzard…
Okay, dann ist das das, was ich vorhin versucht habe zu umschreiben. Ich wusste nicht, wie
man das genau nennt. Mit, dass sie das nicht reinmachen, Diablo 3 am Leben halten, für
die Fans.
Einziger Teil innerhalb der Gesamt-Corporation, die verloren haben. Nämlich von 35 Millionen
Active User 2018, jetzt in einem neuen Report, jetzt von letzter Woche, sind es noch 32. Während,
alle anderen Beispiele, die sie verloren haben, die haben sie verloren. Und das ist dann auch
so, dass sie das nicht reinmachen. Und das ist dann auch so, dass sie das nicht reinmachen,
während alle anderen beiden Sparten, hier King auf 150 Millionen Active User und Activision
selbst mit Call of Duty, ich habe nicht mehr den genauen Wert, ist aber auch deutlich gestiegen
durch den Erfolg von Call of Duty, ist wieder hoch. Und das ist nämlich der Signal. Wenn
du da siehst, okay, du verlierst irgendwie deine Active User, dann wird die Unternehmung
anfangen. Und wahrscheinlich wird sie aber nicht anfangen im Spielersinne. Nämlich,
okay, dann gehen wir dem Ganzen noch dran.
Ja.
Dann machen wir drei Jahre mehr und dann machen wir noch mehr.
Machen wir noch einen Hearthstone-Add-on.
Sondern sie werden vermutlich eher weiter anfangen zu fokussieren und zu restrukturieren.
Also sozusagen Overwatch, alle Kraft darauf. Und das eher weg. Das eher weg. Also auch
dort, das würde mich nicht wundern, wenn wir in drei Jahren hier sitzen und dann gibt
es vielleicht nur noch zwei Blizzard IPs oder maximal drei. Das wäre zum Beispiel
jetzt so meine Prognose in die Zukunft.
Hearthstone, wow.
In diesem Firmenkonstrukt.
Overwatch.
Ich habe ja auch gesagt, wer weiß, vielleicht kauft ja irgendjemand Neues dann mal Blizzard
da irgendwie. In diesem Firmenkonstrukt glaube ich, wird der Weg in Richtung Mobile gehen,
in Richtung weniger IPs, in Richtung volle Monetarisierung von, wie du schon sagtest,
von Spielen, die lange laufen, die dauerhaft Geld einbringen müssen.
Sehr schlimm hier. In drei Jahren mag ich Blizzard nicht mehr, in 20 Jahren mag ich
CD Projekt nicht mehr. Geh weg, René. Das ist genug.
Es gibt auch so viele tolle neue.
Das fand ich, das fand ich auch tatsächlich ein schönes Schlusswort von dir wiederum.
Ja.
Dass man dann als Spieler ja durchaus angehalten ist, mal zu gucken, was könnte denn das neue
Blizzard sein.
Steam ist voll. Game Pass ist voll.
Ja, Steam ist voll.
Game Pass ist voll.
Mit so vielen tollen, also nicht nur Indies, sondern auch so mitten.
Es gibt, es gibt schon gute Sachen, aber es ist halt, es ist wirklich schwierig, was zu
finden.
Es gibt so viel, also wir leben in einer Zeit von so viel Auswahl, von so vielen guten
Spielen und vielleicht müssen wir halt mal wieder ein bisschen aus unserer Komfortzone
raus und ein bisschen wieder neugierig sein und da einfach auch mal anderen Sachen wieder
ne Chance geben.
Das finde ich gut.
Wir enden jetzt damit, bevor du wieder irgendwas Böses, Düsteres sagen wolltest.
Nein, geh weg.
Dann danke ich euch beiden für eure Einschätzung und gebt das mal noch an die Zuschauer weiter.
Habt ihr denn Tipps, was das nächste Blizzard sein könnte für Leute, die jetzt deprimiert
sind wegen…
Wenn ich das hätte, würde ich mir Stonks kaufen.
Das einzige, worauf ich mich im Gaming-Sektor wirklich in naher Zukunft freue, also so
innerhalb von 10 Tagen.
Ist die neue Path of Exile League, da wäre ich wieder mit den Hintern wundgrinden.
Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt ja die erste League wieder gespielt seit 5 Jahren, wo ich das
Game nicht angefasst habe.
Das hat ultra Bock gemacht.
Ich setze jetzt auf am Ende der League, ich meine die League ist vorbei jetzt, ich glaube
in 3 Tagen oder so.
Oder so, wann ist das?
10.
In einer Woche.
In einer Woche ist die aktuelle Path of Exile League.
Also viel werde ich da jetzt auch nicht mehr machen.
Ich habe ziemlich viel Ingame-Währung noch über.
Ich habe gerade glaube ich jetzt 12 Exalted-Orbs über und was ich Chaos-Orbs, also ich könnte
den zweiten Charakter locker noch magieren für die letzten 10 Tage, aber es macht halt
übelst Bock.
Und ich habe noch lange nicht alles soweit gecheckt, dass ich gut klarkommen würde in
dem Game.
Leakcrime.
Also es kann durchaus sein, dass wir einen Path of Exile-Stream machen, wenn die League
startet.
Ich muss mal gucken, an welchem Tag startet die nochmal, Moment, gucken wir mal.
Ähm.
Ach fuck, wie hieß das Neue?
PoE D Delirium.
Wann kommt das raus, wann startet?
13.
Am 13.
Der 13.
ist ein Freitag.
Oh, das ist wunderbar.
Freitag.
Da machen wir wahrscheinlich wirklich mal einen Freitag.
Ja, Freitag.
Freitag.
Daran gibt es mehr als 18 Stunden,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 Stunden PoE Crying Stream.
Welche Seite ist eigentlich gut um in PoE einzusteigen?
Guckt ihr ein paar Tutorials auf YouTube an.
So, okay, und jetzt was soll ich mir noch, den Tweet von Ninja sollte ich mir noch angucken.
Ein sehr kontroverser Tweet hat jemand geschrieben.
Mal gucken wie kontrovers dieser Tweet wirklich ist von Ninja.
Was hat er denn geschrieben?
Ist, äh, oh fuck, wie soll ich das jetzt übersetzen, ist, ist, ist schlechte, ist ein, eine schwache, eine schwache Einstellung, könnte man das so übersetzen, schwache Einstellung, ähm, wenn man zufrieden ist mit dem, was passiert, äh, wenn man zufrieden ist damit zu verlieren, wenn man mit, äh, irgendwie nicht perfektem Spielen, ähm, zufrieden ist, äh, wenn man aufhört, äh, sauer zu werden, nachdem man verloren hat,
hat man doppelt verloren, ähm, es gilt immer Sachen zu lernen und es ist immer, äh, Raum sich zu verbessern, äh, man soll niemals Ruhe geben, okay, äh, warum ist das jetzt so, so, so kontrovers, warum ist das jetzt so kontrovers, dieser Tweet, er hat doch prinzipiell, also, wenn man das mal auf, auf, auf Spielen, beziehungsweise auf sich verbessern, sich verbessern bezieht, hat er doch recht, ja, man muss sich einfach überlegen, äh, wie ernst man war,
wie ernst man war, wenn man was rein aus Casual, rein aus Just for Fun macht, ähm, und keine Ambitionen hat, da irgendwie besser drin zu werden, irgendwie im Rank zu steigen oder sonst was, hey, dann ist das vollkommen zu, okay zu sagen, oh, fuck, nehmen wir Overwatch, ja, wenn man da wirklich keine, keine Ambitionen hat, irgendwie einen besseren Rank zu kriegen oder CS oder LOL oder irgendwas, ja, und, ähm, man spielt einfach nur mal ab und zu, vielleicht mit ein paar Freunden, die man L kennt, irgendwie ein paar Runde, vielleicht sogar irgendwelche
Bot-Matches oder so, äh, es gibt ja gerade, gerade so die Hyper-Casual-Leute haben ja Probleme mit PvP-Spielen, die spielen am liebsten gegen Bots oder sonst was, ähm, oder auch, dann ist es doch vollkommen okay zu sagen, es ist nur ein Spiel, aber ihm geht's ja nicht darum, sondern ihm geht's um Leute, die sich verbessern wollen in dem Spiel, eindeutig, und, ähm, wenn man dort quasi bei jedem Mal, wo man verliert, sagt, ach, nee, ist ja nicht so schlimm, äh, ist ja nur ein Spiel,
dann, äh, wird man auch nicht das Interesse haben, die Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, die notwendig sind, dass man besser wird, was nicht bedeutet, ähm, was nicht bedeutet, dass man, äh, seine, schreibt er ja irgendwie, seine Tastatur einschlagen soll, sondern unter anderem, mal angenommen, ich spiele jetzt, ähm, ich spiele jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich spiele Overwatch, ich spiele, ich spiele Ana als Support, so, ähm, und ich habe eine Runde verloren,
zu sagen, ähm, ah, das ist, das ist nur ein Spiel, ich logge jetzt aus, sonst was, okay, aber wenn man Ambitionen hat, sich zu verbessern, wäre es ziemlich bescheuert, zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, ach, da kann ich eh nix dran machen, es war entweder das Team oder es war das Spiel, nee, eine der Sachen, die man dann machen kann, ist, natürlich ist man stinkig und am besten ist man erstmal sauer, natürlich unter anderem auf sein Team, das ist, geht in Teamgames immer ein bisschen Hand in Hand,
aber man ist auch, und das merkt man,
das habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon öfters auch gemerkt, wenn ich manchmal Sachen spiele, wo ich mal ganz gut drin gewesen bin und jetzt mittlerweile sacke, ne, also Spiele, wo ich dann lange nicht gespielt habe, wo man beispielsweise ein bisschen mit dem Eax vor, vor einer Weile wieder Overwatch Rank gespielt hat, war ich übelst stinkig, allerdings auf mich selber, ähm, und, ähm, auch wo man mal wieder angefangen hat, hier ein bisschen, ein bisschen Battlefield zu spielen und so, da bin ich übelst sauer, aber gar nicht so sehr auf das Game, sondern weil ich weiß, dass ich es gerade voll verkacke,
und wenn man, wenn man das sich nicht, da hat er vollkommen recht, wenn man das sich nicht eingestehen kann, ähm, dann hast du, hast du gelitten, ja, und was man machen kann, ist ja nicht, dass man sich dann selbst irgendwie, äh, du musst ja nicht selbst irgendwie eine klatschen und sagen, Max, spiel besser, das hilft nix, ähm, du musst dann Sachen, du musst dann Maßnahmen ergreifen, die, die helfen, besser zu werden, gibt's ja verschiedenste Dinger, du kannst dir Replays angucken und analysieren, was du verkehrt gemacht hast, du kannst mit deinen Teammates, wenn du ein festes Team hast, drüber sprechen, okay,
was für eine Taktik wollen wir machen, wie, wie, wie wollen wir das in Zukunft, wie wollen wir das in Zukunft spielen, ähm, vielleicht haben auch deine Teammates Hinweise, was man machen könnte, es kommt halt immer drauf an, ob man gescheite Teammates hat oder nicht, welche, die nur flamen können, oder welche, die auch ordentlich was sagen können, ähm, man kann gucken, okay, was ist denn das, was ich, was es mir Mechanic-mäßig fehlt, fehlt's mir daran, dass ich die Maps nicht kenne, fehlt's mir daran, dass ich nicht aimen kann, äh, ist meine Hardware kacke für das jeweilige Game, was auch immer, das Wichtigste ist, man muss analysieren, woran das liegt,
warum man verkackt hat, und wenn man die Aussage trifft, es ist nur ein Spiel, nicht weiter schlimm, und man hat die Ambition, in dem Spiel besser zu werden, dann verträgt sich das nicht, weil wenn man einfach nur sagt, äh, es ist nur ein Spiel, und, äh, juckt mich nicht, dann wird man das nicht analysieren, und dementsprechend auch nicht besser werden, und aus dem Gesichtspunkt hat er doch vollkommen recht, über was regen sich die Leute denn jetzt da drin auf, der hat doch, der hat doch vollkommen recht, wenn's um Competitive Games geht,
okay, also,
was antworten die Leute denn drauf?
This is disappointing, this is a disappointing stance.
Ah, ja.
But why?
Guck mal, die Antwort
ist vollkommen
an dem vorbei, was er geschrieben hat.
Die Antwort ist voll an dem vorbei, was er geschrieben hat.
Also, ich,
wie ich das interpretiere, hab ich ja grad erzählt,
die letzten 10 Minuten irgendwie,
aber die Antwort ist doch vollkommen
an dem vorbei, was er geschrieben hat.
Und vor allem, es, äh,
es ist doch vollkommen egal, auch bei dieser Aussage,
wer er jetzt persönlich ist.
Das ist ein Ding, das, das könnte man
für alle Competitive-Sachen so
umschreiben, ja.
Aber, okay, sie, sie, sie ist enttäuscht, dass er so
eine Einstellung hat, äh, vor allem von
jemandem, der, der quasi so eine,
so eine Zuschauergemeinschaft hat,
und, äh, die würde das ja
angeblich, die Zuschauer würden das ja angeblich
so auffassen wie, es ist in Ordnung,
wenn ich, äh, wenn ich mein Keyboard
kaputt, äh, meine Tastatur kaputt schlage,
und, ähm,
Screamed at my loved ones. Alter,
was ein bescheuerteres
reininterpretieren, das, was er da
gepostet hat.
Sowas beknacktes.
Also, das könnte, das, das könnte mich echt aufregen.
Das hat er nie gesagt.
Nicht mal, das kann man,
wenn man ehrlich ist, kann man das da noch
nicht mal reininterpretieren.
Das kann man, also, man muss schon wirklich,
man muss schon, das, das tut,
das ist wirklich painstrap, das tut weh.
Ähm, da muss man schon wirklich
sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr weit ausholen, dass man auf die Idee
kommt, das da rein zu interpretieren,
was sie geschrieben hat.
Also,
oh Gott.
Punch a hole in the wall
just because I lost the game.
Auf der anderen Seite,
gehen wir mal, gehen wir mal den Extremfall, ähm,
den Extremfall aus, weil angenommen, ja,
das, um jetzt mal zu zeigen,
dass das, dass ein Loch in die Wand
schlagen, jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben, aber sag mal,
den Controller gegen die Wand pfeffern,
dass das nicht, äh,
dass das eigentlich was
Menschliches ist, weil, überlegt
euch mal, jemand möchte wirklich
besser werden in dem Game, wirklich besser werden in irgendwas
und, ähm,
hat auch wirklich viel geübt.
Ja? Äh,
mal angenommen, jemand hat viel, jemand hat viel, viel,
viel geübt, gelernt von sonst was
und im entscheidenden Moment
verkackt das. Dann ist der halt übelst
enttäuscht und sauer auf sich selbst und da kann
auch mal ein Controller an die Wand fliegen.
So what? Ja?
Ich glaube, die Leute interpretieren das
angry ein bisschen, ein bisschen zu.
Es geht, es geht einfach eher darum,
dass man, dass man
auf sich selbst
sauer ist, dass man, dass man
ein bisschen böse auf sich selbst ist,
weil man es verkackt hat. Wenn man das nicht hat,
hat man doch auch kaum eine Motivation
zu sagen, ich, ich, ich will das, ich will das besser
machen. Du musst dir erstmal
denken, scheiße, da hab ich's verkackt.
Du musst erstmal diese Einsicht, diese Einsicht
haben, so nach dem Motto, scheiße, ich hab's verkackt
äh, und allein schon mit dieser Aussage,
merkst du ja, oh fuck, ich, äh, ich hab's
verkackt, weil wenn du das nicht merkst,
dann, dann kommst du ja auch gar nicht auf die Idee, aha, da muss ich was
machen. It's just a read.
Das ist, das ist eigentlich eine gute Kopie
Pasta, oder? This phrase, it's just
a game, da, da könnte man eine gute Kopie Pasta
draus machen. Alter, was,
das, die Antwort hier, wer ist das überhaupt?
Bomb, wer ist Geek Bomb?
Was ist Geek Bomb?
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ähm, oh Gott!
Oh!
Das ist, das Schmerz ist ja,
das tut ja weh!
Oh Gott!
Alter!
Was ist mit den Leuten los?
Muss man echt allem irgendwie
so seinen Stempel aufdrücken?
Es geht
ihm offensichtlich um Leute,
die sich
in einer gewissen Disziplin
verbessern wollen. Es ist doch
vollkommen egal, ob das jetzt CS ist,
Fortnite, oder
keine Ahnung,
100 Meter
schwimmen, oder so.
Ist doch vollkommen egal.
Ähm, jemand, der
für sich sagt, er möchte
besser werden, der von
sich selbst, der an sich selbst
den Anspruch hat, in einer Disziplin
besser zu werden, da geht's ihm doch
drum. Da geht's ihm doch drum.
Und da sagt doch auch nicht einer
so nach dem Motto, ah ja gut,
ich hab jetzt zwar drei Monate,
drei Monate hier, ähm,
hab ich das zwar trainiert, dass ich das
hinkriege, aber, ja,
es hat leider jetzt nicht funktioniert. Nein,
die Leute sind stinkig, wenn's nicht funktioniert
hat. Und die sind meistens
stinkig auf sich selber.
Ich, äh,
you're essentially telling young kids to keep
playing until you win or you are a failure.
Hat er, äh,
äh, falsches E-Mode.
Da platzt der Mensch der Kopf, wenn man das liest.
There's always room for
improvement. Winning isn't
everything. Continuity, trying to improve
yourself,
Gewinnen, in dem Sinn,
für sich selbst, muss das, also,
Gewinnen heißt nicht zwangsläufig, ich bin
erster Platz.
Aber natürlich ist es das Ziel von jemandem,
der sich in irgendwas verbessern will,
dass er damit auch dann quasi
gewinnt, gegenüber
anderen, die halt nicht so, also,
wo er besser ist. Immer wenn du
besser bist und was besser ausführst als andere,
hast du quasi gewonnen in dem Sinn.
Ich kann das nicht verstehen, warum die da
so, na gut, ähm,
wenn du 5,5 Millionen,
Follower hast, da bleibt das nicht aus.
Ja, Matt, genau, so, das ist ja
genau das. Und,
und, überhaupt nichts, wo man sich wahnsinnig
drüber, drüber empören muss.
Aber eins zeigt uns das wieder,
dass wenn sowas, wenn sowas
schon kontrovers ist,
wenn sowas schon
irgendwie als kontrovers gilt, dann
da hilft nichts mehr, das ist vorbei.
Dann,
the fuck, Alter.
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Wir sind dort kaum dazu
geguckt.
Fast 4, 3 Stunden 40 on.
Schau mal auf die deutschen
Twitter-Trends. Soll ich das wirklich machen, oder
wollt ihr nochmal meine Atemschutzmaske sehen?
Ähm,
okay, Twitter, Twitter-Trends
Deutschland.
Was sind die Twitter-Trends?
Doppelpass?
Mario
Basler? Fußball, Fußball,
schönen Sonntag, Eiswein, Flüchtling,
Toleranz. Naja,
Fußball halt, wir sind in
Deutschland.
Fußball halt.
Und mal wieder eines der Lieblings-Empörungsthemen
auf Twitter schlechthin.
Grenze, Erpressung, Verstärkung, Drake.
Was macht der denn?
FC Bayern. Gut,
Fußballtechnisch muss es ja gestern wohl wirklich abgegangen sein,
das hab sogar ich mitgekriegt, ihr wisst, ich interessiere mich null
für Fußball, dass sie entweder ein Fußballspiel
fast abgesagt hätten oder abgesagt haben.
Äh,
irgendwas in der Richtung.
Aber mehr hab ich davon auch nicht mitgekriegt.
Was macht eigentlich Corona so auf Twitter gerade?
Mal kurz gucken.
Corona.
Virus.
DE.
Was gibt's da grad Neues?
Gestern beim Einkommen haben sich zwei Typen fast
eingeschlagen wegen einem Pack Wasser.
Da bin ich ja richtig froh,
dass ich so einen Wassersprudler daheim hab
und im Zweifelsfall
einen ganzen
Fischteich mit Wasser, das ich
abkochen kann. Fußball, Toleranz und
Flüchtlinge, Deutschland in der Nutshell.
Zumindest in den Twitter-Trends.
Okay, was gibt's denn hier? Corona.de.
Aktuell sind keine weiteren Verdachtsfälle gemeldet.
Gut, es ist Sonntag.
Da werden die Leute
weniger krank.
Nicht wirklich irgendwas Spannendes, Neues.
Langweilig.
Leute, wir gucken uns jetzt noch eine Runde Battlefield an.
Brauchen wir ein bisschen was zum Ausruhen.
Warum? Was für
Schwermetall? Du meinst, weil es da reingeregnet hat, oder wie?
Genossen bleibt
standhaft. Ja, manche Leute, weiß ich auch nicht, was mit denen
los ist.
Außerdem, wenn es hart auf hart kommt, ich hab noch
die Heizung im Keller.
Die hat einen
130 Liter Tank.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema Heizung
sind. Was macht eigentlich
meine Heizung gerade?
Die Pumpe geht wieder nicht.
Ah.
Die Pumpe geht nicht.
Was macht der Druck im Keller?
Moment, Leute, ich muss mal gucken, was der Druck
im Keller macht.
Der ist ja fast unter 1 jetzt.
Kein Wunder, dass die Pumpe nicht pumpt.
Die kann wahrscheinlich nicht pumpen.
Weil der Druck zu gering ist.
Alter, der Heizungswahn
muss echt morgen kommen.
Was ist das voll für ein Arsch?
Zum Glück hab ich meine Klimaanlage, die auch heizen kann.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Leider
geht den Druck, der Druck automatisch auslesen
geht nicht, weil der Druck ist
sehr analog.
Die Anzeige ist analog und keiner der
Sensoren von der Heizung
bietet mir die Möglichkeit,
den Druck abzufragen.
Ich hab hier sonst alles drin, was die Heizung
ausliest,
aber den Druck, der
der geht bloß per
Kamera. Was das für eine Kamera ist?
Ganz so eine hier.
Das ist eine China Cam unter der Haube.
Unter der Haube ist das eine China Cam,
die übrigens viel günstiger ist,
als man das hier gerade sieht.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich mir die Kamera
gekauft habe, ist, weil ich die einmal im
10er Pack bestellt habe.
Also die hier und die hier.
Und weil es dafür eine Customfirma gibt.
Das ist die Customfirma, die ich da drauf habe.
Die Arbeit, da jetzt OpenCV drüber zu machen
und Druck, ne, ne, ne, da habe ich keinen
Bock drauf.
Man kann es auch übertreiben.
Zumal, was habe ich davon?
Ich habe ein Bild
mit einem, wie nennt man dieses Ding?
Manometer?
Drauf?
Oder aber ich hätte ein Bild in meinem
Kafana mit einem Manometer drauf, was das
analoge Manometer anzeigt.
Das macht keinen großen Sinn.
Das macht keinen großen Unterschied.
Außerdem hoffe ich ja, dass ich das bald nicht brauche.
Weil der Heizungsmann das repariert hat.
Man kann es auch übertreiben.
Ihr wisst, ich sage so lange, man kann es übertreiben,
bis ich es dann übertreibe.
Wobei ich die Idee mit OpenCV echt gut finde.
Könnte man vielleicht mal ausprobieren.
So, das ist die, das ist die Customfirma für die Kamera.
Das ist eine ganz normale China Cam.
Musst du dich in deinem Haus eigentlich noch bewegen?
Ja, ja, ja, leider.
Leider muss ich mich noch bewegen.
Okay.
Battlefield.
Ah, yes, exzellent.
Exquisite.
Bam, den Kopf.
Jetzt schreckt, Alter.
Alter, wie sie da rum, wieder, wieder rum lupen.
Hello and welcome to the Battlefield 4 Top Plays.
What an amazing clip that was to start off the episode.
Quick sent in a load of clips.
They're all only in Battlefield Moments.
And he's the sort of.
Ist das hier ein React-Stream?
Das hier ist ein Big Brain-Stream.
Guy that will pull these things off.
Wenn du auch ein Big Brain haben willst, kostet dich das einfach nur einen Prime-Suff.
It doesn't matter whether he's in a shopper, playing infantry in a tank.
He's always getting these amazing Only in Battlefield Moments.
Ich muss meine, ich weiß Leute, ich muss meine Sellout-Übergänge noch ein bisschen üben.
Aber Übung macht den Meister.
It's as you can see, a couple of them in the background, just as a taster of what's to come.
He's getting all sorts of epic.
Hab keinen Amazon Prime.
Top-Late Moments.
Ah, du darfst auch so da bleiben.
This is what Battlefield 4 is renowned for.
Linus TechTipStore.
Ey, Linus TechTipStore ist der Beste.
Ist Überleitung-Sellout der Beste.
BigXTheOne abonniert Twitch Prime.
Ja, das unser Hirn wird wirklich, steigt ins Unermessliche langsam.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Samus Prime.
Samus Kramer.
PureSavage3, Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Samus Kramer.
Es wird hier immer, es wird immer, das Hirn, also der Chat,
heute ist wirklich schon, der Chat ist eigentlich, um ehrlich zu sein, ist der Chat, ist der Chat schon so.
Ja, also nachdem, der Hype-Train ist am Start, Leute.
Abonniert Stufe 1, 7 Monate, Chuck96, huge.
Leute, der Hype-Train läuft.
Das ist gar Wahnsinn.
Official Matus, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Samus Kramer.
Stufe 1 ist erreicht.
Der, das ist, mich hat noch vorhin einer gefragt, so, äh,
was hat Amazon noch mit Twitch vor?
Diese Sache, die sie jetzt eingeführt haben mit dem Hype-Train,
genau solche Sachen werden wir in Zukunft öfters auf Twitch sehen.
In allen möglichen Varianten und Variationen.
Einfach, weil das dazu führt, dass die Leute Geld auf Twitch ausgeben.
Der Scam-Train.
Und vielleicht schaffe ich es auch irgendwann mal in nächster Zeit,
von den 20 oder 24 Emote-Slots,
mal ein paar neue auf Fiverr zu bestellen.
Anstatt die vier Emotes, die wir schon irgendwie seit einem Jahr drin haben.
Bis einer wenige so geblieben sind, wie er ist.
Ja, nur ich mache zwar keinen Call of Duty mehr,
aber ich habe halt den Vorteil gehabt,
an der Stelle muss ich es auch mal sagen,
auf YouTube,
ich war halt schon,
äh, 20 plus, als ich mit YouTube angefangen habe.
Und, ähm,
ich war quasi fertig.
Im Gegensatz zu den anderen, die dann mit 14 angefangen haben.
Und quasi, mit ihrem eigenen YouTube-Erfolg aufgewachsen sind.
Wo ist eigentlich mal ein T-Shirt vom T-Shirt-Giveaway?
Im Zug.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass ich nicht mal wirklich ein T-Shirt-Giveaway gemacht habe.
Aber ich habe eigentlich alles immer verschickt bei einem Giveaway.
Gucken wir mal weiter bei Netflix.
Das war ein Choke. Nein, da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen.
Da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen. Ich hätte gedacht, dass es hier...
...happening to you or a friend.
Whilst in BF5 and BF1...
Hardware an der Heizung, äh, Raspberry Pi Zero.
Oh, jetzt habe ich den Shot nicht gesehen.
Aufwach-Stream-Kaffeetasse.
Oh, das ist eine gute Idee.
...happens all the time, in every game,
there's always an only in-battlefield moment happening
to you or a friend.
Whilst in BF5 and BF1,
there are still only in-battlefield moments...
Okay, das war nicht predicted. Das kann mir keiner erzählen,
dass das predicted war.
...but is never on the same level as what we had in Battlefield 4.
This game was just on a different level
when it came to these crazy...
TROPSZZ sagt,
ich warte immer noch auf meine
1000 Euro plus Xbox 360.
Ah, yes.
Und ich warte auf deinen Twitch Prime Sub.
...nice.
...highlight moments,
like the stuff you're seeing in the background.
I'll leave a few more of them for you to watch,
because I just love watching them.
Ja, der Kommentator sagt echt immer das Gleiche.
Jedes Mal.
...because they are that awesome.
Oh, der war cool!
Der war cool!
I'll watch them again when this video eventually releases,
because they are that awesome.
Ich meine, das ist halt übelst Glück,
dass der sich auch nicht bewegt hat,
aber das war schon...
Ein Sender hat kurz gar nicht überstehen...
...Fliex...Fliexpress?
Oh, das stimmt wahrscheinlich hinten und vorne.
Ich habe Dankeschön für den Sub.
...Samscrimer!
...cute brain.
Also Yuki, vielleicht, wenn du 25 plus bist,
und da können wir mal probieren,
weiblich 25 plus
und vielleicht auch irgendwo aus der Nähe von Frankfurt,
da können wir mal probieren,
ob das theoretisch möglich wäre.
Wo soll man kochen können?
Nein, nein, Michael,
jetzt hier,
wenn das jetzt wieder die falschen Leute lesen,
Michael, im Chat,
dann ist gleich die Abmahnung raus.
Natürlich müssen Frauen nicht kochen können.
Grinch flirrt auf Twitch.
Also ich glaube,
ich weiß nicht,
wenn das jetzt schon der Flirt für dich war,
aber der Michael ist eh zu sehr mit seinem...
Was hat er letztens erzählt?
Im Chat?
Warte mal, wie war das, Michael?
Ich krieg das nicht mal zusammen.
Was hast du letztens erzählt?
Der Virgin?
Der Virgin Simulator oder irgendwas?
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Du bist ja schon beschäftigt genug.
Das war die Geschichte, wo ich gesagt habe,
du darfst dir einen Emote aussuchen,
und ich bis heute kein Emote,
kein Emote gepastelt habe dafür.
Ach so,
Version Manager war das.
Version Manager.
Ah, yes.
Guck dir Moji an,
wie er Weiber auf Twitch...
Wer ist Moji?
Weiß niemand, wer Moji ist?
Ich will gar nicht nachgucken,
ehrlich gesagt.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Modern... äh...
äh... Man of Honor War... ne...
Warfighter? Äh... nix.
Da kommen die Gegner aus dem Boden gefahren,
wer sich noch dran erinnert.
Ach, Monster Hunter World.
Ach so! Ähm...
Hab ich nicht gespielt.
Ich wollte das mit dem Friseur spielen,
aber da ist es nie dazu gekommen.
Ist nicht schlecht, okay.
Ja, aber da wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal dazu kommen,
dass ich das mit dem Friseur spiele.
Der Friseur spielt ja aktuell lieber Mobile Games.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass Shadowplay
very buggy on PC ist. Shadowplay funktioniert
wunderbar.
Aber er ist nicht in der ersten Position.
Der andere Clip, den er veröffentlicht hat, war
an Operation Locker und ist ein sehr
zufriedenstellender 11-Mann-Spraydown
mit der MG4 in der Support-Klasse.
Oh, der Hintergrund-Chat, Leute!
Hört ihr das?
Bekommen wir das am Start?
Ist Laggy das neue Blackscreen
von damals, wenn der Aimbot
zu hohen FoF hat? Habe ich mir noch nie
Gedanken drüber gemacht. Ähm, man könnte das
allerdings sicherlich gut verstecken.
Ich dachte immer, oh Leute, es ruckelt gerade!
Es ruckelt gerade! Oh, jetzt schön, wenn der Aimbot ausschaltet.
X-22...
Gibt's den Kram überhaupt noch?
Warum ist denn das so laut?
Ja, Gimps mit Diamond-Plus, User!
Die Gegner sind immer wieder absolut auf Massive Brain ausgerichtet.
Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Den Clip kennen wir schon, Leute.
Oder?
Den Clip kennen wir schon, aber die anderen Clips kannte ich noch nicht.
Hat er die Clips etwa mehrfach verwendet?
Äh, Stellsor, wir haben doch ein Video gemacht, mal.
Wir haben, genau in dieser Konstellation haben wir mal ein Video aufgenommen.
Das ist schon ewig her.
Das ist auch absolut, das war auch übel, das war garantiert gestellt.
Also, entweder, entweder stand er den ganzen Tag da und hat immer in die gleiche Richtung auf der gleichen Mapsmores gespammt,
oder das war gestellt.
Ich tendiere zu gestellen.
Ja, da haben wir danach, außer Michael, außer darüber zu sprechen, haben wir nichts mehr gemacht in der Zeit.
Aber dazu müsste ich erstmal eh Videos machen auf YouTube.
What?
Hat er gerade gesagt, er ist nicht mehr drin?
Oh, nice!
Huge, huge Snipe.
Die Reaktion HD wird auf Operation Locker gespielt, aber er benutzt keine Waffe.
So ist er auf einem Quad-Bike.
Schaut mal, was er danach macht.
Wo gibt's denn auf Locker überhaupt einen Quad?
Ach, das ist Conquest.
Okay.
Gibt es auf Conquest Quads?
Drop!
Ah, yes, excellent, Chat.
Der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Ich fährte hier einfach durch und machte Blood.
Hahaha!
Das ist geil.
Haha!
Oh Gott, sind die...
Die Gegner, Alter!
Okay, ey.
Also entweder war das gestellt, glaube ich in dem Fall nicht,
oder die Gegner sind einfach komplett beschränkt.
Oder...
Oder aber sie wollten eben den Clip nicht versauen.
Nein, gerade...
Gerade...
Gerade wo er hier gegen die Wand fährt, ne?
Gerade wo er hier gegen die Wand fährt.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Jetzt fährt er hier gegen die Wand.
Der Typ ist down.
Guck mal.
Der kann rückwärts fahren.
Da schießt nicht einer auf ihn.
Was ist mit den Gegnern los?
Komplett lost, die Gegner.
Oh, cool.
Ich bin mir irgendwie nicht sicher, ob wir das nicht schon mal gesehen haben.
Ich muss nämlich sagen, der, der, der, das von den Rohren, das runtergeschossene, kam mir voll bekannt vor.
Der Quad, der Quadkill kam mir nicht bekannt vor.
Und den Quadkill, also mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Quad, also nicht der Quad, Quad, also ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ähm, den hätte ich mir gemerkt.
Okay.
Ja gut, es ist Metro in Battlefield 4.
Das Spiel kommt auch.
Oh, da werden sie weggesprayt.
Da werden sie weggesprayt.
Back to good old Operation Locker.
And a clip sent in from Dexter, who's going absolutely mental with the AEK 971.
Real meat grinder stuff here on Operation Locker.
As he is pushed by so many enemy players.
Ich sehe überhaupt keine Gegner.
Gets the advantage of spotting.
Ich habe überhaupt nicht erkannt.
Absolutely mental with the AEK 971.
Real meat grinder stuff here on Operation Locker.
As he is pushed by so many enemy players.
Spotting FTW.
Gets the advantage of spotting there through the smoke.
Which is not something I really enjoy too much in BF4.
Doch, ich enjoye das richtig in Battlefield 4.
Da muss man einfach nur richtig stehen und dann werden die Gegner weggebashed.
Bam, ba-ba-bam.
... to play in BF5.
But then again, I don't know.
Again, it does make players more visible and you can have a bit more fun that way.
A great clip so far, racking up over 1300 points.
Pushing towards this section of the map he is playing to.
Also, das Spotten...
Kann sich noch einer daran erinnern, wie das Spotten in Bad Company 1 war?
Das war ja leider in einem Console-Only-Release.
Das Spotten in Bad Company 1 war nahezu komplett useless.
Du musstest den Gegner irgendwie 10 Sekunden oder so durch Scope anschließen.
Und dann gucken, wo es ganz praktisch war mit dem Fernglas.
Ja.
Können die nämlich einfach eine Granate reinwerfen?
Welche Bewegungsmelder gab es auch noch?
Ja.
Die Waffe sieht man sehr.
Heute sind viele Lockerclips dabei.
Ganz ehrlich, in dieser Situation muss ich überhaupt nicht lange überlegen, was ich mache.
Ich spraye einfach so lang in die Gegner rein.
Bis die gecheckt haben, wo ich bin und mich schon pre-firen und dann gehe ich weg.
Aber die Gegner haben keinen Bock, ihn zu pre-firen.
Oder zumindest, was heißt so pre-firen, zumindest mal in die Richtung zu gucken, wo er gleich herkommt.
Das ist zu advanced für das Gegner-Brain.
Das war so ein nices Game.
Persönlich ist mir Bad Company 2 und Battlefield 3 immer noch ein Ticken lieber, aber Battlefield 4 ist mittlerweile echt da ganz gut oben mit dabei.
Leider gab es danach kein Battlefield mehr für mich, was mir gefallen hat.
Das ist die, Leute, ähm, das ist die Pickup-Sniper, oder?
Ja, ich hab's jetzt grad nicht mehr gekonnt. Das ist die, die man aufsammeln muss.
Äh, Michael, das ist eine richtig gute Idee. Das hatten wir schon vor ein paar Streams.
Aber dazu müsste ich halt erstmal Videos machen.
Auch noch eine, die gleiche Position, mit einem Lauf von sehr blinden Gegnern, die den Stürzschlag campen.
Er drückt durch und weckt sie alle.
Du du du, du du du, du du du.
Moving on, we have WoeGaming, and he's gonna be playing on Operation Locker with the AUG, or the AUG, however you like to pronounce it.
Now he's going on a bit of a killstreak.
He's running around, getting himself a selection of kills and enemies that really aren't up to the task of stopping him.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, Michael. Du hast vollkommen recht, dass die Videos nicht großer Aufwand wären.
Ähm, aber ich krieg's ja auch schon jetzt gerade nicht in Videos zu machen, die auch nicht großer Aufwand wären.
Oder, Leute, kriegen wir jetzt mal Frage an den Chat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon gesehen habt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute von euch noch Battlefield 4 spielen.
Würden wir es schaffen, würden wir es schaffen, aus dem Chat eine Battlefield Top Place Montage zu machen, die, sagen wir mal so, 6-7 Minuten geht.
Battlefield 3, also alles, alles bis Battlefield 1, ja.
Alles, alles bis Battlefield 1.
Okay, okay, wir, okay, Leute, wir machen das.
Wir machen das.
Ähm, ich überleg grad, wie man das, ähm, ich überleg grad, wie man das am besten machen.
Ich bräuchte irgendeinen Google Docs, ne?
Irgendeinen Google Docs, wo man den Kram, ähm, ja, es muss ja auch keiner sich installieren und spielen.
Ähm, wenn wir das, wenn wir das vielleicht machen, wir machen das ja vielleicht dann auch öfters, wenn das jetzt, wenn das jetzt gut funktioniert.
Lass ruhig erstmal die Leute einschicken, die schon fertige Clips haben.
Wir machen das jetzt.
Also, ich leg jetzt mal einen Google Docs an.
Docs.
Oh, fuck, ich muss mich erstmal einloggen.
Monkites.
Und dann uns, oh nee, uns, uns streamen schneiden, da kann ich uns streamen nicht.
Vielleicht, okay, Docs, Docs, Docs, Docs, Google Docs.
Ähm, ja, login.
Next.
Äh, looks, remind me later.
So, ich leg jetzt mal ein Google Docs Dokument an, äh, wo man den Kram eintragen kann.
In der Zwischenzeit lass ich mal kurz das hier weiterlaufen, dass ich was zu gucken hab.
In Battlefield 4.
Getting kicked or banned by an angry admin.
I am, of course, being sarcastic.
It really does suck.
But it happens all the time and there's not a whole lot you can do about it.
A nice flip-flop as he does rack up a serious amount of kills.
I have edited it in some places because it's a lot longer this streak than I'd like to have on the top plays nonetheless.
It's a great bit of infantry gameplay.
Forms, brauner, forms.
Okay, okay.
Also, wir machen das so, Leute.
Ich leg jetzt, ich leg eine Google Forms an.
Ähm, und, ähm, das Einzige, was man eintragen muss, ist quasi, äh, Autor, Spieler, Spieler,
beziehungsweise Link, äh, Link zum YouTube-Channel oder so, was ich verlinken soll.
Und, ähm, den Link zum Download.
Das reicht ja im Endeffekt auch, ne?
Ähm, muss ich mal kurz, nur mal kurz gucken, wie ich das mache, äh.
Question?
Der Eichler hostet mich jetzt.
Gibt's dich auch noch, der Eichler?
Lange nicht gesehen, auch.
Link gehört auf Twitter.
Äh, äh, nicht Twitter, Dings hier, äh, Twitch.
Der Eichler ist am Start.
Ähm.
Natürlich, Michael, selbstverständlich.
Ich muss grad nochmal kurz, okay.
Denn die Form, äh, BF-Top-Plays, Max-FPS, BF-Top-Plays, Gameplay 1 schicken.
So.
Ähm, Dame, äh, Short-Answer, Verlinkung und Options.
Nose is next up, with an incredibly accurate sniping clip.
Äh, Options, Link zum Gameplay.
Okay.
Probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Ich weiß, dass der Eichler, ich fand's so cool, weil ich grad gesehen hab, dass du mich gehostet hast.
Okay, ähm, ich speicher die Form mal.
Black Cube 001 is next up on Nansha's strike.
Getting himself a couple of very awesome...
Wie, wie speichern wir hier?
Safe?
Nee.
Ich bin zu dumm, Google Forms zu bedienen, Leute.
Das ist, das ist unglaublich.
Share link.
Copy.
Okay, mal gucken.
Mal gucken, Leute, mal gucken, ob die Form funktioniert.
Massive.
Okay, Shorten, Shorten-Url ist besser.
Okay.
Test, testen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Name, Max, Verlinkung, äh, Link zum Gameplay, blub, blub, blub.
Submit.
Äh.
Äh, ähm, okay, your response has been recorded.
Wo seh ich denn jetzt, äh, wer darauf geantwortet hat?
Also, Leute, es hat keinen Sinn, da jetzt was drauf zu, zu, zu, zu machen, wenn man...
Ah, Responses, ich hab's.
Easy.
Na super.
Nice.
Moment, das funktioniert nicht, das ist kaputt.
Ich glaube, oh, oh, ich glaube, ich hab's falsch gemacht.
Wenn ich jetzt nämlich hier Max 2 eingebe, Verlinkung, äh, äh...
Äh, keine Ahnung, google.de, dann seh ich nicht, wer von was erstellt hat.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, nee, das ist kaputt, das geht nicht.
Ich kann damit nix anfangen.
Shit.
Alter, ich, das gibt's nicht.
Ich bin zu, ich bin zu dumm für Google, für, für Google Forms, Alter.
Oh, Mann.
Wobei, doch, natürlich bringt mir die Antwort was.
Doch, klar, funktioniert.
Alles gut, funktioniert, Leute.
Eats.
Ja, Link.
Ich hab gerade...
Okay, also Leute, wenn ihr Clips habt, könnt ihr, könnt ihr einschicken.
Ich schick euch nochmal in Chat den, den Link.
Shared, Link.
So.
Also, wer Clips hat, haut rein.
Ähm, wie viele Clips, ihr dürft, ihr dürft so viele Clips senden.
Also, nee, nee, nee, nee, das mach ich nicht.
Chat, ich, ich weiß es.
Maximal erstmal fünf Clips pro Person, weil, ähm, ich will ein bisschen Variation drinne haben.
Und sonst, sonst, sonst wird's zu viel.
Ähm, maximal erstmal fünf Clips.
Was ihr machen könnt ist, was ihr machen könnt ist, ähm, ihr könnt, wenn ihr mehrere Clips habt,
mal angenommen, ihr habt irgendwie richtig geile, richtig geile, ähm, 30 Sekunden Clips oder sowas, ja.
Ähm, dann könnt ihr die, die zusammen, zusammen machen zu, keine Ahnung, so zwei, drei Minuten Clip und den als einzelnen Clip hochladen.
Ähm, haben wir einen Mod am Start?
Haben wir irgendeinen Mod am Start, der, ah, der Serious Max ist da.
Könntest du ein, ein, äh, Command, ein, ein Bot-Command erzeugen, wenn du weißt, wie das funktioniert?
Zu dem Form.
Maximale Länge pro Clip.
Ähm, naja, nachdem's, nachdem's kurze Clips, also, Top Plays sind, sollte das mit, sagen wir so, maximal so zwei Minuten gehen.
Kommt, also halt ein zusammenhängender Clip, wo gebasht wird.
Ne komplette Runde muss man machen.
Muss man da nicht schicken.
Ne komplette Runde muss man da nicht schicken.
Und es sollte schon so geschnitten sein, dass ich da nicht erst noch ne halbe Stunde an jedem Clip rumeditieren muss.
Also, das sollte ungefähr dort anfangen, wo das gute Game, wo das gute Play kommt.
Und, äh, da ungefähr aufhören, wo das gute Play zu Ende ist.
Ein bisschen kürzen kann ich's immer noch.
Oh, das wird geil, da hab ich echt Bock drauf jetzt.
Äh, wie soll der heißen?
Äh, nennen wir's, äh, Chat, gute Idee.
Nennen wir's, äh, Play.
Äh, Battlefield, äh, BF Place.
B, ja, BF, Battlefield, äh, wir machen ein gutes, kurzes Command.
Battle Place, oh, Battle Place ist cool.
Battle Place, Comfix kennt sich aus, äh.
Mach, mach Ausrufezeichen Battle Place, das find ich gut.
Das ist huge.
Okay, soll ich mal funktionieren, soll ich mal gucken, ob da Leute, ja, es haben schon Leute was eingeschickt hier.
Ja, Responses.
Von Foxditzen.
Link zum Gameplay.
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob die ganzen Sachen funktionieren.
Wahrscheinlich hat er jetzt einen Rig, Rigroll eingeschickt.
Und Leute, seht davon ab, ich weiß, sobald man das sagt, machen's die Leute.
Seht davon ab, Blödsinn einzuschicken.
Ähm, wenn das nämlich zu viele Leute machen, wird das mit dem Video nix.
Und außerdem, derjenige, der Fakes einschickt, über den bin ich zumindest nicht erfreut.
Wenn er mir dann noch weiter im Chat auf den Sack geht, ball ich ihn.
Weil da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, quasi mir die einzelnen guten Sachen rauszusuchen zu müssen, zwischen Bullshit.
Ja.
Ähm, das muss nicht sein.
Muss man einen Google Account dafür haben?
Nee, brauchst du nicht.
So, das hat grad jemand eingeschickt.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Poop.
Oh, oh, mit, mit, mit Slow-Mo, mit Slow-Mo.
Okay, also, dann machen wir das.
Das ist eine coole Idee, da hab ich echt Bock drauf.
Man muss, man muss aber dazu sagen.
Ja, ist gleich mal ein Disclaimer.
Gleich, gleich, gleich mal ein Disclaimer.
Ähm, ich behalte mir vor, nicht alle Clips zu verwenden, die eingeschickt werden.
Also, es kann durchaus sein, dass wenn manche Clips nicht reinpassen, ich die nicht nehme.
Aber ich versuche alles soweit zu verarbeiten, wie es, äh, wie es kommt.
Sind Fail-Clips auch erlaubt?
Äh, kommt auf den Clip an, kann ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt schwer sagen.
Aber, ähm, vielleicht so als ein oder andere,
der ein oder andere Gag zwischendurch.
Ist das glaube ich schon ganz nice.
So.
Hier haben wir einen Link.
Sehr gut.
Huge.
Heißt das wirklich immer noch Untitled Form?
Nee.
MarkusFB, SBF, Top Plays.
Pock.
Nice.
Da hab ich Bock drauf.
Gucken wir mal, ob dabei was rumkommt.
Ähm.
Und dann, dann setze ich mich dran und machen.
Ich glaube, da freuen sich die Leute auf YouTube auch drüber.
Wenn es einfach mal wieder nice Battlefield, Battlefield Gameplays gibt.
So.
Also das ist, das ist eine coole Sache.
Das machen wir.
Und, ähm, wenn das dann, wenn das gut, wenn das, wenn das gut funktionieren sollte,
dann, äh, kriege ich bestimmt auch über YouTube ein paar, ein paar weitere Clips.
Ja.
Äh, ach so.
Äh, welche Spiele, also prinzipiell würde ich sagen, ähm,
erstmal alles bis Battlefield 1.
Allerdings, ich würde die Ausnahme machen, weil ich meine, es ist immerhin Battlefield.
Ich hätte auch keinen Schmerzen damit, äh, ab und zu einen Battlefield 1 oder einen
Battlefield 5 Clip reinzumachen.
Aber ich würde gerne mal so die ersten 1, 2 Folgen oder zumindest die erste Folge erstmal,
ähm, erstmal gucken, wie es, wie es, wie es ankommt.
Also, ähm, wenn ihr richtig geile.
Also sowas hier in der Richtung, wie wir uns hier angeguckt haben, ähm, in Battlefield
1 und 5 habt oder Hardline oder was auch immer, könnt ihr die auch erstmal posten.
Ich persönlich habe mehr Bezug zu Battlefield 3, 4 und Bad Company.
Aber wenn ihr richtig, richtig krasse Battlefield 1, äh, oder Battlefield 5 oder Hardline oder
sonst was Clips habt, könnt ihr die auch posten.
Und dann muss ich mal gucken, was wir, was wir da draus machen.
Poggers.
Schauen wir mal.
Also mit Ausrufezeichen, ähm, was war's?
Battle Place.
Kriegt ihr den Link zum Formular.
Ähm, wenn ich mit dem Stream fertig bin, schreibe ich noch, schreibe ich vielleicht noch irgendwie
was drunter.
Ähm, was genau, kann man da irgendwie noch ne, ah hier, Battlefield, ok, ich schreib,
ich schreib nochmal oben drüber.
Ähm.
Ähm, was man, äh, was, was man da für Gameplays.
Also, Gameplays sollten von, sagen wir mal so, 30 Sekunden bis, äh, 2 Minuten pro Clip,
äh, also pro Clip 30 Sekunden bis 2 Minuten, äh, alle Battlefield Games erlaubt.
Bevorzu, ne, bevorzu, aber gar nicht.
Alle Battlefield Games erlaubt.
Ihr wisst, dass ich persönlich halt mehr Bezug habe zu den älteren Teilen.
Ähm, aber, und ich kann halt auch vor allem ältere Teilen etwas besser kommentieren,
weil ich halt das Game kenne.
Ähm, bevorzugt die älteren vor BF1.
Hallo, ich kann nicht mal richtig tippen.
Die älteren vor Battlefield 1.
Ok, gut.
Fehlt noch ne, ne Spalte, naja, du kannst, du kannst deinen Namen eintragen, die Verlinkung, äh,
achso, bei Verlinkung, das sollte ich vielleicht aktualisieren.
Mit Verlinkung ist gemeint, den Channel, also was ich von euch verlinken soll.
Äh, das aktualisieren wir nochmal schnell.
Spielername, ähm, Spieler Channel oder, Spieler Channel oder Link oder, oder, äh, äh,
ne, nicht Profil, wie nenn ich das denn?
Spieler, äh, Link, Link für Credits, ha?
Credits, sowas oder was man.
Für die Credits.
Link zum Gameplay, ok, sehr gut.
Ok, jetzt sollte, sollte es eigentlich funktionieren.
Äh, hat sich der, hat sich der Link jetzt geändert dadurch, dass ich die, den, die Form geändert hab?
Ne, ist immer noch.
Ist das, ist der Link jetzt anders als vorher?
Als vorher?
Oh Gott, ich und Google Docs, äh, ich und Google Docs.
Na klar ist der Link anders, ich seh das doch sofort, äh.
Der Link ist nicht der gleiche.
Ich hab grad den neuen Link gepostet, äh.
Ok, perfekt, ok, jetzt funktioniert.
Ok, dann ist egal, dann, dann lass, dann lass das so, dann lass so.
Ok, mal gucken.
Tatsächlich, ok, dann ist egal.
Wunderbar.
Was ist mit sieben Kills in zehn Sekunden?
Na klar, hau rein, hau rein.
Hau rein.
Im Zweifelsfall spiel ich den Klick, den Clip einfach doppelt ab.
Oder du machst noch ein bisschen was da vorne.
Schickt einfach mal ein.
Erstmal nicht so sehr, nicht so hundertprozentig das, was ich reingeschrieben hab.
Wenn's ein bisschen plus, minus paar Sekunden ist, ist auch nicht so wild.
Hauptsache, dass wir ein bisschen Gameplays zusammen kriegen.
Und dann schau ich mal, was man draus machen kann.
Gucken wir uns den Rest hiervon noch an.
Ach ja, übrigens, Plattform ist mir auch egal.
Boah, na gut, also...
Das war nice.
91 Kills in total, mit über 5 KPM.
Und wir bekommen nicht oft Killstreaks in die Top Plays,
weil ich sie nicht wirklich posten kann.
Es ist ziemlich schwierig, eine 15-Minuten-Gameplay zu posten,
auch wenn es vielleicht großartig sein könnte.
Also habe ich das einfach in ein paar meiner Lieblingspartien gesplittet.
Ihr könnt euch das ganze Video auf seinem Kanal anschauen.
Er hat viele Gameplays da für das Attackjet.
Lasst mir wissen, was ihr von dem in den Kommentaren denkt.
Würdet ihr, dass ich größere Killstreaks am Ende der Episoden veröffentliche?
Vielleicht einen 10-Minuten-Killstreak oder so.
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen seltsam, das zu posten,
weil es nicht einen Kommentar hat.
Es ist fast wie ein Content von jemand anderem,
der am Ende meines Videos veröffentlicht wird.
Aber wenn ihr noch weitere Clips in den Top Plays sehen wollt,
dann bin ich sehr froh, sie zu posten.
Ich habe dieses Clip von Anfang bis Ende gesehen.
Und ich muss sagen, er ist ein sehr guter Attackjet-Pilot,
der mit diesem Q5-Phantom verwendet wird,
um fast alles hinzuzufügen, was er kann.
Und einer der besten Jetmaps im Spiel.
Ein wirklich guter.
Ja, vielleicht ist er auch außer Wasser nicht vieles.
Danke fürs Zuschauen dieses Episodes von den Top Plays von Battlefield 4.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, lasst mir einen Daumen nach unten wissen.
50 Minuten 90 Killstreaks.
Ähm...
Das ist zu lang.
Da musst du...
Dann schneid...
Dann schneid doch einfach das Beste raus.
Ja, du kannst auch ohne Probleme da eine 2 Minuten Montage draus machen.
Also eine Montage in Form von halt,
dass du 2 Minuten lang die besten Clips da rausschneidest.
Das ist auch okay.
Aber ich will halt nicht aus 50...
Weil da komm ich...
Da komm ich...
Da wär ich ja nie fertig mit dem Video.
Ich will nicht aus 50 Minuten mir das selbst raussuchen müssen.
So I know you enjoy the Battlefield 4 Top Plays.
I don't post a whole lot of them, but it's nice to know
some people are enjoying them at least.
Remember to send your clips in to battlefieldtopplayers.gmail.com
and I'll catch you in the next episode.
Ach ja.
Stimmt.
Das muss ich noch reinposten.
Keine Musik.
Wenn da...
Wenn da Copyright Musik im Hintergrund ist, kann ich nicht verwenden.
Oder...
Oder ohne Sounds.
Aber ohne Sounds ist doof.
Ähm...
Das muss ich noch unbedingt reinschreiben.
Summary.
Keine Copyright...
Nee.
Überhaupt keine...
Keine Musik im Hintergrund.
Sonst YouTube Strike von K.S.
Fuck.
Ok, ich hab noch mal eingetragen.
Ist sind ohne Sounds ok.
Es ist zwar nicht schön, aber wenn's ein geiler...
richt...
nicer Clip ist, geht's auch ohne Sound.
Jetzt sagt er nix mehr, oder was?
Weil...
er nichts mehr oder was, weil er gemeint hat, eben
Clip ohne Commentary. Der kann auch
sein Standard-Gezeug hier wieder
ablassen.
Kyokunas war mir klar.
Aber auch bitte
kein Hentai im Hintergrund.
Einfach nicht,
was Copyright-Probleme macht im Hintergrund.
Was ist denn ein gutes
Schnittprogramm, wo ich nichts zahlen muss,
wegen Ausprobieren und so?
Keine Ahnung.
Da Vinci Resolve, ist das nicht übertrieben kompliziert?
Kannst einfach mit FFM-Pack was
wegschneiden vorher. Musst du nicht mal re-encoden.
Okay, da kommen die wirklich nicht mehr.
Ey, das ist ja langweilig.
Das ist ja blöd.
So, ich sehe schon, die ersten
Einsendungen sind am Start hier.
Die ersten Einsendungen
sind am Start.
Tribolon, genau solche
Clips meine ich.
Genau sowas.
Einfach eine Minute lang, wo die Gegner
gebasht werden.
Huge.
Zeigt mal den Clip.
Den Clip gibt es dann im Video.
Da können wir uns die Clips
alle im Video, hier im Stream angucken.
Ist ja auch doof.
Aber Michael, ich muss sagen, das war eine gute Idee.
Vielleicht komme ich so dazu,
mal wieder eine Runde YouTube-Videos zu machen.
Je nachdem, wie viele Clips
heute noch kommen.
Vielleicht auch, vielleicht heute noch.
Also zumindest das Video aufnehmen.
Aber ich glaube, dafür haben wir nicht genug.
Kann man ein bisschen, ein bisschen, äh,
zu wenig Leute, die noch Battlefield spielen,
auf, ähm...
Bekommst du 3k Q-Chat-Punkte?
Würde ich dir geben, aber man kann leider
keine Punkte giften.
Ah, letztes Video ist ja schon wieder
ewig her.
Vier Monate, Alter. Vier Monate.
Ähm, bevor ich aufgehe,
Leute. Ich bin jetzt ja schon eine ganze
Weile am Start, ne. Bevor ich aufgehe,
wollen wir
das erst mal...
Wollen wir das erst mal
Twitch-only lassen?
Oder soll ich's auf Twitter posten?
Das Formular.
Was meint ihr?
Wollen wir erst mal gucken, ob, ob wir
mit Twitch, Twitch und, und, ähm,
Battlefield-Spielern hier auf Twitch
die erste Folge vollkriegen?
Ich würde sagen, wir gucken erst mal,
was zusammenkommt.
Hier über, über Twitch.
Oder was meint ihr, Chat?
Warum geht der Link nicht mehr? Äh...
Wut?
Der Link geht nicht mehr? Och.
Der Link geht noch.
Guck hier.
Der Link geht.
Quatsch mit so so Posten, also...
Leute, könnt ihr mal probieren,
ob der Link bei euch geht? Also bei mir ist kein,
kein Problem.
Funktioniert. Geht bei mir.
Du lebst ja noch. Ja.
Das ist der Link, in den du deinem
Linux einrichtest. Ja gut, ey.
Keine Ahnung,
warum der nicht mehr geht. Wahrscheinlich ist das Video zu alt.
Keck.
W.
Geht, geht, geht.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Was bringen die Q-Chat-Punkte?
Du kannst mit den Q-Chat-Punkten zum Beispiel
deine Nachricht hervorheben lassen hier.
So zum Beispiel.
Das ist eigentlich ein ganz cooles Twitch-Feature.
50.000 Q-Chat-Punkte.
Eieiei. Dafür könntest
ihr ja fast schon mal eine Maske hier bestellen.
Ne, leider kriegt man von Q-Chat-Punkt...
Leider gibt es keine Möglichkeit,
Q-Chat-Punkte in
echte, in Cent umzurechnen.
Dann hätte ich
bei, ich glaube bei Dance-Gaming habe ich auch schon
irgendwie 60k oder irgendwie 50k
oder irgendwie massig, ja.
Aber ich finde, das ist eine echt
gute, gute Idee mit dem
mit dem Battlefield.
Wer kam eben
nochmal auf die Idee Battle-Plays
zu machen? Irgendwas mit C
glaube ich am Anfang. Wer kam
da eben nochmal auf die Idee?
Comfix?
War das Comfix?
Ah hier, Comfix 21, genau.
Wie bist du auf die Idee gekommen?
Einfach spontan, oder?
Oder gibt es das schon?
Battle-Plays.
Ne, nicht wirklich, oder?
Nichts großartiges, bekanntes.
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Aber das ist eine gute Idee gewesen.
Okay, ähm.
Leute, es war schön, dass
so viele dabei waren heute.
Ähm.
Mal schauen wir mal, ob das mit den Clips,
ob da was zusammenkommt.
Wenn nicht, werde ich im nächsten Stream nochmal ein bisschen
das ganze rumpasten und ein bisschen
erwähnen. Denkt an Ausrufezeichen
Battle-Plays gibt's den
Link zum Formular.
Hoffentlich kommen die
Top-Plays gut an, dann kannst du ja auch auf Youtube nach Clips fragen.
Jaja, ich mach das dann auf jeden Fall auf Youtube
in die ähm
äh, in das Kommentar
von dem Video. Aber wir müssen erstmal
initial, guck mal oben rechts, oben rechts
ha?
Oben rechts, Essen.
Immer oben rechts, Essen.
Das ist doch, das ist doch schön, Michael.
Auch wenn es wahrscheinlich debated ist.
Aber es ist schön,
wenn's dir gefällt. Ähm, und äh
mir gefällt's auch.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt am Ende.
Soll ich's mal in Discord pausen? Kannst du machen.
Kannst du, ist ne gute Idee. Kannst du machen.
Ähm, kann man im Discord irgendwas
pinnen? Mega-Quest.
Der Name kommt mir noch bekannt vor. Gibt's den noch?
Der kommt mir bekannt vor.
Der Name.
Jo, Leute.
Okay, gibt's den halt nicht mehr.
Musst du oder Sibaro machen was pinnen?
Okay, das probier ich jetzt mal aus im Discord.
Ob man das pinnen kann.
Gucken, wie man Sachen im Discord pinnt. Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Erstmal alle Updates installieren.
Leute, ich muss euch mal ausblenden.
Wer weiß, in welchem Fenster
ich im Discord gerade rauskomme, ähm.
Oh.
Oh. Okay, passt.
Man weiß ja nie.
Okay, allgemein.
Ähm.
Achso.
Hat eine nach, ah, es ging doch, oder?
Und wo sieht man das jetzt angepinnt?
Ach, hier. Ah.
Okay, nice.
Nice, sehr schön.
Huge. Sehr nice.
Ähm, ja, mal gucken, was so alles zusammenkommt.
Schauen wir mal.
Haben ja schon einige Leute geschrieben,
die sind noch aktiv hier am Battlefield spielen.
Jetzt haben wir schon sechs, sechs
Einsendungen. Aber davon sind
zwei Stück, äh, oder drei Stück von mir
vom Testen. Äh, ich habe insgesamt
sechs Anfragen, aber drei Stück sind von mir.
Vom, vom Testen.
Gucken wir mal. Wir haben ja ein bisschen Zeit. Ist ja nicht, ist ja nicht so, dass
das irgendwie jetzt über das Knie gebrochen werden muss.
Meins rennt halt gerade. Ja, wie gesagt.
Leute, ähm.
Wenn wir da genug zusammenkriegen,
nehme ich es vielleicht heute Mittag schon
auf. Aber ich denke mal, wir werden ein bisschen
länger Zeit brauchen, bis da genug zusammen sind.
Ich, ich lass mich mal überraschen.
Aber ich hab da auf jeden Fall jetzt
gerade spontan echt
Bock, das zu machen.
Wenn das mit den Gameplays hinhaut.
Peilst du dann so zehn Minuten an?
Ich würde, in dem Dreh.
Ich würde mal sagen, so fünf bis zehn Minuten.
Fünf bis zehn, also,
ähm, wenn ich über fünf Minuten
habe, würde ich aufnehmen.
Du willst doch nur
easy Views. Wer will das nicht?
Hast du echt nur vor, Battlefield
zu machen? Bevor ich mir über weitere Sachen
Gedanken mache, mache ich jetzt erstmal ein
Battlefield Topplay Video.
Vielleicht mache ich dann auch mal ein paar andere, aber
ich habe von dir schon fünf Minuten.
Ja, da muss ich gucken, dass noch ein paar
andere, paar andere Leute
eingestreut kriege, weil
nur von einem Spieler
die Hexe hat bestimmt auch noch
ein paar Sachen. Das kommt sowieso
in die Trends. Na, ich weiß ja nicht.
Was mache ich denn für, was mache ich denn für einen Sound
im Hintergrund? Einfach Battlefield Soundtrack am besten,
ne? Einfach Battlefield
Soundtrack im Hintergrund.
Ja, ein bisschen, ein bisschen,
ein bisschen Battlefield, ein bisschen Soundtrack im Hintergrund
ist der Sound von den Clips klar,
aber ein bisschen, ein bisschen im Hintergrund finde ich schon
nicht verkehrt. Oder,
ich weiß, was ich im Hintergrund mache.
Nein, das mache ich nicht wirklich im Hintergrund, aber
das wäre doch mal was.
Beste Battlefield Hintergrundmusik überhaupt.
Keck weh. Bad Company 1
oder Snowy Mountains von...
Was? Snowy Mountains? Du meinst Valparaiso
Snowy Mountains? Äh, du meinst Dings hier.
Achso, du meinst den
Soundtrack, oder was?
Äh, ja, ich werde schon was finden.
Ich werde schon, werde schon, werde schon
irgendwas ordentliches finden.
Ich werde schon garantiert was ordentliches finden.
Erstmal brauche ich Clips, dass das funktioniert.
Excellent.
Okay, Leute.
Also schon mal danke für alle,
die was einschicken.
Wenn ihr das Formular sucht,
Ausrufezeichen,
Battle Place,
dann zeigt euch der
Bot den Link zum Formular.
Heute noch jemand raiden,
das ist glaube ich keiner on, den ich
kenne.
Und der Viewer brauchen würde.
Haben wir da irgendjemand on?
Aber nicht.
Das war eskalierende.